THIS MEETING OF THE SENATE
HOUSING COMMITTEE -- TO ORDER
WELCOME EVERYONE -- TO THE FIRST --
SEND HOUSING COMMITTEE OF YEAR
WHAT WE'RE HEARING BILLS -- IF
FOLKS COULD PLEASE TURN OFF YOUR
CELL PHONES AND IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY CONVERSATIONS OR FEEL THE
NEED -- TO IF YOU COULD TAKE IT
OUTSIDE SO THAT WE CAN HEAR
TESTIMONY.
THIS IS OUR FIRST BILL HEARING
OF TWENTY NINETEEN SO WE WILL.
NEED TO BEGIN BY ADOPTING OUR
COMMITTEE RULES AND POLICIES
ONCE WE'VE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM --
THESE ARE STANDARD RULES -- THAT
HAVE BEEN CHANGED. TO USE -- NON
GENDER SPECIFIC LANGUAGE -- SO.
WHY DON'T WE -- ESTABLISH A
QUORUM FIRST.
SENATOR WIENER PRESENT WIENER
PRESENT MORRELL [inaudible]
BATES.
BATES PRESENT CABRERO.
SEVERAL PRESENT DORADO YES
DORADO PRESENT MCGUIRE.
MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE PRESENT ROUGH.
RAFI PRESENT SKINNER.
NUMBER GOOD BECAUSE HE OKAY WE
HAVE A QUORUM IS OUR MOTION.
OKAY CENTER ROTH HAS MOVED
ADOPTION OF THE COMMITTEE RULES
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION WELCOME
WILL HAVE TO CALL THE ROLL AND
THEN PUT IT ON CALLED SO -- IF
THERE'S NO DISCUSSION CALLING
SON WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE COMMITTEE RULES.
SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER HI MORRELL.
BATES ALRIGHT BATES I COVER.
CAN VERIFY DORADO -- ALSO HI
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE A FIVE ROUGH.
OFF I SKINNER.
AMBERG CASKEY.
HI KATHY AYE.
BUT THAT HAS SEVEN VOTES WHICH
IS ENOUGH TO PASS BUT WE'LL PUT
IT ON CALL FOR OUR MEMBERS WHO
WILL BE JOINING US.
SHORTLY.
SO WE HAVE A TOTAL OF FIFTEEN
BILLS TODAY. TWO OF WHICH ARE ON
CONSENT THIRTEEN OF THIRTEEN LOS.
MY APOLOGIES THIRTY BILLS TWO OF
WHICH ARE ON DEFENSE.
A DOUBLE COUNTED THERE -- SO WE
WILL -- START WITH THEIR CONSENT --
CALENDAR -- WHICH IS -- SB SIX
AND SB.
THREE THIRTY THREE OKAY IS THERE --
ANY OBJECTION TO THESE ITEMS
BEING -- HER ADULT DON'T CONSENT
OKAY BUT WE WILL THEN CALL THE
ROLL.
ON THE KANSEN COUNTER WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS FOUR IN
TEN SENATOR WIENER HI WIENER HI
MORRELL.
BATES RIGHT BATES HI CAMARO.
HI DRAWS -- HI DORADO HI MCGUIRE.
MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE HI ROUGH.
ROUGH I SKINNER.
AMBERG CASKEY.
HI [inaudible] SEVENTY OKAY --
THE VOTED SEVEN ZERO IT'S ENOUGH
TO PASS -- WE WILL PUT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ON CALL FOR OUR
MEMBERS WHO WILL BE JOINING US.
OKAY -- WE A START WITH OUR
SPECIAL ORDER WHICH ARE -- ITEMS
WANTED TO US BEFORE AND SB.
FIFTY FIVE CENTER MCGUIRE AND
SENATOR BELL WILL BE PRESENTING
US BEFORE AND WILL BE JOINING US
SHORTLY SO WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH SB -- FIFTY AND THEN WE'LL
GO TO US BEFORE AFTER THAT AND
THEN CONTINUE WITH THE REST --
OF THE FILE -- SO I WILL --
HANDS -- IT OVER.
TO SENATOR WHY CAL SKI --
BECAUSE THEIR MOISTURE IS NOT
HERE I DON'T KNOW IT'S A OR YOU
MIGHT HAVE TO YEAH I HAVE TO GO.
TO AND REGISTER.
BY SENATOR BATES WOULD YOU --
PROCEED BY PLEASE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
GREEN.
IT'S ALSO ALONG THANK YOU.
PLEASE RECEIVE THE FIVE THANK
YOU I CENTER BATES -- COLLEAGUES
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT.
SENATE BILL -- FIFTY THE MORE
HOMES ACT.
SB FIFTY ADDRESSES ONE OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL OBSTACLES TO HAVING
ENOUGH HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR EVERYONE WHO NEEDS A
SPECIFICALLY HYPER LOW DENSITY
ZONING.
THAT BANDS EVEN SMALL APARTMENT
BUILDINGS AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUILDINGS AND A HUGE MAJORITY OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HYPER LOW DENSITY ZONING OFTEN
IN THE FORM OF BANNING AND
PROHIBITING ALL FORMS OF HOUSING.
OTHER THAN SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
CALIFORNIA TO CLOSE OUR MASSIVE
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION HOME
DEFICIT.
IT PERPETUATE SEGREGATION.
IT PUSHES WORKING FAMILIES OUT
OF COMMUNITIES AND INTO MULTI
HOUR COMMUTES.
IT INCREASES FREEWAY CONGESTION
AND CARBON EMISSIONS.
AND IT MAKES HOUSING BRUTALLY
EXPENSIVE.
SB FIFTY SETS BASIC STANDARDS
FOR ZONING NEAR HIGH QUALITY
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
AND IN JOB CENTERS.
IT DOES SO BY LEGALIZING SMALL
TO MID SIZE MULTI UNIT HOUSING
IN AREAS THAT ARE WITHIN WALKING
DISTANCE OF HIGH QUALITY PUBLIC
TRANSIT.
AND JOB RICH AREAS.
AND IT DOES SO LOG.
ENSURING THAT CITIES CONTINUE TO
HAVE LOCAL CONTROL OVER MANY
IMPORTANT ISSUES. FOR EXAMPLE
THE APPROVAL PROCESS. FOR
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS CITIES WILL
RETAIN THAT FULL CONTROL.
WHETHER SEE C<c.cyan> CONDITIONAL</c>
USE DISCRETIONARY APPEAL
[inaudible]
DESIGN STANDARDS.
RULES AROUND DEMOLITIONS
RESTRICTIONS ON DEMOLITIONS.
ALL LOCAL CONTROL UNDER THIS
BILL.
THESE WILL CONTINUE TO BE ABLE.
TO CREATED IMPOSE IMPACT FEES
WHETHER FOR TRANSPORTATION OR
SEWERS OR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND CITIES WILL CONTINUE. TO BE
ABLE TO IMPOSE SETBACK
REQUIREMENTS MANY MANY ASPECTS
OF LOCAL LAND USE ON THEIR SB
FIFTY WILL CONTINUE TO BE UNDER
LOCAL CONTROL -- AS YOU CAN SEE
FROM THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
COLLEAGUES.
THE COALITION SUPPORTING THIS
BILL.
IS BROAD AND DIVERSE.
IT'S ONE OF THE FEW BILLS THAT
I'VE SEEN.
WITH ENDORSEMENTS FROM BOTH TE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE YOU DON'T SEE THAT VERY
OFTEN.
OUR INTEREST IS ALSO INCLUDE THE
BUILDING TRADES.
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUILDERS WHO BUILD.
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING FOR OUR LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS.
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
MAJOR ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
THE UC STUDENTS ASSOCIATION.
A A RP HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
DISABILITY RIGHTS RGANIZATIONS
AND A GROWING LIST OF MAYORS
COUNTY SUPERVISORS AND CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS.
WHO UNDERSTAND THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM?
ISN'T WORKING AND NEEDS REFORM.
AND THE BILL'S SIXTEEN CO
AUTHORS FROM ALL OVER THE STATE.
INCLUDE SOME OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S MOST LIBERAL
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS.
AND SOME OF THE MOST
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICANS.
SHOWING ONCE AGAIN THAT HOUSING
IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE.
WHETHER RED OR BLUE.
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE STRUGGLING
WITH HOUSING.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION ABOUT THIS BILL.
ABOUT HOW IT'S A SUPPOSE IT
COMPLETE STATE TAKEOVER OF LOCAL
LAND USE.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY FALSE.
AS I JUST DESCRIBED SB FIFTY
RETAINS ENORMOUS LOCAL DECISION
MAKING.
BUT IN ONE AREA OF STATEWIDE
IMPORTANCE DENSITY NEAR PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AND JOBS.
IT SETS A BASIC STANDARD.
OTHERS HAVE CLAIMED THAT SB
FIFTY IS AN ATTACK ON SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES.
THAT IS ALSO INACCURATE.
NOTHING IN SENATE BILL FIFTY
PREVENTS ANYONE FROM BUILDING OR
LIVING AND A SINGLE FAMILY HOME.
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
IN MY VIEW OR A GOOD THING.
BUT SO OUR APARTMENT BUILDINGS.
SB FIFTY ALLOWS SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES.
BUT IT MOVES US AWAY FROM
MANDATING THAT SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES ARE THE ONLY THING.
FEDERAL OUT TO BE BUILT -- NEAR
TRANSIT OUR JOBS YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO BUILD VARIOUS KINDS OF
HOUSING NOT JUST ONE TYPE.
SO WHY FOCUS ON ZONING DENSITY
NEAR TRANSCEND JOBS.
WALL ZONING ISN'T THE ONLY
IMPEDIMENT. TO CALIFORNIA MEDIAN
HOUSING NEEDS WE ALSO NEED
FINANCIAL INVESTMENT IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE NEED STRONGER TENANT
PROTECTIONS.
WE NEED FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
HELP CITIES ENGAGE IN GOOD
PLANNING AND SO FORTH.
ZONING IS FOUNDATIONAL.
YOU CAN UP ALL OF THE INVESTMENT
AND STREAMLINING IN THE WORLD.
BUT IF IT'S A LEGAL IF IT IS
PROHIBITED TO BUILD ENOUGH
HOUSING.
THEN YOU'RE SORT OF STOCK.
AND 80% APPROXIMATELY OF THE
RESIDENTIAL LEASE ON LAND IN
CALIFORNIA AND ABOUT 70% EVEN IN
BIG CITIES LIKE SAN FRANCISCO
AND LOS ANGELES.
IT IS ILLEGAL TO BUILD ANYTHING
OTHER THAN A SINGLE FAMILY HOME
OR MAYBE A TWO UNIT BUILDING.
THAT MANS IT'S ILLEGAL TO BUILD
EVEN A THREE FOUR FIVE OR SIX
UNIT SMALL APARTMENT BUILDING
ILLEGAL IN THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT MEANS IT'S ILLEGAL TO BUILD
MULTI UNIT SENIOR HOUSING.
ILLEGAL TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
BECAUSE THAT IS INHERENTLY MULTI
UNIT.
AND WHAT DOES THIS RESTRICTIVE
ZONING MEAN FOR CALIFORNIA.
THAT MAKES IT ALL BUT IMPOSSIBLE
TO CLOSE OUR THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION HOME DEFICIT.
IT'S BASIC MATH.
IF YOU SAY THAT YOU CAN ONLY
BUILD ONE UNIT PER PARCEL IN THE
VAST MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO MEET YOUR
HOUSING GOALS AD IF YOU DO.
YOU'RE GOING TO DO IT BY
CREATING MORE AND MORE SPRAWL
COVERING UP FARMLAND AND OPEN
SPACE AND CLOGGING OUR FREEWAYS
AN INCREASING CARBON EMISSIONS.
AND CREATING A GROWING CLASS OF
SUPER COMMUTERS WHO SPENT FOUR
OR FIVE HOURS A DAY.
ON THE ROAD.
THIS HOUSING SHORTAGE WHICH IS
SELF INFLICTED IN MANY WAYS HAS
REAL LIFE CONSEQUENCES FOR
PEOPLE IT PUSHES PEOPLE IN THE
POVERTY AND HOMELESSNESS.
AT SPIKE'S EVICTIONS AND
DISPLACEMENT.
IT IT IS A PROBLEM AND WE HAVE
TO ADDRESS A AND WE WILL NEVER
MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
IF WE CONTINUE TO HAVE PAPER LOW
DENSITY ZONING NEAR JOBS IN
TRANSIT.
ALL WE WILL DO IS FORCE PEOPLE
TO COMMUTE LONG HOURS.
AND INCREASED CARBON EMISSIONS.
SB FIFTY ADDRESSES THIS PROBLEM
IN A THOUGHTFUL AND BALANCED WAY.
OVER THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF.
A WE HAVE WORKED WITH A BROAD
SPECTRUM OF STAKEHOLDERS.
INCLUDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INTENDED ADVOCATES. FOR PROFIT
AND NOT FOR PROFIT HOUSING
DEVELOPERS.
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
LABOR UNIONS STUDENTS RELIGIOUS
LEADERS AND DISABILITY AND
SENIOR ADVOCATES. TO CRAFT A
BILL TO MOVE THE DIAL ON HOUSING.
SO THAT WE MOVE AWAY FROM
HOUSING ANXIETY AND TOWARD
HOUSING ACTION.
SB FIFTY PROVIDES AN AREAS
WITHIN A HALF A MILE OF FIXED
RAIL OR FERRIES STOPS.
WITHIN A QUARTER MILE OF A HIGH
FREQUENCY BUS STOP WHICH MUST
RUN FROM EARLY MORNING INTO THE
NIGHT SEVEN DAYS A WEEK AT A
HIGH FREQUENCY.
OR IN A JOB RICH AREA.
THE CITY COULD NOT PUT AN
ARBITRARY CAP ON DENSITY BY
MANDATING FOR EXAMPLE ONLY ONE
OR TWO UNITS ARE ALLOWED ON THE
PARCEL.
THE CITY ALSO CANNOT FORCE A
HEIGHT LIMIT LOWER THAN FOUR OR
FIVE STORIES.
IN THE AREAS AROUND FIX RAIL OR
FURRY.
OF COURSE BASIC GEOMETRY AND THE
BUILDING CODE PUT A NATURAL
LIMIT ON DENSITY.
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH SPACE AND
THERE ARE BASIC REQUIREMENTS
UNDER THE BUILDING CODE.
BUT WE WILL MOVE AWAY FROM THE
ARBITRARY NUMERICAL COPS.
BOB PLEASE NOTE THAT I
ORIGINALLY LAST YEAR HAD IN EACH
STORY OPTION IN THE BILL AND WE
REMOVED THAT.
LISTENING TO CONSTRUCTIVE
FEEDBACK SOME THE SUMMER ON
HAPPY THAT WE REMOVE THAT BUT
SOME WERE VERY HAPPY -- AROUND
THE BUS STOPS AND JOB RICH AREAS
THE BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE
ABILITY OF CITIES TO ENFORCE
LOCAL HEIGHT LIMITS.
MORE SETBACKS.
SO IF THE LOCAL HEIGHT LIMIT IS
THIRTY FEET THAT HEIGHT LIMIT WE
WILL BE ADOPTED EFFECTIVELY BY
SB.
FIFTY BUT INSTEAD OF BEING
MANDATED TO ONLY BUILD SINGLE
FAMILY YOU COULD BUILD LET'S SAY
THREE FLAT.
MULTI UNIT OR SIX TWO PER STORY.
THE BUILDING WOULD LOOK THE SAME
FROM THE OUTSIDE.
THE SAME HEIGHT SAME SETBACK BUT
INSIDE IT WOULD HELL'S MORE
FAMILIES.
ALSO IN RESPONSE TO FEEDBACK
FROM TEN ADVOCATES.
THIS BILL NOW CONTAINS.
AMONG THE STRONGEST PERHAPS THE
STRONGEST TENER PROTECTIONS THAT
EXIST UNDER STATE LAW.
SPECIFICALLY.
IF A TENANT HAS RESIDED ON THE
PROPERTY AT ANY POINT IN TIME IN
THE LAST SEVEN YEARS.
YOU CANNOT GET A DEMOLITION
PERMIT TO BUILD UNDER THIS BILL.
EVEN IF YOUR LOCAL CITY WOULD
ALLOW YOU TO HAVE THAT PERMIT
THIS BILL SAYS YOU CAN'T USE
THIS BILL. TO START THE POLICY
INTENDED OCCUPIED BUILDINGS THE
BILL FURTHER PROVIDES THAT IF IN
ELLIS ACTIVE ACTION HAS OCCURRED
ON THE PROPERTY.
IN THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS YOU
CANNOT INVOKE THIS BILL.
OUR GOAL HERE IS TO BE ADDITIVE
WITH HOUSING TO ADD THE HOUSING
WE NEED NOT TO REPLACE EXISTING
RESIDENTS.
I AM VERY SENSITIVE TO THE
CONCERNS EXPRESSED AROUND
DISPLACEMENT.
WE HAVE EXPERIENCE OUT IN SAN
FRANCISCO IT IS HAPPENING AROUND
THE STATE -- AND WE HAVE TO BE
VERY CAREFUL THAT WE ARE ADDING
THE HOUSING WE NEED WHICH WILL
REDUCE DISPLACEMENT.
BY STOPPING THIS RUN AWAY
HOUSING MARKET.
WHAT MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE ALREADY LIVING IN A
COMMUNITY CAN STAY THERE?
SB FIFTY REQUIRES THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BE A PART OF
NEW DEVELOPMENTS.
ABOVE A CERTAIN SIZE.
LOCAL INCLUSIONARY WILL APPLY IF
THERE IS NO LOCAL INCLUSIONARY.
THAN THIS.
PROVIDES AN INCLUSIONARY
STRUCTURE -- FOR THESE PROJECTS.
FINALLY -- SB FIFTY DIFFERS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL FOR
FIVE YEARS.
IN WHAT WE CALL IN THE BILL SENT
QUOTE UNQUOTE SENSITIVE
COMMUNITIES THE FIND IS
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH SIGNIFICANT
LOW INCOME POPULATIONS.
WITH RISK OF DISPLACEMENT.
SO THAT THESE COMMUNITIES CAN
ENGAGE AND LOCAL ANTI
DISPLACEMENT PLANNING.
AND EXERCISE MORE FLEXIBILITY
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION -- IN
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS.
KNOWN IN TALKING ABOUT THIS BILL
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL -- WHILE THE
BILL AS I DSCRIBED LARGELY
RETAINS LOCAL CONTROL.
IT DOES MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
STATE AND LOCAL DECISION MAKING
BALANCE.
JUST AS WE HAVE.
A STATE LOCAL BALANCE AROUND
PUBLIC EDUCATION.
LOCAL CONTROL ISN'T BIBLICAL.
LOCAL CONTROL IS A GOOD THING
WHEN IT DELIVERS GOOD RESULTS
AND IT USUALLY DOES DELIVER GOOD
RESULTS AND I SAY THIS IS A
FORMER LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIAL.
BUT NOT ALWAYS.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO HOUSING
CALIFORNIA'S SYSTEM OF ALMOST
PURE LOCAL CONTROL.
HASN'T WORKED WE'RE NOT TRYING
TO DO AWAY WITH THAT SYSTEM.
FIND TO REFORMAT SO THAT WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD AS A STATE.
I ALSO WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
THIS BILL IS A CONTINUING WORK
IN PROGRESS.
WE HAVE MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS
OVER THE PAST YEAR OR SO WORKING
NOT JUST WITH OUR SUPPORTERS BUT
WITH OUR CONSTRUCTIVE CRITICS
PEOPLE WHO OPPOSE THE BILL LAST
YEAR OR NEUTRAL.
BUT WE'RE WILLING TO ENGAGE WITH
US TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK AND WORK
TOGETHER TOWARD SOLUTIONS -- AS
YOU PROBABLY SAW A COALITION OF
HOUSING PROGRESSIVE ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS SENT IN A LETTER
OF CONCERN.
OUTLINING ISSUES ON WHICH THEY
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK.
I AM DEEPLY COMMITTED TO THAT
WORK.
WHILE I CAN NEVER GUARANTEE --
THAT WE WILL ALL END UP AGREEING
ON A 100% OF EVERYTHING.
AS I'VE SHOWN OVER THE PAST YEAR
I'M WILLING TO LISTEN.
EXCEPT CRITICISM AND FEEDBACK
AND ADJUST THE BILL AND
REASONABLE WAYS.
INDEED THE TENET AND DEMOLITION
PROTECTION IN THIS.
PROTECTIONS IN THIS BILL WERE
NEGOTIATED WITH SOME OF THE KEY
SIGNERS OF THAT LETTER OF
CONCERN SO I PUT MY MONEY WHERE
MY MOUTH IS WHEN IT COMES TO
WORKING WITH PEOPLE.
WHO AREN'T IN AGREEMENT?
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK SENATOR
MCGUIRE WHO IS A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE IS NOT HERE RIGHT NOW
WILL BE HERE SHORTLY -- I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR MCGUIRE WHO
ALSO OF COURSE CHAIRS THE NEXT
COMMITTEE STOP -- FOR THIS BILL
THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE -- CENTER
MCGUIRE AND I CHAIR THE TWO
COMMITTEES -- THAT HERE A LOT OF
THE HOUSING -- BILLS IS DOUBLE
REFERRALS -- WE AGREE ON MANY
THINGS WE DON'T AGREE ON
EVERYTHING WE HAVE SOME
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES -- BUT I
THINK OUR PRO TEM IN -- SHE'S A
VERY WISE PERSON IN HER IN HER
WISDOM SHE APPOINTED TO TEARS
WHO DON'T NECESSARILY SEE EYE TO
EYE.
ON EVERYTHING BECAUSE THAT OFTEN
RESULTS IN STRONG BALANCED
POLICY.
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND I HAVE BEEN
WORKING INTENSIVELY FOR AWHILE
NOW. TO SEE TO WORK TOWARD.
A SHARED APPROACH WHERE WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER --
REGARDING SB FIFTY AND US BEFORE --
I KNOW THAT CENTER MCGUIRE AND I
OR BOTH COMMITTED. TO DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN -- TO REACH A
RESOLUTION -- COLLEAGUES WHEN IT
COMES TO HOUSING OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE SUFFERING.
AND THEY WANT THEIR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES TO FIX THE
PROBLEM.
AND FRANKLY MOST OF THEM DON'T
REALLY CARE WHETHER THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS FIXING THE PROBLEM.
ARE THE PEOPLE THEY VOTED FOR ON
THE CITY COUNCIL LINE. FOR THE
PEOPLE THEY VOTED FOR ON THE
STATE SENATE OR ASSEMBLY LINE.
THEY JUST WANT US TO FIX IT AND
THEY DON'T CARE WHICH OF US IS
ACTUALLY FIXING IT.
THEY WANT US TO DO WHAT WE CAN
TO MAKE THINGS BETTER REGARDLESS
OF WHAT OUR TITLE IS.
SB FIFTY IS CERTAINLY NOT THE
COMPLETE SOLUTION.
BUT IT IS PART OF THAT SOLUTION.
COLLEAGUES I THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE -- WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY.
H. O. GOV I WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ONE OF OUR BILL
SPONSORS WHICH REPRESENTS A
BROAD COALITION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS -- MICHAEL
GUNNING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND STATES ARE THE AS WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU.
BUT I WANT TO ALSO SAY THE
JOINING US TODAY.
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AS
BRIAN HAMMOND THE CEO CALIFORNIA
U. M. B. -- ALSO ONE OF OUR
SPONSORS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY MY NAME IS PATRICK OF ALL
AND I'M WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR SB FIFTEEN AS A BOLD
APPROACH TO ADDRESS OUR STATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS.
BY PROMOTING INCLUSIVE GROWTH
WHILE COMBATING RESTRICTIVE AND
EXCLUSIONARY ZONING AND
PROTECTING EXISTING
AFFORDABILITY.
NPH IS A FORTY YEAR OLD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION BASED IN SAN
FRANCISCO THAT WORKS AND ALL
NINE BAY AREA COUNTIES.
WE REPRESENT SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MEMBERS WHICH INCLUDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
BUSINESSES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
ORGANIZATIONS MISSION IS TO SEE
A BAY AREA WHERE EVERYONE HAS AN
AFFORDABLE AND STABLE PLACE TO
CALL HOME.
AND WE'RE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
CAN STATE AND PROSPER.
AS YOU ALL KNOW THE BAY AREA IS
AT THE EPICENTER FOR STATES
HUMANITARIAN HOUSING EMERGENCY
AND WE FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT THE
SOLUTION IS MORE HOMES NOT MORE
RESTRICTIONS. FOR MORE
PERSPECTIVE AS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION WE ARE
EXCITED BY SB FIFTIES HEIGHT
INCREASES BECAUSE IT WILL ALLOW
CONSTRUCTION OF DEED RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE HOMES.
IN PLACES WHERE MULTI FAMILY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
WAS PREVIOUSLY NOT ALLOWED TO TO
LOCAL HEIGHT RESTRICTIONS.
ALLOWING MORE AFFORDABLE HOMES
TO BE BUILT NEAR HIGH QUALITY
TRANSIT WHICH RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
RESIDENTS RIGHT MORE.
THAN WERE THOSE HOMES LOCATED
ELSEWHERE -- SB FIFTY ALSO
INCLUDES A 15225% INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING COMPONENT DEPENDING ON
THE PROJECT SIZE AND RESPECTS
LOCAL INCLUSIONARY PROGRAMS IF
THEY REQUIRE HIGHER LEVELS OF
AFFORDABILITY.
THIS WILL LEAD TO THE PRODUCTION
OF THOUSANDS OF NEW INCOME
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE HOMES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WHICH WAS
ANOTHER CRITICAL REASON FOR OUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AS THE SENATE A SENATOR WIENER
DESCRIBED SB FIFTY ALSO HELPS
PRESERVE EXISTING AFFORDABILITY
AND PROTECT TENANTS FROM
DISPLACEMENT.
THROUGH STRICT DEMOLITION
PROVIDE CONTROLS ON SITES THAT
HAVE BEEN OCCUPIED BY TENANTS
WITHIN THE PAST SEVEN YEARS.
AND ANY SITE THAT HAS HAD AND
ELLIS ACT EVICTION OVER THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS.
SB FIFTY ALSO INCORPORATES.
CRITICAL COMPONENT THAT IN PH
PUSH FOR THROUGH THE CASA CON
PROCESS CALLED.
SENSITIVE COMMUNITIES CAUGHT
SENSITIVE COMMUNITIES WHICH
ALLOW LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR TO THE POWER TO SELF
DETERMINE THEIR FUTURE BY THE
LAYING THERE IN INCREASED AND
CITIES IN SB FIFTY IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES FOR A PERIOD OF FIVE
YEARS.
SO THAT THOSE COMMUNITIES CAN
DEVELOP THEIR OWN COMMUNITY
PLANS THAT ADDRESS ISSUES OF
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY AND ANTI
DISPLACEMENT POLICIES WHILE
STILL MEETING THE MINIMUM BILL
HEIGHTS AND DENSITIES.
WELL SB FIFTY CONTINUES TO
EVOLVE WE AND THEN PH FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT MORE THE MORE HOMES
ACT IS ONE OF THE CRITICAL
SOLUTIONS THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS OUR STATE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS.
WE'D I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND POSSIBLE [inaudible]
FOR TWO NEXT WITNESS.
MADAM CHAIRMAN MICHAEL GUNNING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION FOR A START
I JUST WANTED KNOWLEDGE MY GOOD
FRIEND CITIES ARE HERE AND THAT
WE'RE HERE TOGETHER -- AND HAVE
YOU KNOW CBI A INSTITUTED THE
HOUSING KILLER AND HOUSING
CREATOR LIST LAST YEAR WHICH
POINTS WHICH TRIES TO IDENTIFY
THOSE -- THOSE BILLS THAT EITHER
EXACERBATE OR MILLIE EIGHT THE
HOUSING CRISIS AND WE'RE HERE TO
ANNOUNCE THAT OF COURSE SB FIFTY
IS A HOUSING.
CREATOR TODAY AND I THINK ONE
WAY TO POINT THAT IS LITERALLY
TO GO THROUGH THE DEFINITIONS ON
HOW WE ARRIVED AT THAT DECISION
AND EXPLAIN WHY SB FIFTY MAKES
THE CRITERIA.
WELL THE BILL STIMULATE HOUSING
PRODUCTION SUPPLY YES.
WOULD DECREASE THE COST TO BUILD
HOUSING YES WOULD MAKE HOUSING
LESS EXPENSIVE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS YES WOULD MAKE ANY
OF THE PROCESSES ASSOCIATED WITH
HOMEBUILDING SUCH AS THE EXT
ENTITLEMENT APPROVAL OR
PERMITTING PROCESS LESS
COMPLICATED EASIER AN
EXPEDITIOUS.
YES WILL ENCOURAGE HOMEOWNERSHIP
YES DOES IT DECREASE REGULATORY
BARRIERS YES.
DOES THE BILL PROPOSED TO
RESOLVE THE HOUSING CRISIS
FAIRLY WITH AN EGALITARIAN
DISTRIBUTION OF THE SOLUTION YES.
SO.
WITH THAT CRITERIA OUTLINED WE
CERTAINLY THINK THIS IS A
HOUSING CREATOR AND DESERVES OUR
SUPPORT IN AN AYE VOTE TODAY AND
URGE YOU TO VOTE ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
SISTER THE IS ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL.
OF PROUD TO BE HERE WITH SENATOR
WIENER -- WHO IS REACHED OUT TO
US THAT HE SAID -- FOR OVER A
YEAR TO TRY TO ADDRESS A VERY
COMPLEX AND DIFFICULT ISSUE.
THAT'S A VERY -- PERSONAL ISSUE
FOR ME -- I DID GROW UP IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN THE MISSION
DISTRICT I HAVE.
FAMILY MEMBERS WERE PERSONALLY
STRUGGLING WITH HOUSING -- AND
SO I ALSO REPRESENT THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO ACTUALLY BUILD THE
HOUSING AND MAKE A LIVING.
OFF OF AND CAREERS -- WITH
BENEFITS FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES SO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AND VERY CLOSE TO OUR
HEARTS -- IN THE BUILDING TRADES
TO WORK VERY CLOSELY AT
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT BOTHER STATUS FACE WITHOUT --
ONE OF THE ROOT CAUSES OF
HOUSING OTHER HOUSING CRISIS IS
A INCREASING EVER INCREASING
INCOME GAP.
AND PEOPLE NOT BEING ABLE TO
EARNED -- ENOUGH TO ACTUALLY
LIVE IN THE COMMUNITIES -- WHICH
WHERE THEY'RE WORKING.
AND SO -- WITH THAT COMPLEXITY --
OFTENTIMES A SOLUTION TO TRY TO
PRODUCE MORE HOUSING.
HAS TO DEAL WITH ISSUES OF LOCAL
CONTROL -- HOW TO DEAL WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT?
HOW TO DEAL WITH THE PUBLIC
SERVICES SUCH AS TRANSPORTATION
OR OTHER SERVICES THAT IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE LIVING AND WORKING
AROUND THOSE COMMUNITIES?
AND OF COURSE AFFORDABILITY.
BECAUSE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN THE ECONOMY.
AND SO WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A
WORK IN PROGRESS WE ARE VERY
PROUD OF HOW -- THE CENTER HAS
REACHED OUT TO A LARGE COALITION
OF FOLKS AND IS STILL WORKING
WITH A LOT OF PEOPLE TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IN VERY
SURGICAL AND CAREFUL MANNER.
IT'S NOT AN EASY THING -- BUT
WE'RE STAND HERE IN SUPPORT
BECAUSE WE DO SEE THE URGENCY OF
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING NOW IS
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING QUICK --
TO ADDRESS A LOT OF THESE ISSUES
THAT WORKING PEOPLE ARE FACED
WITH SO THANK YOU ENERGY SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I OTHERS IN SUPPORT I SEE YOU'RE
ALL LINED UP THERE SO PLEASE
COME FORWARD AND NOW PLEASE KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS.
ODD TO MINIMUM HOW WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK SO -- LET'S PROCEED
I'LL GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
OPPOSITION TO HAVE ADEQUATE TIME.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER SPECK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WE ARE
PLEASED TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF
THE BILL HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
SAYS IN MY MATTER NOT LIKE HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS PART OF THE BILL.
MR THERE ALONE BECAUSE
ACTIVITIES PAY FOR EVERYONE WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF ENDING
SEGREGATIONIST EXCLUSIONARY
ZONING.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN WHITE
HERE WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING ALLIANCE BUILDERS
DEVELOPERS OF SINGLE FAMILY AND
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING UNITS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR IN THE IN THE
COMMITTEE AND MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M STEVEN FAULK AND I
LIVE IN LAFAYETTE.
AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING PEOPLE
WHO ARE UNEMPLOYED.
AND PEOPLE WHO NEED A PLACE TO
LIVE WITHOUT CRUSHING EARTH
DESTROYING.
COMMUTE AND I SUPPORT SB --
FIFTY CHAIR AND MEMBERS HI MY
NAME IS JAMES SWEENEY.
I REPRESENT BAY PACKED BLACK
AMERICAN POLITICAL ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
THE TERM MEMBERS NIKITA CROWDED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL OVER IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL FROM A CLIMATE
PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ADAM WRIGLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JASON BRYANT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DOWNTOWN ASSOCIATION THE STATE'S
BUSINESS IMPROVEMENT DISTRICTS
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KAREN MEMBERS COURTNEY JENSEN
WITH TECH MAN IN SUPPORT. TWENTY
BOY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT SUFFICIENT HERE IN
TRANSPORT.
BOB NAYLOR AND TO HAVE A POWERED
AHMANSON JUNIOR IN SUPPORT OF
THIS VERY IMPRESSIVE PIECE OF
LEGISLATIVE CRAFTSMANSHIP.
MICHAEL MCLAUGHLIN VOLUNTEER
WITH A A RP WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
DOUG TROUBLE FOR INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO IN INDIVISIBLE STATE
WIDE.
IN SUPPORT.
MISTER COLIN CHAPMAN WITH
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO AND WITH
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA'S NEED
STRONG STOP STATE STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MCNULTY STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
SUPPORT.
CHRISTINE SHOEMAKER WITH FOSSIL
FOR CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
ESPECIALLY FOR THE CLIMATE
HOUSING NEXUS THANK YOU.
TINA GAILLARD FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA WARNER ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ON A SOUL OREO
TALK COMMUNITY HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES CORPORATION
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HELLO SCOTT FEENEY WITH MISSION
YOU BE A COMMUNITY GROUP
CONSISTING OF NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
NEIGHBORS IN THE MISSION
DISTRICT OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THE NEW TRASK CALIFORNIA RENTERS
LEGAL ADVOCACY AND EDUCATION
FUND OR A NONPROFIT WE ENFORCE
THE GREAT STATE HOUSING LAWS
THAT YOU.
PASS AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
YOU MIGHT AS HE SETTLES ON
BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FIFTY ON A HOUSE OF LEAD WITH
UNITED WAYS OF CALIFORNIA WELL
WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO TAKE A
SUPPORT POSITION AT THIS TIME WE
ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE A CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO IT
AS IT PROGRESSES.
THANK YOU.
CAITLYN VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
COREY SMITH ON BEHALF OF THREE
HUNDRED MEMBERS OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
BERRYHILL NJ CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES AND LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY SUPPORT -- KEITH
MEASURE MEMBER BOTH MISSION YOU
MEDIUM JACKSON HERE'S A SUPPORT.
GILLIAN STROHMAIER WITHIN THE
ACTION AND I SUPPORT IT FULLY
THANKS.
LARA BINGLE SERMON ON BEHALF OF
FIVE HUNDRED NEIGHBORS IN
PROGRESS AND WE VALLEY.
ON SCOTT WINNERS HOME TURF
DISTRICT EIGHT SAN FRANCISCO.
WE SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS HOLDEN LAND HOWLS
NOW I LEAVE IN MARIN COUNTY I'M
HERE TO VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR SB
FIFTY WE NEED TO PROVIDE MORE
HOUSING FOR HER CARE GIVERS WE
HAVE A VERY -- ELDERLY
POPULATION AND WE NEED OUR CARE
GIVERS TO BE NEAR.
THE STOP TRANSPORTATION HUBS AND
WE SB FIFTY WILL ENCOURAGE MORE
CONSTRUCTION IN THOSE AREAS WE
NEED TO KEEP OUR CARE GIVERS FOR
ELDERLY AND OUR CHILDREN NEARBY
EVERY TIME I GET MY CARE GIVER
TELLS ME I NEED TO MOVE OUT
AGAIN AND AGAIN.
MY HEART SKIPS A BEAT I HAVE AN
EIGHTY SEVEN YEAR OLD MOTHER AND
TWO CHILDREN IN ALL OF OUR MOMS.
WE ALL TALKED ABOUT IT WILL FEEL
WE NEED TO PROVIDE HOUSING FOR
OUR CARE GIVERS THANK YOU.
JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT -- DAVID
POLLOCK -- SAN MATTEO COUNTY
HOMEOWNER AND OF A ONE OF MANY
MPS DOWN THERE I FULLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JORDAN GRIMES -- LEAD MEMBER OF
PENINSULA FOR EVERYONE -- FOR
AMD GROUP ON THAT SAME DETAIL
PENINSULA IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
TODD DAVID ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
STRONG SUPPORTER THIS BILL EVERY
MUNICIPALITY NEEDS TO DO THEIR
PART.
TO GET THE TO THE THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION HOUSES THAT WE NEED
THANK YOU.
MAX CANISTER MEMBER OF YOU IN
THE ACTION AND SOMEONE WHO GREW
UP IN PALO ALTO I SUPPORT THIS
BILL SO THAT PEOPLE WHO GREW UP
IN POLITICS DON'T HAVE TO BE
THEIR HOME.
THANK YOU.
ALEX MELENDEZ REPRESENTING THE
HOUSING LEADERSHIP COUNCIL OF
SAN MATEO COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
REPRESENT CAR MEMBER OF YOU BE
ACTION RESIDENTS SAN FRANCISCO
PERSON WITH.
TO BABY NEPHEW AND NIECE IN PALO
ALTO WANT TO SEE THEM ABLE STAY
HERE IF THEY WANT TO IN SUPPORT.
TECH CARRILLO FOR THE COALITION
OF SENIORS INSULT SACRAMENTO.
MANY OF US HAVE ONLY OUR SOCIAL
SECURITY INCOME TO LIVE ON AND
PAY OVER 50% OF OUR INCOME IN
RENT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO SERRA OGILVY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I'M A MEMBER OF YOU IN
THE ACTION AND I ALSO REPRESENT
THE HOMELESS CHURCH ON THE WHARF
OF SAN FRANCISCO.
I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
REGGAE'S ON BEHALF OF UP FOR
GROWTH A HIGH DENSITY HOUSING
ADVOCACY COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND JUST TO
CLARIFY OUR POSITION BEING
CONDITIONAL SUPPORT.
BASED ON THE INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING ELEMENT OF THE BILL.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT HOUSING
IS ACCESSIBLE NEAR PUTTING YOUR
TRANSIT AND AND JOBS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL INCOME
LEVELS IN ORDER TO MAXIMIZE THE
CLIMATE BENEFITS IN THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS.
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE STAFF IN BRINGING
TOGETHER THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON SHARING GUNS
ALL OF HIS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF OAKLAND IN EMERYVILLE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SENATE READER MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE STEVE CARLSON FOR THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OF GREATER
LOS ANGELES IN THE SANTA BARBARA
RENTAL PROPERTY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
TIFFANY PHANTOM HAVE A BRIDGE
HOUSING IS PART.
LET'S HAVE A REPRESENTING THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN THE CAL ASIAN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
IN A WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM WE'VE A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION
RELATED TO DEMOLITION LANGUAGE
AND AFFORDABILITY AND THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US.
CHAIR MEETINGS AND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M HERE MONROE WITH EAST BAY
FOR EVERYONE JUST HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
WITH KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF
MARYLAND AND BREED FROM THE CITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY AND I WOULD
THAT JONES WITH ALLIANCE FOR
COMMUNITY TRANSIT NO POSITION
BUT WE ARE PART OF THE GROUP OF
FIFTY FIVE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
EXPRESSED CONCERNS WITH THE BILL.
WE'RE NOT THERE YET.
HELLO ONE I SKY SAID I THINK I'M
A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH SAGE --
NO POSITION YET BUT WE ALSO
SHOULD HAVE MANY CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL WE ALSO SIGNED ON TO
THAT LETTER.
THANK YOU [inaudible] TO MY NAME
IS JUSTIN FRANK I AM A MEMBER
SAGE AS WELL -- I AM I HOPE NO
POSITION BUT WE DO HAVE STRONG
CONCERNS.
THANK.
LARA FOOT ON BEHALF OF THE TWO
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED MEMBERS
OF YOU IN THE ACTION AND THE
GROWING IN THE MOVEMENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
THIS SERIOUSLY AND ACTUALLY
PROPOSING SOMETHING AT SCALE
WITH THE SIZE OF OUR PROBLEM WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER SUPPORT AND TO ME AS WELL --
CITY GEORGIA BENEATH
REPRESENTING AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION WERE ACTUALLY THE
ONES ARE GONNA HAVE TO IMPLEMENT
THIS -- AND WE WERE YOU TALK TO
THE AUTHOR WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
TECHNICAL ISSUES THEN WE'D LIKE
TO BE FIXED SO IT FUNCTIONS WELL.
AND THAT WORKS WELL WITH THE
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY OTHER BILLS
THAT HAVE JUST BEEN PASSED -- WE
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE GONNA HAVE
TO EXPLAIN THIS AT THE CANNERY
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE CAN DO THAT.
IN ADDITION WANNA MAKE SURE IT'S
MORE CONTEXT SPECIFIC SO WE
DEFINITELY AGREE WITH THE GOALS
OF THE BILL TO JUST WANT TO LET
LET EVERYTHING ABOUT THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL -- FOLKS HERE IN
SUPPORT.
IF NOT THOSE OPPOSED TO YOU COME
FORWARD
[inaudible] THREE ALL
THREE OF OKAY [inaudible]
SIR. TO ALL THREE OF YOU WILL
HAVE THREE SONS CHOOSE WHICH IS
GOING.
TO AND THEN -- AND TOTAL OF TEN
MINUTES SOPHIA AS THE CHURCH
THANK YOU.
SURE MEMBERS CHASE FRIENDLY
CALIFORNIA CITIES -- WE HAVE AN
OPPOSING THE SUBMITTED POSITION
ON THIS BILL.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW THIS YEAR.
KILLER HOME WE WE'VE REALLY --
YOU KNOW PUSH OURSELVES TO GET
TO A POSITION WE CAN REMOVE YOUR
OPPOSITION TO NUMBER THESE BILLS
ON SWEET YOU KNOW TAKING A
REALLY DEEP DIVE WITH OUR BORDER
POLICY COMMITTEES ARE INTERNAL
COMMITTEES AND COMMITTEES. TO
TRY TO DETERMINE WHAT ARE THOSE
SOLUTIONS MAYBE ALTERNATIVES --
BUT WHAT CAN WE DO IN ORDER FOR
THIS DISCUSSION -- AND TO BE
REALLY CLEAR THOUGH -- YOU KNOW
WE WE AGREE WITH THE FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEM THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
HOMES BEING BUILT IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE KNOW THAT WE ARE
CERTAINLY PART OF THAT SOLUTION
AND WE PLAY A VERY IMPORTANT
PART AND SAY IN THE STAGE FOR
FOR DEVELOPMENT.
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY IN SUPPORT OF
MORE DENSITY AROUND KEY TRANSIT
AND JOB CENTERS NEAR WERE OR
ABSOLUTELY AND SUPPORT OF
OPENING UP YOU KNOW OUR
COMMUNITIES TO ALL THOSE FOLKS
WHO WANT TO LIVE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES -- BUT I THINK
THERE'S WAYS OF GOING ABOUT
DOING IT PERHAPS THAT -- THAT
MIGHT BE MORE ACCEPTABLE TO TO
FOLKS.
SO WHAT SPECIFICALLY REGARD SB
FIFTY ON THE ISSUE -- THAT THAT
IS YOU KNOW THE COURSE OF THIS
IS REALLY THE UNDERMINING OF
THIS EXISTING PLANTS AND WE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT -- ILLEGALS
OWNING AND NOT BE ABLE TO BUILD --
WHILE IT'S NOT A FORMALLY
AUTHORIZED TO BUILD A MULTI
FAMILY IN A SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOOD AND NOTHING
PROHIBITS A BILL FROM COMING
INTO MY QUESTION IS ONLY CHANGE
IN ORDER TO BUILD THAT -- SO
THAT OFTEN DOES HAPPEN AND THEN
IT WILL OCCUR BUT IT DOES ALSO
MAKE IT A LITTLE MORE DIFFICULT
FOR THE DEVELOPER I'M TO
ACTUALLY BUILD.
NOW WITH REGARD TO THE PLANS IT
WOULD JUST LIKE TO REMIND
EVERYBODY THAT 90% 91% OF OUR
CITIES ALL HAVE AN APPROVED
HOUSING PLAN THIS IS SOMETHING
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
APPROVED.
IT IS REQUIRED BY LAW JUST IKE
A GENERAL PLAN.
AND WE HAVE ALL OF THE ZONING
AND CITED IN EDUCATION NECESSARY
TO ACCOMMODATE ALL OF THE GROWTH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SAID WE
MUST ACCOMMODATE INNER CITIES.
SO THE STATE IS COMPLETELY
COMPLICIT WHEN IT COMES TO
APPROVING THOSE PLANS SO IT IS
SAYING THAT WE ARE READY FOR
DEVELOPMENT AND DEVELOPERS COME
IN AND DEVELOP SO THE IDEA THAT.
WE'RE JUST NOT DOING WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING IF WE ARE
FOLLOWING THE HOUSING PLAN THAT
IS APPROVED BY SEE THE
CALIFORNIA WE ABSOLUTELY ARE.
SO BY COMING IN AND HAVING THIS
TOP DOWN APPROACH AND COMPLETELY
UNDERMINING THOSE PLANS A REALLY
QUESTIONS WHY CITIES HAVE TO DO
GENERAL PLAN AND WHY CITIES NEED
TO DO A HOUSING ELEMENT.
AND INCORPORATE ALL THE
COMMUNITY INPUT IT'S ALMOST AS
IF WE'RE SETTING OUR CITIES UP
TO FAIL YOU TELLS THE PLAN YOU
pARE GOING TO BE CHANGED WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL INPUT.
SO PROVIDING THAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR INPUT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT -- I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO MENTION THAT SB FIFTY I'M
STILL HAS THE DEVELOPER OFTEN
APPROACH WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
THAT WE CERTAINLY HAVE CONCERNS
WITH.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT SITTING STATE
POLICY THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THAT
THE DEVELOPERS GOING TO BUILD A
MAXIMUM HEIGHT THE MAXIM DENSITY.
IMPORTANT TRANSIT HUB THEY COULD
FLUCTUATE BETWEEN THEIR SO WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT IF THE
STATE WANTS TO HAVE A POLICY
MAYBE SHE LITTLE PRESCRIPTIVE IN
WHAT'S THAT HEIGHT WHAT'S THAT
DENSITY THEY LIKE TO SEE.
AND NOT ALLOW IT OVER TO TO PICK
AND CHOOSE -- AND FINALLY YOU
KNOW I WOULD LIKE TO TO TO SAY
THEY CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
SENATOR WINNERS --
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT COMMUNITIES
ARE DIFFERENT AND THERE ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT MAY NEED A
LITTLE MORE TIME TO UPDATE THEIR
PLANS -- WE JUST THINK THAT
PERHAPS ALL COMMITTEE SHOULD
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO COME UP
WITH AN ALTERNATIVE THAT STILL
MEETS THE STATE CRITERIA THE
STATE CAN BE VERY SPECIFIC IN
WHAT THEY WANT.
BUT ALLOW THE FLEXIBILITY THE
LOCAL LEVEL FOR US TO MEET THOSE
NEEDS AND WITH THAT I'LL HAND IT
OVER TO THE NEXT SPEAKER THANK
YOU.
I GUESS SON THANK YOU KAREN
KLINGER LOCAL REAL ESTATE BROKER
I OPPOSE SORRY IT SOUNDS LIKE A
GREAT BILL BUT WE ALREADY HAVE
THAT IN OUR COUNTY GENERAL PLAN
UPDATE AND MORE.
THIS IS BY RIGHT ANYTHING THAT --
YOU'RE SAYING.
YOU WANT TO HAVE BUILT LIKE IT'S
NOW SEVEN STORIES NOT EIGHT BY
THE POTENTIAL OF EIGHT STORIES
THIS WOULD DESTROY MY SUBURBAN.
SINGLE FAMILY ONE HOME PER LOT
NEIGHBORHOOD [inaudible]
BECAUSE IT IS MY RIGHT THE LOCAL
OFFICIALS WOULD BE ELIMINATED
UNDER THIS PROCESS YOU WOULD
HAVE DIFFERENT TYPES OF AGENCIES
AND DEFINITELY THIS IS ABOUT
REGIONALIZATION WHICH AYE
OPPOSED.
I SUPPORT OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO BE ABLE CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO BE ABLE TO CONTROL THEIR
VISION AND WE THE PEOPLE OUR
VISION OF WHAT WE WANT.
I DO NOT WANT TO CONTINUE TO SEE
A VIOLATION OF OPS OWNING.
AND IT CAN BE UP SOME DID IN THE
TIME NOT JUST UNDER THIS ONCE
UPS OWNED IT ANYTIME.
THIS IS THE REMOVAL AS A SET OF
A LOCAL -- LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS I LOOK FORWARD TO
GOING IN TO SEE THE FUNDING
SOURCE ON THIS BECAUSE A CA ONE
IS GOING TO BE THE FUNDING
SOURCE -- BUT THIS IS THERE'S A
LOT OF UNKNOWNS WITH THIS AND
IT'S UNKNOWN BECAUSE WHEN THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE REMOVED
WHO WILL BE OUR GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE.
WE KNOW THAT IT WILL BE SPECIAL
INTERESTS STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE
PAST WE KNOW IT COULD BE
OBVIOUSLY THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD.
WE KNOW IT COULD ALSO BE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL ALL
KINDS OF COMMITTEES DEPARTMENTS
AGENCIES A PARTY'S.
BETTER THERE BUT THEY'RE HIDDEN
AROUND KNOWN YOU DON'T SEE THAT
MOST PEOPLE DON'T EVEN KNOW
THEY'RE THERE IT'S LIKE
REDEVELOPMENT THIS IS ABOUT
DESTROYING.
SUBURBAN ONE HOME PER LOT SINGLE
FAMILY RESIDENTIAL NO
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND I'M SORRY BUT I CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS THIS IS
DISCRIMINATION.
IT'S ALSO ABOUT SMART GROWTH AND
IF ANY OF YOU FOLLOWED SMART
GROWTH YOU KNOW EXACTLY THAT IT
IS ABOUT REMOVING ARE SINGLE
FAMILY RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOODS
ONE QUARTER TO ONE HALF A MILE.
FROM THE TRANSIT TAUGHT STOP
TRANSIT REMOVE SUBURBAN
NEIGHBORHOODS AND MOSTLY FOR
THOSE IN POORER NEIGHBORHOODS TO
HAVE ALREADY THOSE BUS STOPS
PROBABLY MUCH CLOSER.
I WANT -- TO FINISH BY SAYING
THIS IS DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
SUBURBAN NEIGHBORHOODS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM VICE TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SENATOR
WIENER MY NAME IS NORMA GARCIA I
AM THE DIRECTOR POLICY ADVOCACY
FOR THE MISSION ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY WHICH IS A
FORTY FIVE YEAR OLD NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
ORGANIZATION.
HEADQUARTERED IN SAN FRANCISCO'S
MISSION DISTRICT WERE ALSO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER
WITH A SIGNIFICANT TRACK RECORD
A FEW POINTS BECAUSE I WANT TO
BE A ONE MINUTE TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES.
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
BILL BECAUSE ALTHOUGH THERE HAS
BEEN THE SAFETY VALVE OFFERED AS
THE SENSITIVE COMMUNITY
DEFINITION.
UNBELIEVABLY THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THE MISSION DISTRICT IS NOT
CONSIDERED TO BE AND A SENSE OF
COMMUNITY WHEN WE SEE HEADLINES
LIKE THIS ON SAN FRANCISCO
WEEKLY THAT THE MISSION IS
GENTRIFYING THERE'S NO DENYING
THAT THE SAN FRANCISCO MISSION
DISTRICT IS A SENSITIVE
COMMUNITY GET WE DO NOT APPEAR.
ON THAT MAP.
THERE'S ALSO ISSUES AROUND ON
THE SENSITIVE COMMUNITIES LIKE
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER SEVEN YEARS
LET'S JUST SAY THAT'S US FIX
STOP THAT WERE A SENSE OF WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER SEVEN YEARS TO
REVERT BACK. TO KNOW PROTECTIONS
THAT'S NOT CLEAR THERE'S ALSO AN
ISSUE ABOUT A LACK OF VALUE WE
CAPTURE FOR THE CITY WE'RE
GIVING AWAY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO DEVELOPERS BY THIS PROPOSAL
AND NOT BRINGING THAT MONEY BACK
TO THE CITY. TO HELP WITH THE
KINDS OF PROGRAMS A CONSERVE THE
KINDS OF CLIENTS THAT WE SERVE
IT AT META WHICH ARE LARGELY LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES WHO
ARE STRUGGLING TO STAY IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN A NEIGHBORHOOD THAT
THEY'VE CALLED THEIR HOME
PERHAPS SINCE MANY CASES FOR
GENERATIONS.
THIS IS TALKING ABOUT REZONING
THE WHOLE STATE.
WITHOUT A STUDY.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT WILL BE ARE
WE READY TO PROCEED AS A STATE
ON THIS SCALE WITHOUT HAVING
BACK QUESTION THOSE IMPORTANT
ISSUES ANSWERED. TEN PROTECTIONS
THERE'S BEEN SOME TALK ABOUT
THERE BEING SOME SAFETY NETS
HERE FOR PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
ELLIS ACTED -- FOUR HAVE LIVED
THE WERE THE BUILDING HAS BEEN
OCCUPIED IT FOR SEVEN YEARS.
BUT WE'RE NOT TALKING HERE ABOUT
WHATHAPPENS TO PEOPLE WHO LEAVE
THEIR PROMISES BECAUSE THEY WERE
BOUGHT OUT TEN AND BUYOUTS ARE
INCREDIBLY INCREDIBLY FOR OF
COMMON IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THERE'S NO PROTECTIONS HERE
THERE'S NO AND THERE'S NO
ANYTHING HERE FOR TENET BUYOUTS.
FINALLY THE LETTER THAT --
SENATOR WINNER ALLUDED TO THAT
LETTER I THINK IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT'S VERY
DETAILED AND IT AND EXPRESSES
THE VIEWS.
OF NOW FIFTY FIVE SIGNATORIES.
COMPRISED OF LARGELY SOCIAL
JUSTICE LEGAL SERVICES PROVIDERS.
ADVOCATES FOR LOWINCOME AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT SUBSTANTIVE CONCERNS.
OUR POSITION AT MATTER WE ARE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED BUT WE ARE
ASKING YOU TO TAKE A REALLY
CLOSE LOOK AT THIS BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT OUR COMMUNITY IS NOT
PROTECTED.
AND WE KNOW THAT WE ARE GROUND
ZERO FOR GENTRIFICATION SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M FROM THE
MISSION DISTRICT AND I ALSO HAVE
DEEP ROOTS IN BOYLE HEIGHTS AND
I CAN TELL YOU THE LAST THING I
WANT TO SEE.
IS THAT THE LATINO COMMUNITY AND
SAN FRANCISCO IN BOYLE HEIGHTS
IS REDUCED TO A PLAQUE ON THE
GROUND THAT SAYS WE WERE HERE.
SO IF YOU WANT TO BE SERIOUS
ABOUT THIS WE NEED TO GO BACK TO
THE TABLE AND HAVE THESE
DISCUSSIONS WERE HAPPY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU SENATOR WIENER ABOUT
OUR PERSPECTIVE WE'VE OFFERED TO
BE THE TABLE WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
THAT OFFER.
THANK YOU HE GOT ABOUT A MINUTE
AND A HALF LEFT SO I'LL TRY TO
KEEP IT SHORT MY NAME IS RENEE
KRISTIN MOORE AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF HOUSING IS A HUMAN
RIGHT THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATIONS HOUSING ADVOCACY
DIVISION I'M ALSO A VOLUNTEER
TENANT ORGANIZER WITH ELLIE
TENANTS UNION.
FIGHTING AGAINST THE
DISPLACEMENT OF TENANTS
ESPECIALLY WORKING CLASS
ATTENDANCE OF COLOR ACROSS LA
CENTER TO DO RUSSELL I'M ONE OF
YOUR CONSTITUENTS I HAIL FROM
HIGHLAND PARK IT'S WHERE I WAS
BORN AND RAISED.
IN THE RAPIDLY GENTRIFYING
NEIGHBORHOOD OF NEAR NORTHEAST
LOS ANGELES I SAW MANY OF MY
FRIENDS PUSHED OUT OF THEIR
HOMES AND IT MYSELF FACED
SERIOUS HOUSING IN SECURITIES OF
THIS IS PERSONAL FOR ME.
TO HOUSING IS HUMAN RIGHT HAS
TAKEN AN EARLY POSITION OF
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL FIFTY
WE BELIEVE A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH THAT STRIP SIGNIFICANT
POWERS FROM OUR COMMUNITIES TO
DETERMINE PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES LIKE
PLEASE TO EXPERIENCE AGAIN IF I
CAN GENTRIFICATION PRESSURES
WORKING CLASS COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR LIKE THE ONE I WAS BORN
AND RAISED IN AND WHAT SHAPES MY
UNDERSTANDING THE PROBLEM AT
HAND.
WE BELIEVE SB FIFTY WILL ADD
SUBSTANTIAL PRESSURE TO TENANTS
IN PLACES LIKE LA DOING LITTLE
TO SPUR THE TYPE OF HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION WE NEED WHILE
PUTTING UPWARD PRESSURE ON
RENTAL HOME PRICES IN HOT REAL
ESTATE MARKETS.
AS WRITTEN SB FIFTY WOULD NOT
MANDATE SUFFICIENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL
PROJECTS AND A SKILL
COMMENSURATE TO THE CRISIS AND
IN FACT MAKES EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME HOUSING REQUIREMENTS
WHICH WE MOST URGENTLY LEADING
CAP NEED IN CALIFORNIA OPTIONAL.
THE BILL ALLOWS DEVELOPERS TO
PAY THEIR WAY OUT OF FULFILLING
ONSITE AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN LA.
AS WE'VE SEEN A DEVELOPERS BEING
INCENTIVIZE TO BUILD THE WRONG
SORT OF HOUSING FOR THE
COMMUNITIES I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH ESPECIALLY IN SOUTH CENTRAL
LA AND IN NORTHEAST LA THANK YOU
BY THE WAY.
WE'RE GONNA WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
SINCE WE HAVE A BIG CROWD THANK
YOU BY THE WAY FOR YOUR COMMENTS --
WE'RE GONNA ASK OTHERS WHO ARE
IN OPOSITION IF YOU CAN JUST
TAKE YOUR NAME -- YOUR POSITION
OF COURSE AND WHO YOU REPRESENT
AND THAT WOULD BE GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THE YOUNG.
DAVID JONES ABOUT THE CITY
PASADENA -- WE MET WITH THE
SENATOR -- PASADENA DONE THE
RIGHT THING AND WE'D STILL POSE
A BILL THANKS.
MY NAME IS JAMES FARM I
REPRESENT WEST CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND THE LGBT.
I FEEL LIKE YOU GUYS REALLY
DON'T HAVE. EIGHTY SAY CIRCLE
UNIT DOWN THERE IN THE
COMMUNITIES AND I'M SURE MOST OF
YOU COULD JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AND I DON'T AGREE ORGANIZATION
OR WITHIN POSITION I'D I'D BE
THINK WE'D ALL BE THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH I THINK IT AFTERNOON
I'M SABINA CROW CITY THE POLICY
MANAGER.
WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR PERSONS
WITH CHILDREN WE ARE SIGNATORIES
WITH THE OTHER FIFTY FIVE
ORGANIZATIONS WE HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS AND TODAY WE HAVE TO
SAY WE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
SPECIFICALLY AROUND LOW IN VERY
LOW INCOME HOUSING THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CAPTAIN SANDERS I
REPRESENT HE RUBIO BARKLEY
EVERYWHERE AROUND HERE BECAUSE I
FEEL LIKE WE GOT AS VESTED FAR
LANE.
YOU GUYS NEED TO GO OUT HERE IN
LI OF IT SEE HOW IT IS YOU TRY
TO PUT ALL THESE PLACES HERE BUT
YOU HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE GOING TO BE OUT OF PLACE.
IF YOU PUT A STOP ALLOW BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK IS RIGHT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DAVID ROBERTSON HOUSING HUMAN
RIGHTS I OPPOSE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ENTRY ENTRY
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS AND OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS ROGER ALICE GOT FROM
OAKLAND AND I OPPOSE.
THIS TO MY SENSES WAS RICHMOND
DISTRICT I OPPOSE.
HOTEL BED TOOK US ANY OTHER
CONSTITUENT OF TWO OUNCES
DISTRICT -- WITH THE BOYLE
HEIGHTS COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND
COMMITTEE TO DEFEND ROOSEVELT ON
BEHALF OF THE NINETEEN SIXTY
WALKOUTS.
STRONGLY OPPOSE -- TRICKLE DOWN
HOUSING THANK YOU VERY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT THANK
YOU.
SUSAN HUNTER LOS ANGELES TENANTS
UNION HOLLYWOOD LOCAL CASE
WORKER MEANT MULTIPLE LOCALS ARE
OPPOSE WE'VE ONLY JUST GOTTEN AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE YOU NEED TO GIVE
US A CHANCE TO MANDATE HOUSING
THANK YOU.
HI AND THEIR JEFFREY A REPRESENT
BERKELEY COMMUNITY.
WHO IS THIS GONNA REPRESENT
ANYBODY GOING TO TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS NOT GONNA FOR
DISCOUNTING THAT YOU WON'T BE
ABLE?
SO I THINK YOU NEED TO REALLY
THEATER CONSIDERING STOP PUTTING
FAMILIES OUT ON THE STREET AND
MAKE IT AFFORDABLE THANK YOU.
I MONEY THE SAMPSON ABOVE THE
OPEN APPLES.
THANK YOU M. AS ONE LINDORES
THERE ARE POSING FOR EAST
OAKLAND.
JILL STEWART DIRECTOR OF THE
COALITION TO PRESERVE LA SIX
THOUSAND MEMBERS FROM A SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY TO EAST SIDE OF
LA WEST SIDE IN SOUTH LA.
WE 1000% OPPOSE THIS BILL -- WE
SEE IT AS A COMPANY VERY BECAME
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HELLO MY IS LASHANDRA YOU SEE
SOME SAUSAGE AND WE ACTUALLY
SUPPORT I APOLOGIZE I WAS
RUNNING FROM ANOTHER HEARING I
WAS LATE.
THANK YOU.
THIS IS ENCOURAGED FOUNDER OF
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA A COALITION
OF ELECTED AND STATEWIDE.
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RECALL CULTURAL ACTION NETWORK
SAN FRANCISCO.
OPPOSE.
THIS IS GENTRIFICATION ON
STEROIDS WITH NO PROTECT NO REAL
PROTECTIONS.
HI MY NAME IS PAT ECHLIN I
CURRENTLY SERVE ON THE NEVADA
CITY COUNCIL AND I WILL BE
BRINGING A LETTER OF OPPOSITION
TO SB FIFTY BEFORE COUNCIL ON
TUESDAY NIGHT -- PLEASE GIVE US
TIME TO IMPLEMENT OUR HOUSING
ELEMENT THAT WE JUST APPROVED.
AND IF I COULD JUST SAY ONE
THING RIGHT MA'AM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'LL PUT IT IN THE LETTER
THANK YOU [inaudible]
JULIE TESTER.
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER PLEASANTON --
I OPPOSE THIS LEGISLATION THAT I
THINK WILL BENEFIT SPECIAL
INTERESTS.
AND WILL NOT SOLVE OUR
CALIFORNIA AFFORDABILITY PROBLEM.
MICHAEL ARNOLD ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF REDONDO BEACH IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SHARE ANY
FLEET -- I'M HERE REPRESENTING
POLICY LINK TODAY WE HAVE
NEITHER A SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
POSITION I THINK MOST OF THE
SPEAKERS WHO FOLLOW -- WERE PART
OF THE LETTER THAT WAS SUBMITTED
BY.
NOW FIFTY FIVE PLUS
ORGANIZATIONS -- OR WE HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS AROUND THE
AFFORDABILITY PROVISIONS AND THE
POTENTIAL GENTRIFICATION IMPACTS
OF THE PROPOSAL AND OUR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ORIGINALLY
CONTINUE WORKING WITH A MEMBER
TO SORT THROUGH THOSE CONCERNS.
TYRONE BUCKLEY A BILLION BEHALF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA ALIGN MYSELF
WITH THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER THANK
YOU.
IF HE BE SEEN LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUST ISN'T AN ACCOUNTABILITY
BUSINESS SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY IN
EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY.
I TO ALIGN MY COMMENT THIS
UNIQUE LEGAL POLICY LIKE.
MITCHELL PARASITE WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES ALIGNED WITH POLICY
LINK.
A BRIAN GUEST ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION RURAL
COMMUNITIES SYSTEMS CORPORATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA.
COALITION FOR RURAL HOUSING --
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THOSE PRIOR
COMMENTS.
I KNOW LAWLER ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY I'M ALSO.
HAVE CONCERT TO LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH THOSE
WITH THE OTHER.
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
MAILING STEPHAN REPRESENTING
SUNNYVALE NEIGHBORS WE WANT TO
RISE AND RECESSED SB FIFTY WE
WANT OUR COUNT SHOWS TO BE
RESPONSIBLE AND ACCOUNTABLE.
PLEASE DO NOT REMOVE OUR LOCAL
DEMOCRACY THANK YOU [inaudible]
QUE EL.
THAT'S IT ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS -- SENATOR SKINNER
[inaudible]
YOUR ALL I THOUGHT YOU WENT THAT
WAY THIS [inaudible]
ROTH.
ACTUALLY I DON'T HAVE A QUESTION
HAPPEN WITH REGARD TO THIS BILL
IN THE ONE TO FOLLOW BUT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME OF THE BILL.
SENATOR I WILL.
YES -- IS THAT A COUPLE
QUESTIONS I'M NOT SURE WE HAVE.
TO GET ALL THE ANSWERS RIGHT NOW
BUT SOME OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE
STOOD OUT. TO ME -- IS IF ONE OF
THE GOALS IS TO INCREASE HOUSING.
FOR ALL INCOME SNEER TRANSIT AND
I KNOW YOU ARE.
COMMITTED TO THAT WHY INCLUDE ON
IN -- IN LIEU FREE OPTION.
THAT ALLOWS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TO BE PLACED ELSE WERE AWAY FROM
TRANSIT BUT HIT ME.
I THANK YOU -- CENTER THERE ALSO
FOR THAT.
QUESTION -- THIS IS BEEN
INTERESTING BONE OF CONTENTION.
BECAUSE THAT PROVISION FOR THE
IN THE MOVIE WAS PLACED IN THE
BILL AT THE REQUEST OF NONPROFIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
THE PEOPLE WHO BUILD A 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. FOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE -- BECAUSE THOSE
FEES GO TO FIND OUT A 100% FOR
WHETHER IT'S FOR FORMALLY
HOMELESS PEOPLE. FOR SENIORS OR
WHATEVER THERE'S BEEN CONCERN
ABOUT THAT AND WHAT I'VE ON THE
EQUITY ADVOCATES ARE THE HOUSING
ADVOCATES WHO RAISES CONCERNS.
I'VE ENCOURAGE -- TO ENTER INTO
DIALOGUE WITH THE NONPROFIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
THIS IS A PROGRESSIVE.
DISCUSSION AND AND I YOU KNOW WE
CAN GO IN DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS
ON THAT BUT I JUST WANNA FROM
ABOUT TWICE.
IT'S IN THE BILL OKAY IT WAS NOT
OR IT WAS NOT MY ORIGINAL
INTENTION.
OKAY -- ANOTHER QUESTION IS.
I THINK THIS IS BROUGHT UP BY
ONE OF THE SPEAKERS IS -- WHERE
GENTRIFICATION IS ALREADY UNDER
WAY -- HOW DO WE IS OUR WAY OR
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
SENSITIVE COMMUNITIES ALSO?
INCLUDES THAT MAYBE YOU COULD
EXPLAIN THAT.
SIR CAN YOU COULD YOU JUST YEAH.
THIS IS ABOUT -- AREAS WERE
GENTRIFICATION IS ALREADY UNDER
WAY LIKE HOW DOES THE DEFINITION
OF A SENSE OF COMMUNITY.
INCLUDES THAT AND NOT SO MUCH
JUST.
YOU KNOW LEVELS OF POVERTY OR
SEGREGATION BUT THERE'S ALSO
ISSUES OF GENTRIFICATION THAT
HAVE ALREADY STARTED.
SORRY I WASN'T SPEAKING WORLD I
MEAN ON THE SIDE -- SO -- CENTER
THANK YOU FOR THAT THE THE THE
SENSITIVE COMMUNITY DISCUSSION
AS A CONTINUING -- ONE THERE'S
BEEN -- WORK THAT IS HAPPEN ON
THAT ISSUE BOTH AT A AT A
STATEWIDE LEVEL -- AND ALSO IN
THE BAY AREA -- AND WE PROVIDE
SOME A LOT OF STUDENTS TERMS OF
ADMINISTRATIVE IMPLEMENTATION --
AND THAT'LL BE A CONTINUING OUR
DISCUSSION -- WE I WANT ONE
THING I DO WANT TO KNOW I'M ONLY
BECAUSE THE META FROM THE
MISSION.
WHAT'S YOUR TESTIFYING AGAINST
THE THERE ARE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY THIS IS NOT ALL THERE
AREAS LIKE ITSELF LA OR PARTS OF
OAKLAND -- THAT ARE ZONED -- LOW
DENSITY BUT WE KNOW THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY.
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES -- ARE
OFTEN ZONE THAT HIGH DENSITY
ALREADY BECAUSE THAT'S BEEN THE
INEQUITABLE APPROACH WE TAKE IN
THE HOUSING FOR A LONG TIME IN
THE STATE OR WEALTHIER.
PLACES HAVE LOW DENSITY SINGLE
FAMILY HOME -- AND LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES CUTS ON FOR DENSITY --
THE MISSION -- IS ZONED FOR
SIGNIFICANT DENSITY -- AND SO I
THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
KEEP IN MIND THAT THERE ARE
PLENTY OF COMMUNITIES.
THAT ARE AT RISK FOR BEING
GENDER FIGHTER MAYBE GENTRIFIED.
THAT WON'T HAVE MUCH IMPACT FROM
THIS BILL BECAUSE ARE ALREADY
ZONED. FOR DENSITY -- BUT THAT
WILL BE A CONTINUING DISCUSSION --
SO LET ME JUST SAY HI -- WE'VE
HAD SOME CONVERSATIONS YOU AND I
I KNOW YOU WORKED EXTREMELY HARD
OVER THE LAST AT LEAST TWO YEARS
IF NOT LONGER.
UP MANY YEARS SEVERAL YEARS AN
AND I APPRECIATE KNOW EVERY TIME
THAT YOU GOT ANOTHER
ORGANIZATION TO SUPPORT YOU GOT
VERY EXCITED BECAUSE YOU'RE
COALITION WAS GROWING.
AND AS A COALITION BUILDER I
TRULY BELIEVE IN THAT SO I
COMMEND YOU FOR THAT NIGHT I
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK -- I
REPRESENT A VERY DIFFERENT OF
VERY DIVERSE PART OF LOS ANGELES --
AND CERTAINLY GENTRIFICATION IS
VERY VERY HIGH ON THE LIST OF
CONCERNS -- THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF VERY SIGNIFICANT
ORGANIZATIONS -- IN LOS ANGELES
THAT EVER REACHED OUT TO ME.
AND THEY REPRESENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES -- AND
THEIR THEIR WORK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IN MY DISTRICT SO --
I'M NOT THE EXPERT I'M SURE
YOU'RE BECOMING IF NOT ALREADY
ON EXPERT -- BUT I RELY ON THEM
VERY MUCH FOR THE KIND OF
HOUSING POLICY THAT -- WE SHOULD
HAVE IN LOS ANGELES -- I'M OPEN
TO SUPPORTING -- THIS BILL
BECAUSE I I KNOW YOU SAID
SEVERAL TIMES THAT YOU'RE
WILLING TO CONTINUE TO MEET WITH
ORGANIZATIONS -- SO TO MOVE
THROUGH THE FIRST STEP OF THE
POLICY PROCESS SO THAT YOU CAN
CONTINUE OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
ALL RIGHT OBVIOUSLY I INTEND TO
BE MORE INVOLVED WITH THE
ORGANIZATION SO THAT I CAN
BETTER -- EXPLAIN TO YOU -- FROM
MY POINT OF VIEW AND THEIR POINT
OF VIEW WHAT THE ISSUES ARE OF
CONCERN -- SO I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
DO WHAT YOU'VE ALREADY COMMITTED
TO DO -- AND I HOPE THAT THEY'LL
BE SOME INCLUSION OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE REFLECTED IN
THE BILL -- THE NEXT TIME BEFORE
IT'S BEFORE IT'S A A COMES TO US --
I DO WANT TO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE SISTERS AND BROTHERS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION.
INDUSTRY IN THE CONSTRUCTION
UNIONS BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE IN
VERY GOOD JOBS THE ONLY WAY TO
REBUILD OUR OUR MIDDLE CLASS.
AND I KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT -- FOR
MORE APPRENTICES AND JOURNEYMEN
AND WOMEN SO I APPRECIATE THEM
ALSO BEING ON ON SUPPORT OF THE
VIEW.
I HOPE THIS DOESN'T BECOME OF OF
US VERSUS THEM SITUATION BECAUSE
WORKING CLASS COMMUNITIES NEED
EACH OTHER WE'RE NEVER GONNA.
RESOLVE THE ISSUE OF HOUSING OR
OF GOOD JOBS IF WERE PITTED
AGAINST EACH OTHER SO.
I'M RELYING ON YOU TAKE ALL THIS
INTO ACCOUNT AND LET'S.
CHANGE THIS OF OF PROPOSED
LEGISLATION ENOUGH SO THAT OTHER
CONCERNS ARE BROUGHT IN SO THANK
YOU AGAIN CENTER.
THANK CENTER MORLOCK BECAUSE
CENTER.
OTHER THAN THAT NO PRESSURE.
CENTER WIENER -- IT'S AN
AMBITIOUS BILL IN IT IT
[inaudible]
PROVIDES CHANGE.
AND CHANGE CREATES A LEVEL OF
ANXIETY SO I APPRECIATE THE GOOD
DISCUSSION AND ALL THE HARD WORK
TO BE DONE FOR THE LAST.
FEW MONTHS THERE'S A LOT A LOT
HERE-- I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DEFINITIONS AND SO YOU'VE GOT
SOME GREAT NEW TERMS HIGH
QUALITY BUS CORRIDOR JOBS RICH
AREA HI I HIRE.
A MAJOR TRANSIT STOP -- AND SO --
I WOULD APPRECIATE I KNOW YOU
DON'T HAVE IT TODAY BUT MAYBE IN
IN THAT THE NEAR FUTURE IF YOU
COULD DEVELOP A MAP.
OF THE LEAST SAFE FOR ORANGE
COUNTY WERE YOU YOU HAVE A TRAIN
STOP HALF MILE.
CIRCLE AROUND THAT IN.
YOU KNOW THEN.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS A YOU KNOW SOME
OF THESE OTHER TRANSIT
OPPORTUNITIES SOME OF THESE --
DRAWBRIDGE YOU KNOW BECAUSE THAT
WERE WERE READY JUST LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO WE'RE WE'RE JUST
BEHIND YOU AND DENSITY.
SO ARM WOULD LOVE TO SEE WHAT
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THIRTY FOUR CITY COUNCILS
THEY ALL KINDA.
YOU KNOW PERK UP AND IT WOULD BE
NICE JUST TO SHOW AN OVERLAY OF
OKAY HERE'S WHAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH.
THE SECOND IS.
THE NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA
THAT'S AS BEFORE.
SO DO I HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
YOURS AND AS BEFORE OR DOES THE
LAST WHEN THEY GET SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR PREVAIL OR WHAT WE WHAT
WE DOING ON THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION -- AS CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MY RECOMMENDATION IS
FOR BOTH BILLS TO MOVE OUT OF
COMMITTEE -- SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
I AS I NOTED IN MY OPENING
REMARKS ARE WORKING INTENSIVELY
TOGETHER TO TRY -- TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER AS OPPOSED
TO HAVING COMPETING BILLS AND I
KNOW.
HE IS STUCK IN JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE NOW I KNOW HE HAD
WANTED TO MAKE SOME REMARKS I TO
THAT HE'S JUST RELAY THAT TO ME
WERE -- IN AGREEMENT -- THAT WE
WANT BOTH BILLS -- TO MOVE OUT --
AND TO CONTINUE THAT -- THE
CONVERSATION.
BUT THEY ARE COMPETITIVE BILLS
THEY'RE SIMILAR WITH THEIR SOME
UNIQUE DIFFERENCES AND WE'RE
GONNA.
THE WHY AND OPTIMISTIC THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO NOT
HAVE COMPETITIVE BILLS.
THE WRITING WORKING VERY HARD
TOGETHER. TO COME TOGETHER AND
MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER CENTER
MCGUIRE AND I AND YEAH SO I I'M
OUR GOAL IS FOR NOT FOR THAT NOT
TO BE THE CASE NOW A LOOK
FORWARD TO THE NEXT PRESENTATION.
SENATOR AND CONSIDER THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN.
SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU SIR WIENER FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS VERY DIFFICULT
PROBLEMS ONE OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING ISSUES I THINK
FACING THE STATE -- SOME
QUESTIONS WITH RESPECT TO THE
AREAS OF FOCUS -- ONE OF YOURS A
FOCUS UNDERSTAND IT'S QUARTER
MILE [inaudible]
OF RADIUS -- IN CONNECTION WITH
A BUS STOP ON A FORGOTTEN THE
TERM HIGH FREQUENCY HIGH
FREQUENCY CORRIDOR.
SO.
IF IF THAT BUS STOP MOVE WHAT
HAPPENS OF THAT BUS STOP MOVES
TWO YEARS AFTER [inaudible]
CONSTRUCTION BEGINS.
BOB ONE OF THE REASONS -- UP
FIRST OF ALL -- BY STOCKS FIVE
YES IT'S POSSIBLE FOR A BUS STOP
TO MOVE -- I DON'T THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS ALL THE
TIME AND SINCE WHEN IT DOES
HAPPEN IT MIGHT BE A MOVES
ACROSS THE STREET ONE BLOCK OVER --
SO IS IT POSSIBLE FOR BOTH OF
THEM OF COURSE IT IS I DON'T
THINK IT'S A COMMON. ONE OF THE
READING WE ORIGINALLY PROPOSED
THIS BILL IS SP TWO SEVEN LAST
YEAR.
BOB BUS STOPS TRIGGERED THE SAME
HEIGHT CHANGES THAT FIXED RAIL
THAT.
OUGHT WE TO IN RESPONSE TO YOUR
EXACT QUESTION WE CHANGE IT TO
SAY THIS BILL WILL DEFER TO
LOCAL HEIGHT LIMITS AROUND
BOSSES. TO TRY TO STRIKE THAT
BALANCE BUT IN THE END GOD
SOMEONE BILLS SAY AN ITALIAN
ABILITY THING AND THE BUS STOP
MOVED.
A FEW BLOCKS OVER IT THAT'S NOT
THE END OF THE WORLD WE HAVE
APARTMENT BUILDINGS ALL OVER.
CALIFORNIA NOT ENOUGH PLACES
SINCE MOST OF IT IS KNOWN TO MAN
AT BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF OUR
BUILDINGS THAT WERE BUILT BEFORE
THOSE BANDS WENT INTO EFFECT --
SO I I DON'T SEE IT AS A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM.
I THINK IN AREAS THAT ARE
DEVELOP SERVICES GO FOR EXAMPLE
IT'S LESS OF AN ISSUE THAN AREAS
THAT ARE DEVELOPING -- WHERE?
ROUTES CHANGE DENSITY CHANGES
AND YOU CAN MOVE A BIT BUS STOPS.
MAY MOVE A QUARTER OF A MILE OR
HALF A MILE.
SO THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEND A
LITTLE TIME WITH YOU.
TRYING TO SEE IF WE CAN'T
SOMEHOW -- MAKE SURE WE WE WE
DEAL WITH THAT ISSUE SO THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE.
SORT OF A A BUS STOP EVERY
QUARTER OF A MILE WHICH
BASICALLY -- CHANGES.
CHANGES THE THE WHOLE TENOR THAT
BILLS WE WOULD WELCOME THAT
DIALOGUE IN YOUR FEEDBACK ONE
THING I WHY I DO WANT TO JUST
MAKE CLEAR AND WITH THE SUPPLIES
TO AT ASHOKE I SET HIGH
FREQUENCY IT'S WITH A BIG LABEL
AT HIGH QUALITY BOSS QUARTER.
AND IT'S AROUND THE BUS STOP NOT
AROUND AREAS IN BETWEEN THEM.
ON AND IT HAS TO BE IT IS VERY
ROBUST SERVICE SO IT HAS TO RUN
FROM. SIX AM TO TEN PM MONDAY
THROUGH FRIDAY -- DURING THE
RUSH HOUR PERIODS WHICH ARE AT
LEAST THREE HOURS WITHIN THE SIX
AM.
TO TEN AM -- FOR THREE HOURS
WITHIN THREE TO SEVEN PM IT HAS
TO RUN A FIFTEEN MINUTE HEADWAYS.
AND THEN FOR THE REST OF THE
DAYS OF THE TIME PERIOD FROM SIX
AM. TO TEN PM IT HAS TO RUN A
TWENTY MINUTE HEADWAYS AND THEN
ON SATURDAY AND SUNDAY FROM
EIGHT AM TO TEN PM THAT HAS TO
RUN A THIRTY MINUTE HEADWAYS SO
THIS IS.
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S A GOOD
POINT OUR BUS MAY NOT RUN THAT
OFFICE ROBUST IT'S ROBUST
SERVICE BUT WE WE LOOK FORWARD
TO THAT CONVERSATION CENTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR SKINNER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M CENTER WIENER I WANT.
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
INCREDIBLE WORK YOU'VE DONE OVER
THE LAST.
YEAR.
I SAY YEAR BECAUSE IT WAS ABOUT
A YEAR AO I WAS SITTING IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE FIRST ATTEMPT
WHICH I WASA CO AUTHOR OF SB.
EIGHT TWO SEVEN I DID NOT
[inaudible]
MOVE FORT [inaudible]
AND WHAT YOU DID SINCE THAT TIME.
WAS TO REALLY.
REACH OUT TO ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE.
THAT.
HAD VARIOUS OPINIONS ABOUT.
HOW A?
INCREASE DENSITY AROUND TRANSIT.
BILL MIGHT HELP US IN THIS
HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE'RE IN.
NOW WHEN I THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE OUTREACH AND
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE AND THE
COALITION YOU BUILT I AM NOT.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR I'M NOT
DISRESPECTING THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE OPPOSE.
BUT I THINK THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE BILL NOW.
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR I WAS
WILLING TO SUPPORT LAST YEAR'S
BILL.
THERE ARE.
IT IS MORE LIMITED.
THERE ARE FOUR FAR MORE.
CAN I PROTECTIONS.
AND THERE IT IMPACTS COMMUNITIES
NEIGHBORHOODS SOME MAY SAY
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WHERE.
SOMEBODY FOR NEIGHBORHOODS
ALREADY HAVE BEEN SERIOUSLY
GENTRIFIED BUT THE WAY THIS IS
STRUCTURED IS THAT.
IT [inaudible]
DOES NOT.
ADD THIS INCREASE DENSITY IN
THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS THAT.
WHERE THE GENTRIFICATION HASN'T
COMPLETELY YOU KNOW IS NOT?
YET A FETE ACCOMPLI.
AND I REALLY RESPECT THAT AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE -- WE YOU SAID IN
YOUR OPENING.
I THINK WE KNOW IT.
WE'VE HEARD IT FROM THE GOVERNOR
WE'VE HEARD IT FOR ANY ANY SET
OF DATA POINTS THAT WE LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA IS IN A HOUSING
CRISIS.
NO CERTAINLY MANY OF US LOOK AT
IT THROUGH THE LENS OF
AFFORDABILITY.
BUT WE HAVE TO ALSO LOOK AT IT
THROUGH THE LENS OF SUPPLY
[inaudible]
AND WHILE.
I AM NOT THE BIGGEST FAN OF
UNFETTERED.
MARKET CAPITALISM AND I'LL BE UP
FRONT ABOUT THAT.
THE FACT IS THAT.
OUR THIRTY TO FORTY YEAR
SUPPRESSION OF BUILDING HOUSING
IN CALIFORNIA.
HAS COME BACK TO HARNESS.
AND THAT.
LACK OF SUPPLY THE FACT THAT IN
YOU STAYED IN YOU AGAIN ANY DATA
POINT ANYONE WANTS TO LOOK AT WE
ARE.
FORTY NINE IN NUMBER OF UNITS
PER CAPITA [inaudible] FORTY
NINE WE HAVE THIRTY THREE OF THE
HIGHEST RENT CITIES IN THE
ENTIRE U. S. OUT OF FIFTY TO
PURCHASE A HOUSE COST TWO POINT
FIVE TIMES MORE THAN ANYWHERE
ELSE IN THE COUNTRY.
THESE ARE FACTORS OF SCARCITY
SCARCITY DRIVES UP PRICES.
THE DRIVING DRIVING UP OF PRICES
THEN DRIVES PEOPLE OUT.
CREATES HOMELESSNESS.
YES WE HAVE TO BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING YES WE HAVE
TO HAVE INCLUSIONARY YES WE HAVE
TO HAVE ALL THOSE THINGS BUT WE
ARE STILL NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS OUR HOUSING CRISIS
WITHOUT AN INCREASE IN SUPPLY.
AND THIS IS A REASONABLE AND
SMART INCREASE IN SUPPLY BECAUSE
IT IS AROUND OR TRANSIT AREAS.
AND I COMPLETELY SUPPORT
[inaudible]
DOES RESULT [inaudible]
NOW.
I APPRECIATE THOSE.
FOLKS WHO'VE COME TO THE THE
MIKE TO COME HERE AT THE HEARING
BECAUSE THE VERY FEARFUL.
THAT THEY COULD BE DISPLACED
FROM THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND CERTAINLY WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE WAY PRICES HAVE GONE UP IN
ANY.
OF OUR JOB RICH AREAS WERE ALL
THE FREE TO THAT.
I AM IN A YOU KNOW I'M ABOVE
MIDDLE CLASS.
BUT IF I WERE TO LOSE MY HOUSE
TODAY I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
LIVE IN MY COMMUNITY OF BERKELEY.
AND INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH RIGHT
NOW IN BERKELEY THE BIGGEST
CHANGE.
IN THE LAST TWO SENTENCES.
HAVE BEEN HAS BEEN THE AVERAGE
INCOME OF BERKELEY RESIDENTS WHY.
BECAUSE HOUSING IS SO EXPENSIVE
KNOW WHAT A BERKELEY DO BERKELEY
IN THE SEVENTIES PASSED THE
NEIGHBORHOOD PRESERVATION
ORDINANCE WHICH BASICALLY
PREVENTED BERKELEY FROM ALLOWING
ANY APARTMENT BUILDINGS.
TODAY THE VERY FEW APARTMENT
BUILDINGS THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
BUILT IN THE LAST. EIGHT YEARS
BUT PRIOR TO THAT NONE WERE
BUILT.
OVER GOOD THIRTY YEAR PERIOD.
TODAY THE ONLY LOW INCOME PEOPLE
THAT STILL REMAIN A BERKELEY ARE
IN THOSE APARTMENT BUILDINGS
THAT WERE BUILT PRE THE
NEIGHBORHOOD PRESERVATION
ORDINANCE -- UNLESS YOU HAVE
LIVED IN A SINGLE FAMILY HOME
THAT IS RENT CONTROLLED FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OR MORE.
YOU PRETTY MUCH CAN'T AFFORD
ANYWHERE TO LIVE IN BERKELEY.
UNLESS YOU AGAIN WERE ON SECTION
EIGHT WHICH MOST RENT MOST
OWNERS IN BERKELEY WON'T EVEN
TAKE A SECTION EIGHT TENANT
ANYMORE BECAUSE THEY CAN GET SO
MUCH MORE.
IN A MARKET RATE.
AND I USE JUST MY CITY IS
EXAMPLE BECAUSE I KNOW IT SO
WELL BUT I COULD USE MANY MANY
MANY MANY MANY OTHER CITIES.
SO WE HAVE TO FIX IT AND THIS IS
ONE WAY TO FIX IT AND I DON'T
BLAME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ALONE
THERE ARE SO MANY FACTORS THAT
CONTRIBUTED TO BURKE TO
CALIFORNIA.
UNDER BUILDING THERE ARE SO MANY
FACTORS PRIVATE SECTOR WASN'T
INVESTING IN URBAN AREAS FOR
RESIDENTIAL PROP THIRTEEN DIDN'T
MOTIVATE ANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THERE'S SO MANY FACTORS BUT WHEN
YOU TAKE THE COLLECTIVE.
INDIVIDUAL DECISIONS BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OVER THIS ENTIRE
PERIOD OF TIME AND ALL THOSE
OTHER FACTORS YOU HAVE THE
CRISIS WE HAVE TODAY AND WE HAVE
TO FIX IT.
AND I SUPPORT RENT CONTROL I
SUPPORTED PROP.
TEN I SUPPORT JUST BECAUSE
EVICTION AND I KNOW THAT MANY OF
THE FOLKS.
THAT SUPPORT THIS BILL THAT ARE
MORE IN THE BUILDING BUT YOU
KNOW IN THAT SPHERE ARE NOT AS
HAPPY WITH THOSE TYPES OF
POLICIES THIS BILL DOESN'T
NECESSARILY ADDRESS THOSE.
BUT WE HAVE TO DO BOTH WE HAVE
TO PROTECT EXISTING TENANTS AND
WE HAVE TO BUILD MORE FOR WERE
NOT GOING TO GET OUT OF THIS
CRISIS AND THIS BILL.
IS.
APPROPRIATE AND RIGHT
ADDITIONALLY.
WE HAVE SUPER COMMUTING
CALIFORNIA NOW.
SUPER COMMUTES BECAUSE THE VERY
FEW PEOPLE THAT ARE YET HOMELESS.
LIVE. EIGHTY TO A HUNDRED TWO
MORE MILES AWAY FROM THEIR JOBS.
BECAUSE THE THAT'S A HUNDRED
MILES AWAY IS THE ONLY PLACE
THEY CAN AFFORD THAT IS WRONG.
AND WE HAVE TO FIX THAT ALSO SO
I AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE -- AND IF THANK YOU.
SENATOR BATES THANK YOU.
LET ME ADD MY OUR KUDOS ON TO
YOU SENATOR WINNER FOR TAKING ON
A PROJECT LONG OVERDUE.
CERTAINLY ARE LOTS OF WORK NEEDS
TO BE DONE ON UNFORTUNATELY I'M
NOT COULD BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY ON MY BIGGEST ISSUE THE
HAS BEEN AND I THINK OF SHARE
THAT WITH YOU ALL ALONG IS THE
PARKING.
RESTRICTIONS THAT WILL BE LIFTED
BECAUSE PARKING IN OUR SUBURBAN
COMMUNITIES TO DRIVE SO MANY
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES I WANT.
YOU KNOW GET INTO SO MANY OF
THOSE TODAY BUT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO DISCUSS AS WE GO FORWARD I
JUST LIKE.
TO I ASK A FEW QUESTIONS ARE --
BEGINNING WITH THE DEFINITION HI
JOBS RICH AREA IT'S IDENTIFIED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ANNOUNCES
SENSITIVE COMMUNITY.
AND I'M WONDERING IF THAT IS
PRESENT IT IN IF IT'S RESPECTIVE
LAWRENCE RETRO ACTIVE.
AS WE GO FORWARD WHEN SOMEONE
COMES TO A COMMUNITY AND WANTS
TO DEVELOP -- A PROPERTY AND
SEEKS THE DEFINITION TO ALLOW
THEM TO GO FORWARD WHAT IS THE
POINT IN TIME BECAUSE I THINK
THESE ARE TWO AREAS THAT COULD --
BE GAME TO A LITTLE BIT
DEPENDING ON ON THE APPLICATION
PROCESS.
HOW DO YOU SEE THESE SUPPLIED --
IN THE CURRENT WHEN THIS GOES
INTO EFFECT IS IT TWENTY TWENTY
AND THEN SOME COMMUNITIES ARE
GOING TO BE ALLOWED AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE OR SIX YEARS TO
IMPLEMENT A PLAN.
WHICH COULD CHANGE THIS
DRAMATICALLY IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
PLAN COMMUNITY PLAN AND I BRING
THAT UP BECAUSE MOST OF SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY.
WAS DEVELOPED A LONG PLANNED
COMMUNITY PLANS WHICH INCLUDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING LOW INCOME --
APARTMENTS WE HAVE A LOT OF
APARTMENTS IN SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY SOME I THINK MANY
COMMUNITIES ARE STILL WORKING ON
THE RENO.
THAT TIME NOT TO THEY'RE NOT
UNDER GREATLY BECAUSE WE'VE HAD
MAKES USE MUCH OF THAT SO THESE
ARE THINGS THAT.
INVOLVE OUR HOW WOULD YOU SEE
THOSE SUPPLIED GOING FORWARD.
SO IN TERMS OF THE JOB BRIDGE
AREA.
CATEGORY IN GENERAL -- THE BILL --
REQUIRES EACH CD AND TWENTY
TWENTY AND THEN EVERY FIVE YEARS
THEREAFTER TO PUBLISH -- THOSE
MAPS SO IT WILL BE UPDATED.
ON EVERY FIVE EVERY FIVE YEARS
THROUGH EACH COMMUNITY. FIVE THE
CITY WAS YOUR MAP FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE -- THAT WAS CHAU WHAT
QUALIFIES AS A JOB RICH OUR
COMMUNITY.
UNDER HEIR STANDARDS THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING OUT FOR THAT YES
AND THOSE ARE THE BILL CONTAINS
ENUMERATION -- AND THEY'RE ALSO
THERE ARE METHODOLOGIES THAT THE
STATE HAS EMPLOYED.
IN THE PAST AROUND -- THIS ISSUE
SO THIS IS NOT -- RECREATING THE
WHEEL FROM SCRATCH ALTHOUGH OF
COURSE HAVE TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
TO CONFORM THE BILL BUT THEY'VE
DONE THIS KIND OF WORK -- BEFORE
SO IT'S NOT BRAND NEW IN IS NOT
ARBITRARY FELT WHAT ARBITRARY IT
IS DEFINITELY NOT ARBITRARY THEN
SECOND ITEM IS UNDER THE
CONCESSIONS THAT ARE GRANTED I
THINK YOU SAID.
THE SETBACKS WOULD NOT BE
AFFECTED YEAH THE CONCESSIONS
THAT ARE GRANTED THERE'S THREE
ADDITIONAL ONES UNDER THE
CURRENT DENSITY BONUS LAW IN ONE
OF THOSE IS A REDUCTION AND SITE
DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS.
ARCHITECTURAL DESIGN
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING SET BACK
AND I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE AND THAT WOULD
BE GRANTED HAS AN ADDITIONAL
CONCESSION ACCORDING TO USING
THE EXISTING DENSITY BONUS LIE
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT.
WELL THE THE DENSITY BONUSES
EXISTING LAW YEAH HAS ITS
PROVISIONS -- AND WE'RE NOT
CHANGING.
WHAT THE DENSITY BONUS --
PROVIDES BUT IT IS THAT IT
WOULDN'T AFFECT SET BACKS AND
THIS WOULD SUGGEST THAT IT COULD
AFFECT.
SET BACKS IF THEY ARE GRANTED
ANOTHER CONCESSION UNDER SOMEONE
INVOKES THE DENSITY BONUS BUT
THEY CAN INVOKE DENSITY BONUS ON
AFFECTS UP BOX TODAY.
YEAH.
SO THEN IT'S NOT.
CONSISTENT THAT YOUR CURRENT
BILL WOULD NOT A FAX SETBACK.
REQUIREMENTS PUT ON OR SOMEHING
BY A SB FIFTY ITSELF -- DOES NOT.
OVERRIDE SAID THERE IS A NARROW
CATEGORY OF IF THERE'S SOME
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE.
WHAT WE MIGHT CALL ABUSIVE
SETBACKS ARE DESIGNED TO MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO BUILD ANYTHING
RIGHT PUTTING THAT ASIDE --
SETBACKS ON OR NOT OVER WRITTEN
IN THIS BILL BUT THE DENSITY
BONUS EXISTING STATE DENSITY
BONUS PROGRAM THE TIME IMPACT
SETBACKS.
AND WE'RE NOT CHANGING WHAT THE
DENSITY BONUS -- PROVIDES OUR
ALLOWANCE.
BETTER SAID YOUR BILL DOESN'T
ADD.
TO WHAT'S CURRENTLY GIVEN AND
LAW.
IT DOESN'T GIVE ALL AROUND
DENSITY AND IN SOME SITUATIONS
HIGH AND IT DOES THAT ARE THERE
THAT WE DO IN SOME RESPECTS.
BUT PERCENT X. IT WOULD BE THE
DENSITY BONUS SECOND IMPACTS UP
BOX.
I'M NOT YOUR BILL NOT IT'S
BECAUSE THE BUT IF SOMEONE
INVOKES THE DENSITY BONUS.
BEN DATE BACK AND IMPACTS THAT
BOX BUT THAT IS A LOT TODAY.
OKAY THAT'S GOING A LITTLE
CONFUSED ON THAT ONE FINALLY ON
THE JOHN GENTRIFICATION.
ISSUE ARE CERTAINLY AND ARE LOS
ANGELES AREA SO I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH HAVING BEEN A
FORMER ALSO.
FORMER SOCIAL WORKER A LOT OF
THE PROJECTS -- AND THE LOWER
INCOME HOUSING AND SOME OF OUR
SOUTH PHILLY AREAS DO LIE AND
THE VERY ARE ALL.
GREAT TRANSIT AREAS A JOB RICH
AREAS BECAUSE ARE CLOSE TO YOU --
TRANSIT AND BUS SERVICE SO I
THINK THAT THE ISSUES BROUGHT UP
BY THOSE WHO ARE VERY CONCERNED
ARE VERY REAL AND KNOWING THAT
YOU'RE GOING.
TO TAKE A DEEPER -- LOOK AT THAT
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING AND
SOMETIMES BECOMES ALMOST THE THE
MOTIVATION -- FOR THOSE PROJECTS
TO COME FORWARD SO.
I'M JUST SAYING THAT THAT WOULD
BE ANOTHER CONCERN OF MINE --
HAVING WALKED THE BOX MANY YEARS
AGO.
THIS COULD DISPLACE LARGE
POPULATIONS OVER THE COURSE OF
THE SEVEN YEARS OR EVEN BEYOND.
SO I'M CENTER MAY I I REALLY I I
APPRECIATE THAT COMMENT AND I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT --
TO TALK ABOUT GENTRIFICATION AND
WHAT CAUSES GENTRIFICATION.
I LIVE IN A NEIGHBORHOOD CALLED
THE CASTRO IN SAN FRANCISCO THAT
HAS EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT
GENTRIFICATION ILIVE ABOUT FIVE
BLOCKS AWAY FROM THE WESTERN
EDGE OF THE MISSION.
WHICH HAS EXPERIENCED FOR THE
LAST -- YOU KNOW GOING BACK AT
LEAST FIFTY YEARS SIGNIFICANT --
GENTRIFICATION WITH THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES ARE
BEING PUSHED OUT.
AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHAT
CAUSES GENTRIFICATION AND IT'S A
COMPLICATED ISSUE BUT ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE MAIN FACTORS ARE
CAUSES GENTRIFICATION
DISPLACEMENT.
IS NOT HAVING ENOUGH HOUSING.
FIVE AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH HOUSING IT EXPLODES
HOUSING COSTS AND PEOPLE GET
PUSHED OUT.
WE HAD A HUGE FIGHT SAN
FRANCISCO -- HEARD ABOUT THE
MISSION BEFORE WE HAD A HUGE
FIGHT ABOUT FOUR YEARS AGO ABOUT
AN EFFORT TO PUT A MORATORIUM ON
HOUSING IN PLACE IN THE NATION --
BECAUSE OF A CONCERN THAT NEW
DEVELOPMENT WAS UP CAUSING
GENTRIFICATION PUSHING PEOPLE
OUT.
WHAT TURNS OUT THAT AT THAT
MOMENT IN TIME AS OF AROUND
TWENTY FIFTEEN FOR THE LAST
DECADE OR SO THE MISSION HAD
SEEN ONE OF THE LOWEST?
NUMBER OF NEW HOUSING BEING
ADDED IT WAS TOWARDS THE BOTTOM
OF THE LIST AND SAN FRANCISCO IN
TERMS OF NUMBER OF NEW UNITS OUT
OF VERY LITTLE NEW.
DEVELOPMENT HAD ACTUALLY
HAPPENED IN THE MISSION THERE
WAS PLANS FOR THE FUTURE.
VERY LITTLE HAD HAPPENED YET
THAT MISSION WAS EXPERIENCING
TERRIBLE DISPLACEMENT.
AND GENTRIFICATION TO THIS
NOTION THAT IT'S NEW
DEVELOPMENTS IN NEW HOUSING THAT
IS CAUSING DISPLACEMENT -- WHILE
OF COURSE WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL
IF YOU START ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
START TEARING DOWN EVICTING
PEOPLE IN TEARING DOWN BUILDINGS
YES THAT IS DISPLACEMENT AND WE
TRY TO PROTECT AGAINST SIDE.
IN THIS BILL -- BUT WHAT THE
HEART OF DISPLACEMENT IS
EXPLOSIVE HOUSING COSTS BECAUSE
IN CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST
FIFTY YEARS WE HAVE MADE IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO BUILD ENOUGH
HOUSING. FOR A GROWING STATE
WE'RE PRETTY WE'RE ACTING LIKE
WE'RE STILL A STATE OF TEN
MILLION PEOPLE WHEN WE'RE STATE
OF FORTY MILLION PEOPLE --
HEADING TOWARDS FIFTY MILLION --
AND SO -- THE ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT THINGS WE CAN DO IN
ADDITION TO TENER PROTECTIONS TO
REDUCE DISPLACEMENT IS TO
ACTUALLY ALLOW ENOUGH HOUSING
FOR EVERYONE THAT'S MY
PERSPECTIVE ON THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU SEVEN AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR YOUR EFFORTS THANK
AND ALTHOUGH THE ON GOING.
AND MORLOCK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF SEVERE WINTER JUST WHEN
I GET BACK TO IT.
A LITTLE DIFFERENT TOPIC.
BECAUSE YOUR YOUR WHOLE PREMISE
IS BASED ON TRANSIT ANTI WANNA
TALK ABOUT TRANSIT A LITTLE BIT --
I'M I COME FROM A SCHOOL WHERE
YOU YOU KNOW THE TREND IS YOUR
FRIEND.
AND AND WE'RE SEEING TRANSIT
DECLINE WE'RE SEEING LIKE A 40%
46% REDUCTION IN LA AND OTHER
AREAS.
THE ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY SING BROKE BUS
RIDERSHIP DECLINED.
RATHER DRAMATICALLY UP TO THE
POINT WHERE IT'S ALMOST.
YOU KNOW YOU GOT IT CAN I DO A
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS KIND OF
STUDY ON WHETHER IT'S STILL.
WORTH PURSUING SO PEOPLE ARE
UING WHAT WITH THEIR UBER OR
NEVER GOT.
AN AGE OF SELF DRIVING CARS
WHICH WE WOULD BE PERSONAL RAPID
TRANSIT.
SO THERE THERE'S LIKE A PUSH
AWAY FROM.
TRAINS AND BUSES WHEN A TRAIN
FAILS EVERYBODY'S YOU KNOW STOCK
AND THEY CAN.
DO YOU KNOW THEY'RE JUST STUCK.
SO I'M JUST KIND OF CURIOUS.
IF YOU COULD COMMENT ON ON THOSE
CONCERNS IT IS IS THIS THE RIGHT
[inaudible]
PREMISE [inaudible]
AND WHY.
ABSOLUTELY -- I THINK WE WANT TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO
LIVE NEAR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
UNTIL LIVE NEAR WHERE WITH WITH
NEAR WHERE THEY WORK -- AS A
MATTER OF ENVIRONMENT AS A
MATTER OF NOT FORCING PEOPLE TO
COMMUTE TWO HOURS.
AS IT'S JUST A MATTER OF HAVING --
HEALTHIER FAMILIES SO PEOPLE
AREN'T GETTING HOME AT NINE
O'CLOCK AT NIGHT WHEN THEIR KIDS
ARE ALREADY IN BED BECAUSE THEY
JUST HAD A TWO AND A HALF HOUR
COMMUTE -- SO I I DO THINK THE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
IS A VERY APPROPRIATE WAY OF
DETERMINING WHERE YOU SHOULD
HAVE A MORE HOUSING -- BECAUSE
ALTHOUGH SOME PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO DRIVE YOU WANT TO GIVE THESE
GIVE PEOPLE THE OPTION NOT TO
DRIVE.
ON NOW WHEN WE TALK ABOUT AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SOME OF THE DECLINING RATES OF
TRANSIT USAGE THERE ARE AGAINST
COMPLICATED THERE'S NO ONE
REASON -- ONE OF THOSE REASONS --
WE SEE WE KNOW THE TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP IS IS GOING TO
STRUGGLE IF YOU DON'T ALLOW
DENSITY.
AROUND THOSE TRANSIT PODS --
BECAUSE IF PEOPLE CAN'T LIVE
NEAR WHERE THE TRANSIT AS THEIR
VERY MUCH LESS LIKELY TO USE IT --
WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR LOW INCOME
PEOPLE TO LIVE NEAR TRANSIT --
LOW INCOME PEOPLE ARE -- THE
MOST LIKELY OUR WRITERS OF
TRANSIT -- AND THAT'S TRUE IN A
LOT OF AREAS ALTHOUGH THERE ARE
ALSO AREAS WHERE THERE'S A LOT
OF YOU KNOW BOTH MIDDLE CLASS
AND LOWER INCOME PEOPLE USING
TRANSIT -- BUT IF YOU DO WHAT
WE'VE DONE.
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS TO SAY IN
A LARGE MAJORITY OF PLACES WERE
ONLY GOING TO ALLOW SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES.
MAKES IT REALLY HARD FOR PEOPLE
OF LOWER MEANS LOWER INCOME --
TO TO BE ABLE TO LIVE NEAR THAT
TRANSIT AND SO IT'S REALLY HARD
FOR THEM TO USE THAT THEY CAN'T
WALK THERE.
THEN YOU HAVE TO DRIVE TO
TRANSIT WHICH IS VERY.
CAN BE VERY HARD -- SO I I THINK
WE HAVE TO RECOMMIT TO IMPROVING
OUR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION -- TO
MAKE IT EASIER AND SAFER AND
CLEANER FOR PEOPLE TO RIDE IT
AND AND ADDING PEOPLE ACTUALLY
HAVE A SHOT AT LIVING CLOSE TO
IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CURRENT I'VE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
I ASK NO QUESTIONS UNTIL SENATOR
MCGUIRE RIGHT THE FIFTY FIFTY
ANIMAL FAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
VERY GRATEFUL -- I WANNA
APOLOGIZE TO AT CARE WIENER.
FOR BEING TARDY -- WE HAD A BILL.
RIGHT BEFORE OUR BILL -- THAT
ONE A LITTLE LONG AND OUT THEM
THERE IS AS A ROBUST DISCUSSION --
BILLS I DO APOLOGIZE SIR.
I WANTED TO TAKE A MOMENT AT
SIMPLY TO SAY HOW GRATEFUL I AM
FOR THE CONVERSATION.
OVER THESE PAST MANY WEEKS SAID
ASSN WINNER AND I HAVE HAD.
IN THE COLLABORATION AS WELL --
SIR WINNER AND I'VE BEEN IN
COLLABORATION FOR WELL OVER A
MONTH NOW -- ON BOTH.
SB FIFTY AS WELLS AS BEFORE.
I I THINK IT WAS VERY STRATEGIC --
PRO TO MACINNES TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE.
CENTER WIENER ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE -- IN BEING ABLE TO SIT
ON HOUSING ENSURING THAT WE ARE
WORKING TOGETHER ON BILLS THAT
ARE MOVING THROUGH THE SENATE.
AND THAT IS NO DIFFERENT THAN
THE BILLS THAT ARE IN FRONT OF
US TODAY WHETHER IT IS FIFTY
FOUR OR FIVE IN.
A CENTER WIENER AND I HAVE BOTH
AGREED PRIOR TO THIS HEARING TO
BE ABLE TO PLAY OFF OF EACH
OTHER'S BILLS.
NOT TO PREJUDICE ANY ISSUE --
AND COMMITTED TO KEEP WORKING
AND WORKING TOGETHER INTO THE
FUTURE -- AS WE BRING THESE
DISCUSSIONS WE WOULD HOPE AND I
WANT TO PUT WORDS INTO CENTER
WINNERS MOUTH -- BRING
DISCUSSIONS AND OUR
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS TO CLOSE
BY APRIL TWENTY FOURTH WHICH IS
THE DATE IN WHICH ALL THREE
BILLS WILL BE HEADING GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE -- WITHOUT AND WITH
GREAT RESPECT DO YOU WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU -- AND KNOW THAT WE
HAVE UP CONVERSATIONS OF THE
COMPANY THEN VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE EFFORTS THAT YOU PUT IN YOUR
TEAM IS PUT IN OVER THE PAST
MANY WEEKS [inaudible]
OKAY -- WE HAVE MOTION SENATOR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE -- THANK
YOU -- MISTER VICE CHAIR.
OUR COLLEAGUES THE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THE DISCUSSION.
YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY --
FASTENING WHEN YOU -- WHEN YOU
SPEND ENOUGH TIME AND HOUSING
POLICY YOU CAN SEE FROM THE
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE THE VERY
DIVERSE PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY
SPANNING THE ENTIRE -- SPECTRUM --
AND AND JUST ALL OF A
STAKEHOLDERS AND ALL OF THE
STRONG OPINIONS TO THAT SPAN THE
ENTIRE.
RUN THE ENTIRE GAMUT ON IT'S
IT'S NOT.
SURPRISING THAT IT'S HARD. TO
MAKE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES AND
HOUSING THE VERY VERY HARD THING
I THINK THE ONLY THING THAT
MIGHT BE HARDER IS LIKE TAX
REFORM -- WHICH IS ALWAYS
WINNERS AND LOSERS IN TAX
REFORMS AND NOTHING EVER HAPPENS --
BUT THE BUT THE OTHER PIECE OF
IT.
IS THAT THE ONE THING THAT
EVERYONE AGREES ON MAYBE NOT
EVERYONE BUT I WOULD SAY A LARGE
MAJORITY OF BOTH SIDES OF THIS
BILL -- IS THAT WE WHEN IT COMES
TO HOUSING WERE IN TROUBLE.
WE'RE IN A YOU KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT IT'S A CRISIS IS AN
EMERGENCY AS WE ARE IN DEEP
TROUBLE -- AND BUT I'M AN
OPTIMIST WE CAN TURN AROUND.
AND WE CAN FIX IT.
AND WE KNOW WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
AND THE THINGS THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN ARE NOT EASY.
IMPROVING TARA PROTECTIONS IS
NOT EASY WE KNOW WHAT HAVE YOU
KNOW THE HISTORY IN THIS
LEGISLATURE.
ON THAT FRONT -- INCREASING
FUNDING DRAMATICALLY. FOR
SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
INCLUDING VERY LOW INCOME
INCLUDING EXTREMELY LOW INCOME.
THAT IS NOT EASY.
IT'S A LOT OF MONEY AND THOSE
CHOICES ARE HARD THE POLITICS
ARE HARD.
AND CHANGING THE WAY THAT WE'VE
DONE ZONING IN CALIFORNIA FOR A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY YEARS.
THE DYSFUNCTIONAL WAY THAT WE'VE
DONE ZONING WHERE WE HAVE
ALLOWED CITIES TO SAY NO ONE IS
ALLOWED TO LIVE IN MY CITY.
UNLESS YOU CAN AFFORD A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME.
IF YOU CAN AFFORD A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME WHETHER IN THE
OPPONENT BEVERLY HILLS OR IN SAN
FRANCISCO ON WHICH IN THE LION'S
SHARE OF SAN FRANCISCO OR
ANYWHERE ELSE IN PALO ALTO.
YOU CAN'T AFFORD A SINGLE FAMILY
HOME [inaudible]
GET OUT.
THAT'S THE SIGNAL THAT WE ARE
SENDING WE ARE TELLING OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
THAT YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO MOVE
BACK TO THE TOWN OR CITY WHERE
YOU GREW UP UNLESS YOU'RE GONNA
LIVE.
IN YOUR PARENT'S BASEMENT OR GET
A JOB THAT PAYS THROUGH THE ROOF
[inaudible]
WE'RE TELLING.
CHILDREN THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE TO
LIVE IN A CAR BECAUSE ONE OUT OF
TWENTY SCHOOL CHILDREN.
IN CALIFORNIA IS HOMELESS.
THIS IS.
WE HAVE TO MOVE PAST THE
PARALYSIS ON HOUSING AND CHANGE
HOW WE DO THINGS SB FIFTY PEOPLE
CAN HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
VIEWS I MAKE CLEAR WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK.
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND SOME OF
THE FOLKS WHO CAME UP --
INCLUDING OCTILLION CITY TO
EXPRESS THEIR SERIOUS CONCERNS I
KNOW THEY HAD A VERY LIMITED
AMOUNT OF TIME -- WHAT THEY
DIDN'T MENTION IS THAT WE WORKED
INTENSIVELY WITH THEM AND PUT
AMENDMENTS INTO THE BILL AT
THEIR REQUEST I HOTEL THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT NEXT TIME -- BUT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
HARD AND WE WANT TO MAKE SOME
POSITIVE CHANGE HERE I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH CENTER
MCGUIRE AND OTHERS -- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
SECRETARY.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
SENATE BILL FIFTY BY SENATOR
WINNER THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE SENATOR
WIENER.
WIENER I MORRELL.
MORRELL AYE BATES NO BATES SNOW
COVER.
COVER I DORADO [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE I ROUGH.
ROUGH I SINNER.
SKINNER I UMBERG.
CASKEY. SIX ONE WILL HOLD
OVERLOAD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALEX.
SENATE.
CHOIR YOU READY TO PRESENT YOUR
BILL.
THANK YOU.
OKAY WILL NOW CALL -- ITEM
NUMBER ONE AS THE FOUR BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE WHO WILL BE CO
PRESENTING WITH HIS JOINT
AUTHORS SENATOR BILL
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
NOT YET.
I CENTER HOLDING ONE THAT'S WAY
FOR PEOPLE TO THEIR ALSO
OKAY I THINK WE CAN START
SANDERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AGAIN I'M GONNA TAKE
MOMENT. TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIRMAN. FOR HIS COLLABORATION
OVER THESE PAST MANY WEEKS.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION THE
GENTLEMAN TO MY RIGHT SENATOR
BELL.
WHO HAS BEEN A PARTNER IN BOTH
SENATE BILL FOUR AND HE'S BEEN
TAKING THE LEAD AND SENATE BILL
FIVE AND WILL BE PRESENTING THAT
BILL HERE IN JUST A MOMENT?
AND IT'S GOING TO SAY PUBLICLY
HOW GRATEFUL I AM TO BE ABLE TO
TO WORK WITH YOU SENATOR BAIL
AND FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK IN
LEADERSHIP OVER THESE PAST MANY
YEARS.
ON THE AREA OF HOUSING.
AND WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD. TO
OUR CONTINUED DISCUSSIONS WITH
GERMAN WIENER.
LEADING INTO GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE.
MISTER CHAIR OVER THE PAST SIXTY
EIGHT MIND CENTER BELL AND I
HAVE PARTNERED IN A SERIES OF
HEARINGS UP AND DOWN CALIFORNIA.
IN FACT WE KEEP IT OFF LAST FALL.
THE FIRST HEARING WE DISCUSSED
THE HOUSING CRISIS AND HOW TO
ADDRESS IT THROUGH FURTHER STATE
FINANCIAL.
INVESTMENTS OUR SECOND HEARING
FOCUS ON LAND USE CHANGES THAT
ARE NEEDED TO ENABLE ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABLE AND MARK RATE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION.
AND HERE'S WHAT WE NOW.
WHAT WE KNOW IS AFTER THE SERIES
OF MEETINGS AND NOW IT DIDN'T
TAKE THE MEETINGS TO BE ABLE TO
DRIVE THIS?
BUT HEARING THE INPUT WAS
IMPORTANT.
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT?
CALIFORNIANS FACED WITH A SERIES
OF COMPLEX CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE BUILD OUT OF HOUSING.
WHETHER IT'S HIGH LAND PRICES.
THE LACK OF HOUSING STOCK
ASSOCIATED WITH GROWING DEMAND.
THE LACK OF AN ONGOING
SUSTAINABLE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
REVENUE SOURCE.
REGULATORY HURDLES HI CASA SO
SHE WOULD PERMITTING
[inaudible]
AND YES.
SONY.
AN INABILITY IN SOME
JURISDICTIONS BUILD STRATEGIC
INFILL HOUSING.
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD OUR WAY OUT OF THIS
SIGNIFICANT DEFICIT THAT'S
FACING US.
WE MUST HAVE A LASER FOCUS A
LASER FOCUS ON THE BUILD OUT OF
WORK FORCE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IN BIG CITIES AND SMALL IN EVERY
CORNER OF CALIFORNIA.
AND HERE'S WHY.
THE TRUE CRISIS EXISTS WITH THE
WORKING POOR IN THE MIDDLE CLASS
AT THE STATE.
WE'RE SHORT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION AFFORDABLE UNITS BETWEEN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE IN THE MODERATE.
LOW IN VERY LOW AFFORDABLE
CATEGORIES.
THE STATE NEEDS TO STEP UP.
AND WE NEED TO BE A TO DEVELOP A
PERMANENT REVENUE SOURCE TO HELP
SUBSIDIZE ACOSTA AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CALIFORNIA. TO HEAR MORE
ABOUT THAT WITH A BILL THAT
CENTER BELLS TO WORKING SO HARD
ON AND THAT'S SENATE BILL.
FIVE WHAT WE ALSO KNOW IS EVERY
SITTING COUNTY THE GOLDEN STATE
NEED TO DO THEIR PART WITH
HOUSING.
AND THE STRATEGY OF SAYING NO TO
NO LONGER WORKS.
AT THE SAME TIME WE KNOW THAT WE
NEED TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
UNIQUE DIFFERENCES OF
JURISDICTIONS BECAUSE A BLANKET
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH.
SIMPLY DOES NOT WORK EITHER.
AND THAT'S WHY WERE HERE BEFORE
YOU TODAY WITH SENATE BILL.
FOR SENATE BILL FOR ADVANCES.
THOUGHTFUL STRATEGIES THAT WILL
HELP ADDRESS THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS IN BIG CITIES AND
SMALL ACROSS THE GOLDEN STATE.
WITH THE RECENT AMENDMENTS THAT
WE RECENTLY ADVANCED.
THIS BILL HITS 90% OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION.
BRIEFLY HERE THE GUTS OF THIS
BEFORE.
IN COMMUNITIES WITH FIFTY
THOUSAND POPULATION IN A NUMBER
ONE STRATEGIC INFILL HOUSING
FOCUSED WITHIN A HALF MILE OF
FIX PASSENGER RAIL OR FERRY
TERMINALS.
SHALL BE ONE STORY ADDITIONAL
HEIGHT.
ABOVE WHAT IS CURRENTLY ZONED.
PLUS VINCENT DENSITY BONUS BY
RIGHT AROUND RAIL AND FERRY
STATIONS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY THAT ALLOWS FOR THREE
STORIES.
YOU AUTOMATICALLY RECEIVE A FOUR
STORY [inaudible]
BY RIGHT.
AND THE MAXIM BUILD OUT ON THAT
LOT.
WITHIN A HALF MILE A PASSENGER
RAIL INDOOR RAIL LINE OR FERRY
TERMINAL.
HOUSING IN THE COASTAL ZONE
HISTORIC DISTRICT IN HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES WOULD BE
EXCLUDED.
BUT AGAIN THIS BILL HITS 90% OF
THE POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA.
BY RIGHT APPROVAL OF FOR PLEXUS
WOULD ALSO BE ALLOWED.
IN THESE BY RIGHT APPROVAL FOR
PLEXUS WILL SPREAD OUT DEAN
SITTING COMMUNITIES WITH A
POPULATION OF FIFTY THOUSAND OR
MORE.
BY RIGHT APPROVAL OF DUPLEXES TO
SPREAD OUT INTO NEW COMMUNITIES
WITH A POPULATION OF FIFTY
THOUSAND OR LESS WOULD BE
ALLOWED.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ISSUE OF
PARKING IN CITIES OVER?
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND NO PARKING
WITHIN A QUARTER MILE OF A
PASSENGER RAIL OR FERRY TERMINAL.
POINT FIVE PARKING SPOTS WITHIN
A QUARTER MILE TO A HALF MILE
CITIES UNDER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
POINT FIVE PARKING SPOTS WITHIN
A HALF MILE FROM PASSENGER RAIL.
AS WELL AS PASSENGER FERRY.
WE KNOW THE GREATEST NEED FOR
HOUSING IS THE LOWEST IN THE
ECONOMICS SPECTRUM.
THAT'S WHY SB FOUR ALSO HAS A
30% ON SITE INCLUSION A
REQUIREMENT.
INCLUDE STRONG LABOR PROTECTIONS
ENSURE THAT WORKERS CAN LIVE IN
THE HOUSING THAT THEY ACTUALLY
BUILD.
NOW ALL SAY.
BUT THIS ISN'T AN EASY BILL.
I AND CANDIDLY.
WE HAVE HAD OUR SHARE.
OF FOLKS WHO HAVE SAID THIS IS
TOO AGGRESSIVE.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY.
EVERY COMMUNITY MUST SEE CHANGE.
SB FOUR PROVIDES A PATH FORWARD
FOR CATALYZING THAT CHANGE.
WITHOUT EARNING OVER EVERY
DIFFERENCE IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO TURN IT OVER.
TO SENATOR BAIL TO BE ABLE TO
OFFER COMMENTS AS WELL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I SUPPORT --
TO AND I'M PROUD TO CALL AFTER
THIS BILL THIS THIS BILL --
PROVIDES -- IS SOONER MCGUIRE
INDICATED -- CABLE THE RESULT OF
THE HEARINGS THAT WERE CONDUCTED --
IN IN THE STATE LAST FALL AND
PREPARING -- US FOR A APPROACH
THAT GIVES FLEXIBILITY. TO THE
CONCEPT OF INCREASING DENSITY IN
A WAY HERE -- ALL CITIES CAN
PARTICIPATE WHETHER -- OF SMALL
MEDIUM OR LARGE SIZE COMMUNITIES --
IN TERMS OF MY EXPERIENCE IN.
IN HOUSING AND REZONING AND OF
THOSE KINDS ISSUE I DON'T REALLY
KNOW ANYBODY IN THE LEGISLATORS
DONE MORE.
APPROVAL OF HOUSING REZONING
THIS THAT I HAVE IN MY THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS.
OF ELECTED PUBLIC SERVICE --
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE ACTUALLY WAS ON THE
PLANNING COMMISSION FOR FOUR AND
A HALF YEARS BEFORE I WAS
ELECTED.
SO I UNDERSTAND -- THE FACT THAT --
REZONING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IS IS REALLY A DIFFICULT THING --
AND I THINK THAT -- THIS BILL
PROVIDES WHAT I WOULD CONSIDER
TO BE.
A A APPROPRIATE -- AND DIRECT
INCENTIVE. FOUR BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT CAN'T
OVERCOME.
THE INHERENT DISADVANTAGES -- TO
GOVERNMENT'S MISS WILL
GOVERNMENTS -- THAT BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HOUSE OF THE
DISADVANTAGES ARE WELL KNOWN WE
HAVE A DISADVANTAGE OF IT IN
TERMS OF TAX.
REVENUES THAT'S A DISADVANTAGE.
OF CITIES WOULD MORE LIKELY WANT
TO BUILD HIGHER COST HOUSING OR
OTHER LAND USES.
THAN BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
THE FACT OF MATTER IS THE
PLANNING TO AS I SAID A LOT OF
PEOPLE THE PLANNING DIRECTOR
WORKS FOR THE CITY MANAGER.
THE CITY MANAGER HAS TO PRESENT
THE BUDGET. TO THE CITY COUNCIL
THE CITY COUNCIL HAS TO APPROVE
A BUDGET.
WITH POLICE FIRE AND ALL THOSE
KINDS OF SERVICES SO THERE'S AN
INHERENT.
WHAT I CONSIDER CONFLICT
[inaudible]
CONFLICT BETWEEN PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
ON ONE HAND AND MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY IN TERMS
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
RUNNING AN OPERATED MUNICIPAL
GOVERNMENT.
IN TERMS OF BALANCING THE BUDGET
PREPARING A REVENUE AND
ESTIMATES -- COLLECTING TAXES
AND HIRING STAFF AND RUNNING THE
CITY GOVERNMENT SO I THINK THIS
BILL THIS BILL -- DOES PROVIDE A
BALANCE.
THIS NECESSARY IN COUNTER
BALANCING THE INHERENT TENDENCY
OF CITIES. TO SHY AWAY FROM
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SO WHEN PEOPLE SAY.
IT'S A ZONING ONLY PROBLEM IS
ALSO FISCAL PROBLEM BECAUSE
CITIES.
CITIES DO NOT.
NECESSARILY.
OF ESPECIALLY THE THE THE
LEADERS OF THE GOVERNMENT DOES
NOT NECESSARILY -- CONSIDER --
THE PRIMARY DUTY TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IN MY OPINION AND I THINK
SOMETIMES.
SOMETIMES -- IT TAKES THE
LEGISLATURE.
AS WAS DISCUSSED IN THE LAST
BILL AND WAS DISCUSSED IN THIS
BILL. TO SET THE THE THE PRIMARY
DUTY TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN CALIFORNIA. TO COUNTER
BALANCE.
THAT TENDENCY OF FISCAL
MANAGEMENT AND CREATING THAT
FISCAL TAXPAYER BASE -- WE WILL
ATTEMPT TO DO THAT WITH OUR
HOUSING BILLS.
WE MUST DO THAT AND IT'S GOING
TO BE A A NECESSITY IF WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THANK YOU I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND ABOUT
RESPECT TO THE CONTINUE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH BASS FOLKS IN
SUPPORT TO BE ABLE TO STAND DOWN
TWO DAYS WE KNOW THAT IS GONNA
BE CONTINUE NEGOTIATIONS AND
WOULD I TURN IT BACK TO YOU SIR
MISTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR CENTER
MCGUIRE -- ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BEFORE.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER BE
ONE BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE DON'T
HAVE.
AN OFFICIAL AS SUPPORT POSITION
BUT WE DID WANT TO THANK BOTH OF
THE AUTHORS FOR WORKING WITH C.
T. AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF OTHER
EDUCATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS TO
ADDRESS -- SCHOOL FACILITY
FUSING WE APPRECIATE THE WORK
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS ON THAT.
CORRECT -- ANY I SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL YES.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MACKENZIE
CHRISTIANSEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PLUGINS OFFICE ON THE
UP THIS IS A LIQUID ROSE ME TO
VALLEJO IN SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS AS ARE THE OTHER
BEHALF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
BUT WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US AND INCLUDING
THE VERY IMPORTANT LABOR
PROTECTIONS THAT WILL ALLOW.
PEOPLE FROM THESE COMMUNITIES TO
BUILD THESE PROJECTS THAT THANK
YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OR SHALL
WE SAY BETWEEN HERS -- THE BILL
I SING ON IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SIR PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM STONE OF
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T SUPPORT THE
PREMISE OF THE BILL BUT THERE IS
A LABOR PROVISION IN THE BILL.
THAT EXEMPTS FROM A CERTAIN
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND ALSO
PREVAILING WAGE REQUIREMENTS --
ANY CONTRACTOR WHO IS UNDER A
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT AND SO
THEREFORE IF OUR MEMBER
CONTRACTORS -- FOR TO DO THE
BUILDING THEY WOULD NOT BE
EXEMPT FROM THESE REQUIREMENTS
BUT IF UNION LABOR WAS TO DO
THAT BUILDING THEY WOULD BE
EXEMPT FROM THOSE REQUIREMENTS --
WE FEEL THAT THIS DISADVANTAGES
ARE MEMBERS IN AN UNFAIR WAY.
AND THAT THEREFORE APPOINTED TO
EXPRESS THOSE CONCERNS THANKS.
I AGAIN BELIEVE THIS IS NOT A
GOOD FOR SUBURBAN NEIGHBORHOODS
AGAIN I LIVE IN A NEIGHBORHOOD
WHERE OP E ARE ALREADY A TARGET
FOR INFILL DEVELOPMENT WHAT DOES
THIS MEAN ALL OF THIS IS VERY
AND KNOWN IT'S VERY FRIGHTENING
BECAUSE YOU COULD TAKE MY WHOLE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
OF NINETEEN HUNDRED HOMES BY
THIS ONE QUARTER MILE ONE HALF
MILE AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU I'M
GONNA FIGHT YOU.
BECAUSE I DO NOT BELIEVE THE
STATE HAS THE RIGHT TO REMOVE
NEIGHBORHOODS WHETHER POOR OR
RICH FOR THE BENEFIT OF
REPLACING IT WITH SOMETHING ELSE
THAT IS DISCRIMINATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON FROWNED ROSSI
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION WERE.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE LAST MINUTE
TO THE VERSION AND PRINT HOWEVER
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE FORTHCOMING
AMENDMENTS.
TO REMOVE THE FEE IMPACTS SO WE
LOOK.
FOR TO REVISED IN OUR POSITION
AND CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OFFERING -- ARE YOU REFERRING TO
SB.
FIVE THIS IS US BEFORE THE
FAURIA.
YEAH OKAY FOR OKAY.
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
OKAY SING THEM WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
COLLEAGUES AS A SARGON CENTER
MCGUIRE.
ONE I SHOULD WATER BECAUSE IN A
MINUTE -- AS I MENTIONED AT THE
BEGINNING -- SENATE MCGUIRE AND
I SINCE WE'RE WE'RE IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH AGREE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO STAY OFF OF EACH
OTHER'S -- BILL SO I WILL BE
SAYING OFFER THIS BILL BUT I AM.
RECOMMENDING THAT THE COMMITTEE --
SUPPORT MOVING THE BILL FORWARD
IN AN EFFORT TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION -- SO -- THAT IS MY
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS -- ANY
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS.
SENATOR BATES A QUESTION
REGARDING THE IN FILL ON
DEVELOPMENT ISSUE IN COMMUNITIES
WHERE YOU HAVE H. AWAY STANDARDS
CCAR'S REGARDING THEN.
THE TYPE OF HOME FIVE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS WITH THIS BILL --
FOR PLANT A CC IN OURS AND IN IN
A YOU KNOW.
OWNERS ASSOCIATION.
THIS WOULD NOT SUPPLANT ANY PRE
EXISTING.
BUT IF A HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
WERE TO BE BUILT WITHIN FOR
EXAMPLE ABOUT A HALF MILE OF THE
RAIL LINE OR A PASSENGER FERRY
TERMINAL.
YES THEY WOULD NEED TO BE ABLE
TO COMPLY.
DEPENDS ON THE SIZE OF THE CITY
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR MORE --
WITHIN A QUARTER MILE OF RAIL
LINE.
NO PARKING -- REQUIREMENTS.
WITHIN A HALF A QUARTER MILE
HALF MILE.
POINT FIVE IN ANYTHING UNDER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND BE POINT FIVE
PROJECT FOR NEW DEVELOPMENT --
I'D LIKE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT SENATOR MCGUIRE BECAUSE IN
MY COMMUNITIES.
ALONG THERE'S A RAIL LINE THAT
RUNS.
ALONG THE DECENT TO THE FREEWAY
THE I FIVE WE HAVE SOME VERY ON
HIGH AND DEVELOPMENTS THERE
WHICH YOU'RE A GATED COMMUNITIES
AND THERE ARE VACANT LOTS.
LOT OF ARE INDEPENDENT YOU KNOW.
FOR AN INDEPENDENT -- HOME
BUILDER TO COMEY ON LOTS RANGE
IN SOME OF THOSE AREAS TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE LOT.
AND IF YOU COULD COME INTO ONE
OF THOSE AREAS AND BUILD A TO
TWO CLICKS ARE FOUR PLEX I THINK
YOU'VE GOT INVERSE CONDEMNATION
I I APOLOGIZE I THOUGHT YOU
REFER TO THE LARGER DEVELOPMENT
SO WITHIN THE DUPLEXER THE FOUR
PLEX THEY HAVE TO BE A TO
CONFORM WITH.
WHAT THE LOCAL ORDINANCE ALREADY
STATES I APOLOGIZE SENATOR BATES
WHAT A CC IN OUR IS THE IS A A
COMPANY?
SO I I APOLOGIZE THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO A LARGER
DEVELOPMENT I AM SO SORRY SO
WITHIN THE DUPLEX THE FOUR PLEX
HE WOULD NEED TO BE ABLE TO
COMPLY WITH WHAT THE CURRENT
LOCAL ORDINANCES IN.
THE LIGHT IT WOULD ALLOW BY
RIGHT.
IF YOU'RE LIVING IN A COMMUNITY
FIFTY THOUSAND NOT A FOUR PLEX.
I THINK THAT THAT IS PROBLEMATIC
FOR THOSE HOMES THAT THE THEY
BASICALLY WERE BUILT ON REGIONAL
LINES ACTUALLY.
HANDED OVER LOOK IN ON THE
FREEWAY IN DIFFERENT AREAS BUT
THEY ARE VERY EXPENSIVE -- BACON
LOTS OPEN LOTS OF HAVEN'T SOLD
PROBABLY MORE BECAUSE OF THE
RECESSION.
I TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THROUGH YOU
KNOW JUST COMING OUT OF IT.
ONLINE THAT WOULD BE VERY
PROBLEMATIC AND SO YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO AVOID LITIGATION ON
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BECAUSE IT'S
NOT A SECRET ISSUE.
HAS TO DO WITH THE CHARACTER THE
COMMUNITY IN THE CURRENT ESOS
VALUES.
OF THOSE COMMUNITY SO I JUST
BRING THAT UP AND TAKE A LOOK AT
IT.
I THINK WHAT I'LL DO I I LIKE
THE DIRECTION THIS IS GOING ON I
KNOW YOU GUYS HAVE SOME SECRET
SAUCE YOU WORKING ON TO MAKE
SOME MORE CONGRUENCY WHICH IS
WHICH IS GREAT.
SO I THINK I'LL JUST LAY OFF ON
THIS BUT I'D LIKE YOU TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S PROBLEMATIC CERTAINLY FOR
THE AREAS THAT I REPRESENT WE
HAVE A LOT OF COOL CELS ON SO
THAT'S ALREADY OUT THAT THESE
ARE AREAS THAT ARE BEYOND THE
MEAN.
HIGH TIDE LINE.
AND THEY ARE NOT CURRENTLY
DEVELOPED BECAUSE THEY WERE
PROBABLY DEVELOPED WITH THE
MAJOR -- HOUSING -- PLANNED
COMMUNITY PLANS PROBABLY IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS.
I HAVE A DOWN UPON TO BE
FOLLOWING UP WITH YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES YES I WAS I POLITICS
AND ARE MORE LIKELY DID HAVE FOR
HIM BUT BEFORE SORT OF A YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
GOOD TO FEEL IGNORED -- THREE TO
TALK TO IGNORE.
OF SENATE MCGUIRE YOU YOU USE
THE PHRASE IT THIS WOULD APPLY
290% OF CITIES.
IN THE POPULATION THE CITY
CALIFORNIA.
I'M SORRY SAID AGAIN 90% OF THE
POPULATION.
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION 90% OR
SO.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN BECAUSE?
I DON'T HAVE ANY FERRY TERMINALS
IN ORANGE COUNTY SO OF RAIL.
I HAVE RAIL BUT IT'S A LOS HAND
CORNER THEY CANNOT CUTS CUTS
CROSS.
DIAGONALLY IT'S NOT REALLY --
THE ARMY OF DESERT WE TALKED AND
LAST QUESTION YOU HAVE TO DRIVE
TO A TO GET TO IT FOR MOST THE
RESIDENTS HOPE.
SO I GUESS MAYBE 90% WHEN
APPLIED ORANGE COUNTY THEN.
I CAN'T TALK IF YOU SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT ORANGE COUNTY BUT WHEN WE
DID OUR MAPPING WHEN YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT BETWEEN RAIL
[inaudible]
FERRY TERMINAL.
IS WELL AS THE FOUR PLAQUES.
FIVE PLAY FOUR PLEX DUPLEX MINUS
SEEN OUT [inaudible]
HISTORIC.
COASTAL IN HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES.
THAT'S ABOUT 90% OF THE
POPULATION AND YOU HAVE A MAP.
WE DID MAPPING YES AND BE HAPPY
TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU I WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE A MEDIC.
PLEASE EACH RECEIVING JUST
ORANGE COUNTY WOULD BE GREAT
WONDERFUL THE SECOND QUESTION.
IS THAT -- IT GETS BACK TO LOCAL
CONTROL AND IT'S FROM CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION ARTICLE ELEVEN
SECTION SEVEN THAT SOME PEOPLE
ARE SAYING WELL WAIT A SECOND
YOU CAN'T DO THIS IT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL I'M WONDERING.
IF EITHER OF YOU HAVE DONE ANY
LEGAL RESEARCH. TO GET SOME
SCHOLARSHIP ON ON THE ON THE
CONCERN OF BABY.
OVER WRITING WHAT CAN BE DONE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
WITHIN.
OUR BILL THERE'S ALREADY
PRESIDENT AT THIS LEGISLATURE'S
ESTABLISHED -- IT SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE SAW WITH AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY THREE WITH THE MAXIMUM
HEIGHT [inaudible]
PLUS.
ONE N. MAXIMUM DENSITY BUILD OUT
ON THE LOT -- WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS SB FOUR CAN'T SPEAK TO SB
FIFTY BUT I HAVE A FEELING THAT.
CHAIRMAN SAY THE SAME THING WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS WOULD
WITHSTAND ANY CONSTITUTIONAL
TEST ARE IN THE COURTS.
AS IT IS BUILDING ON PRE
EXISTING.
ZONE LAND. FOR HOUSING -- AND
BUT DENSITY BONUS.
IF ALLOWED BY THE COUNCIL WOULD
ALLOW FOR AN ADDITIONAL STORY
ALREADY.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR OKAY ANY OTHER DRIVE CENTER
CABALLERO.
I I HAD THE SAME QUESTION THAT
CENTER MORE LIKE IT IF YOU COULD
SHOW US A MAP THAT BE GREAT
ABSOLUTELY AS I THINK WE HAVE IN
OUR HEAD WHAT.
WOULD IT WOULD COVER BUT IT IT'S
BETTER TO SEE IT ON PAPER
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MAKING.
OKAY YES CENTER BATES I THINK
YOUR PARDON I MEANT TO AS GO A
LITTLE DEEPER ON THE PARKING
ISSUE I'VE REYES SO WITH SB
FIFTY THE SAME ONE HERE BUT EVEN
IF PEOPLE ARE LOCATED.
CLOSE TO TRANSIT RAIL BUS
SERVICE ODDLY STILL MOST LIKELY
ON CARS AND WHAT HAPPENS IS WHAT
OF THOSE CARS GO IF WE'VE
ELIMINATED.
YOU KNOW PARKING REQUIREMENTS ON
THE DEVELOPMENT SIDE OR EVEN
JUST A HALF OF SPACE.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THOSE FIND
THEIR WAY INTO THE RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORS OF NEAR -- THE
DEVELOPMENT AND WE'VE HAD
PROBABLY MOST OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE'VE HAD IN THE CITIES
THAT I'M FAMILIAR WITH AND SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY.
THURMOND FIGHTS OR PARKING
ISSUES NOT REGARDING NEW
DEVELOPMENT REGARDING --
DEVELOPMENT WHERE A MULTI FAMILY
THOSE CLOSE TO THOSE SINGLE
FAMILY RESIDENCE CHANGE THE
PARKING REQUIREMENTS SO THAT YOU
HAVE TO PAY FOR PARKING.
GARAGE SO THEY MOVE INTO THE
RESIDENTIAL AREAS AND THAT'S
WHAT THEY ALSO GETS PEOPLE ARE
FOCUSED ON THE FACT THAT WITHOUT
PARKING.
ARE THESE NEW DEVELOPMENTS DON'T
WORK SO.
ARE I THINK YOU NEED TO TAKE A
LOOK SIGNIFICANTLY AT THE
PARKING RESTRICTIONS.
THAT YOU'RE ALLOWING ON THESE
ARE NO PARKING REQUIREMENTS AT
ALL.
ARE THERE HAVE TO BE INCENTIVES
GIVEN THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
PROVIDE THAT EITHER SHUTTLE
SERVICES YOU CAN WORK WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES WITH
THIS BE ONE AND THE MONEY THAT'S
PROVIDED THEREFORE ON MORE
TRANSIT.
YOU CAN HAVE THOSE LOCAL
CIRCULATORS THERE HAS TO BE
SOMETHING -- THAT COULD PROVIDE
FIRM IS SHELTERING OF SOMEONE
WHO OWNS A CAR OR YOU WOULD BE
REQUIRED IF YOU MOVE INTO THESE
NEW DEVELOPMENTS THAT YOU
BASICALLY.
FIND A DOCUMENT THAT YOU DON'T
OWN A CAR BECAUSE I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO FIND IS THAT.
THERE WOULD BE PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUES THAT ARE CREATED WHEN YOU
HAVE THESE -- RESIDENTIAL AREAS
WITH TOM PARKING ALL ALONG NEXT
TO THE SIDEWALKS WE HAVE HAD TWO
INCIDENCES IN MY COMMUNITIES
WHERE CHILDREN NOW CROSSING
BETWEEN CARS AFTER THEY GET OFF
THE BUS OR GOING TO SCHOOL.
HAVE BEEN KILLED AND THAT'S JUST
A FACT SO IT'S SIGNIFICANT WITH
ME IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT THIS
THAT THERE'S A WAY.
THERE'S GOT TO BE AN INCENTIVE
IN THERE SOMEWHERE TO
ACCOMMODATE ALL THE OWNERSHIP OF
A CAR EVEN THOUGH YOU DON'T USE
IT EXCEPT.
FOR LET'S SAY ON RIGHT AROUND
YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD RIGHT AROUND
COMMUNITY SHOPPING FOR THE
WEEKEND ISSUES WHERE YOU'RE AYE
TRANSPORTING CHILDREN NOT TO ALL
THEIR ACTIVITIES.
SO PLEASE TAKE A LONGER LOOK AT
THAT AND BOTH OF BILLS BECAUSE
THOSE ARE THAT'S PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST HURDLE FOR ME HAVING I
EXPERIENCE IT.
FOR MY THIRTEEN YEARS ON A CITY
COUNCIL IN MY FOUR YEARS ON THE
BOARDS TO EIGHT YEARS ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ALWAYS THE
ISSUE.
IS ABOUT PARKING THAT THAT GETS
PUSHED INTO RESIDENTIAL AREAS
BECAUSE OF CHANGES IN LAWS OR
REGULATIONS OF ADJACENT MULTI
FAMILY.
NO AND I APPRECIATED.
THE THOUGHT THAT CENTER BATES IS
PUT INTO THE SINCE COMING FROM
EXPERIENCE.
THROUGH THE CHAIR IF IT'S
ALRIGHT.
WE HAVE.
TRIED TO FOCUS THE ISSUE OF
PARKING. TO THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE LARGER.
A JOB CENTER.
AND DIRECTLY ADJACENT TO RAIL OR
FERRY SERVICE.
SO FOR EXAMPLE.
THE ONLY AREA WITHIN A BILL
WITHIN THE BILL [inaudible]
THAT.
WOULD NOT ALLOW FOR PARKING AT
THIS MOMENT.
WOULD BE WITHIN A COMMUNITY OF A
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND A QUARTER
MILE UP TO A QUARTER MILE AWAY
FROM A RAIL LINE OR FERRY
TERMINAL.
ANYTHING FROM A QUARTER MILE TO
A HALF.
WOULD BE POINT.
FIVE POINT FIVE IS FAIRLY
STANDARD -- ESPECIALLY FOR NEWER.
I HIGHER DENSITY APARTMENTS
CONDOMINIUMS -- DEPENDING ON
COMMUNITY WHICH YOU LIVE IN.
IF YOU'RE LIVING IN A COMMUNITY
UNDER A HUNDRED THOUSAND BECAUSE
TRANSIT IS NOT AS RELIABLE
CANDIDLY.
IT WOULD ALLOW FOUR POINT FIVE
PARKING SPOTS -- SO WE WE REALLY
TRYING TO REFINE IT BUT I HAVE.
TO FOLLOW UPS.
AS BATES SAID I HAD ONE IS THE
FOUR PLEX DUPLEX ISSUE THAT YOU
RAISE IN THE OTHER ISSUE IS
PARKING.
AND I PROMISE I'LL GET BACK.
TO BOTH OF US WILL.
SENATOR ROTH THANK YOU MISTER
PERHAPS I MISSED THE SINCE I HAD.
TO LEAVE THE ROOM OF FOR ANOTHER
REASON BUT WITH RESPECT TO THE
STREAMLINED MINISTER -- REVIEW
AN ELIGIBLE PROJECTS WITHIN A
HALF MILE FIXED REAL TERMINALS.
IS THERE SOME FREQUENCY
REQUIREMENT I MEAN PERHAPS YOU
KNOW IF YOU HAVE BEEN IN SOME
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA AT LEAST --
YOU HAVE -- REALIGN ITS FREIGHT
AND PASSENGER AND YOU MAY HAVE
ONE OR TWO OF PASSENGER TRAINS
TODAY ON A ON A LINE WITH THAT
SORT OF SERVICE REQUIRE --
COMPLIANCE WITH -- AS BEFORE.
YES WE ARE LOOKING AT HEADWAY IN
REGARDS TO A NUMBER OF STOPS IN
TRIPS FOR DAY OKAY THANK YOU
THAT WAS MY QUESTION THANK YOU
MISTER.
A CALLING SENATOR TIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY SEEING NONE -- TURNED BACK
TO SAN REQUIRED TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU KNOW
LOOKED -- CENTER BELL -- ONE A
AGAIN TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE GENTLEMAN TO MY RIGHT.
HI CENTER BELL FOR ALL THS WORK
FOR THESE PAST MANY MONTHS AND
MANY MANY HOURS IN -- WORKING
DISCUSSION IN VERY GRATEFUL
CENTER ABOUT FOR ALL OF YOUR
EFFORTS AND YOUR LEADERSHIP. TO
CHAIR A ONE TAKE A MOMENT ALSO
TO SAY THANK YOU UP FOR THE
COLLABORATION AND LOOK FOR
TOWARD DISCUSSIONS IN THE MONTHS
TO COME.
INTO THE COMMITTEE I KNOW THAT
THIS IS GOING TO BE CAN CONTINUE
TO WORK IN PROGRESS AS WE
CONTINUE TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE
CHAIR -- COMING UP ON APRIL
TWENTY FOURTH STATE.
GOVERNMENTS IN FINANCE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON BEHALF OF CENTER BELL
INCLUDES INCOME ANSWER.
RESPECT LASSEN EITHER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AND AGAIN --
AS I INDICATED BEFORE I WILL BE
STAYING OFF -- BUT I AM
RECOMMENDING AN IPO -- SO THIS
CAN MOVE OUT OF COMMITTEE AND WE
CAN CONTINUE OUR CONVERSATIONS I
WILL NOT CALL THE ROLL.
THE SENATE BILL FOUR BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE SENATOR
WIENER.
MORRELL YEAH BROWN NO BATES.
CARRERO.
HOWEVER I DRAWS -- I RATHER AYE
MCGUIRE.
CHOIR I MORE LOCK.
ALL RIGHT.
MARK I ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
UMBERG CASKEY.
BECAUSE OF A BELL CURVE ACCOUNT
IS CURRENTLY FIVE TO ONE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN -- FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS WHO WILL BE
JOINING US SHORTLY SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. TO OUR AUTHORS.
OKAY WE WILL NOW -- MOVED TO THE
REST OF OUR AGENDA THIS IS
SOMETHING. FOR YES SO NEXT WE'RE
GONNA BE GOING TO ITEM THREE
WHICH IS SENATE BILL -- FIVE
WITH OUR SAME JOINT AUTHORS BUT
THIS TIME I BELIEVE CENTER BELT --
WILL BE TAKING THE LEAD -- AND
THE COMMITTEE HAS PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL.
CENTER ABOUT.
OF THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
I PRESIDING SB FIVE AND ALSO
JOINING ME IS OR JOINT AUTHORS
AND REQUIRE.
AND WE'RE PLEASED TO BE HERE
TODAY -- SB FIVE IS -- SUPPORTED
BY OVER.
SIXTY ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
THE BIG MAYOR'S STAKE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES FIRST
COMMUNITY HOUSING IN THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL AND WE WOULD LIKE --
TO DISTRIBUTED A UPDATED
[inaudible]
SUPPORT LIST -- OF THE
SUPPORTERS.
OF SB.
FIVE AND MANY OF THESE GROUPS
WERE NOT IN YOUR YOUR REPORT.
SO THEREFORE I WON A MAIL MAKE
SURE YOU HAVE THE LIST.
OF THE PROPER LISTS THIS BILL IS
A A PART OF THE WORK THAT CENTER
MCGUIRE -- DONE AS PREVIOUSLY
DISCUSSED -- IN TERMS OF SB FOUR
FIVE AND SIX WHICH I BELIEVE IS
COMING UP.
AND A WEEK OR TWO THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR IN THIS COMMITTEE.
THE PACKAGES BASED ON INPUT
GATHERED AT THE SERIES OF PUBLIC
MEETINGS.
AND HEARINGS WE CONVEYANCE
ACROSS THE STATE THIS FALL -- I
WOULD ALSO LIKE SAY FOR THE
RECORD THAT WE ACCEPT --
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED
IN THE ANALYSIS -- CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS IS STAGGERING SB
FIVE CREATES -- DESPERATELY NEED
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES FOR HARD
WORKING CALIFORNIANS.
BUT ALSO HELP ALLEVIATE POVERTY
CREATES JOBS AND MEETS OUR
STATEWIDE ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
WITHOUT AFFECTING SCHOOL FUNDING.
SINCE THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
CALIFORNIA'S HAS FAILED TO
PRODUCE THE ESTIMATED A HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND NECESSARY
HOUSING UNITS PER PER YEAR --
THIS RESULT HAS HAS HAS CAUSED
NEARLY IN MY OPINION HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND MEN WOMEN
CHILDREN LIVING ON OUR STREETS
EVERY YEAR.
SO I THINK OUR HOUSING SHORES
HAS ACTUALLY.
CREATED THAT SITUATION.
ANOTHER TWO POINT TWO MILLION
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME AND VERY
LOW INCOME RENTER HOUSEHOLDS ARE
COMPETING FOR ONLY SIX HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS.
THIS LEAVES ONE POINT FIVE FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS OF THE
LOWEST INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT
ACCESS TO HOUSING AND AT RISK OF
BECOMING HOMELESS.
THE STATE MUCH ACT WITH AN
URGENCY TO ADDRESS THIS SHORTAGE.
SB FIVE MAKES THE STATE A LONG
TERM PARTNER.
AND PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED MONEY
TO SPUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION ACROSS THE STATE.
IT PROVIDES SIX NEVER FORGET
ONGOING INVESTMENT WRAPPING UP
TO TWO BILLION ANNUALLY OVER
TIME.
AND OFFERS AN EFFECTIVE FINANCE
TOOL LOST WHEN THE STATE
DISSOLVED OR REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES.
SPECIFICALLY SB FIVE ALLOWS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO COLLABORATE
IN STATE APPROVED COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT PLANS WHICH WILL BE
FUNDED BY REDUCING THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE EDUCATION.
REVENUE AUGMENTATION FUNDS.
FUNDS CAN BE USED FOR THE
FOLLOWING PURPOSES AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT.
WHICH COULD BE HOUSING INFILL
DEVELOPMENT WHICH COULD BE
HOUSING.
RES REVITALIZING AND RESTORING
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND ALSO PLANNING -- FOR THE SEA
LEVEL RISE ISSUES.
A MINIMUM 50% OF THE FUNDS MUST
BE USE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
THERE IS THERE IS A 12% SET
ASIDE FOR RURAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES.
AND THE BILL CREATES A STATE
COMMITTEE HOUSE UNDER THE
HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT TO REVIEW AND APPROVE
PROPOSED PLANS PROVIDING STATE.
STRONG STATE OVERSIGHT.
NOT NOT LIKE WHAT WE DID WITH
REDEVELOPMENT WHERE THERE WAS
LITERALLY NO STATE OVERSIGHT --
THE COMMITTEE HAS -- IS ALSO
THIS COMMITTEE THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE IS ALSO EMPOWERED TO
TAKE CORRECTIVE.
ACTION WHEN LOCALS DO NOT MEET
THEIR PLAN PLANS -- OBJECTIVES --
I LIKE TO TURN OVER TO SAM
REQUIRE AND THEN -- HERE ARE
WITNESSES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CENTRE BELL ALL BE VERY QUICK.
AS WE JUST HEARD THIS IS A
DESPERATELY NEEDED MEASURE TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT CRISIS OF
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION FORMAL
UNITS NEEDED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT'S THE DEFICIT WE
PROJECT BETWEEN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE IN ADDITION TO THE 50% OF
THE PROGRAM FUNDING GOING TO
CONSTRUCTION AFFORDABLE HOUSING
REMAINING FUNDS CAN BE USED
RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE.
BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE HEARD TIME
AND TIME AGAIN FROM DEVELOPERS
AS WELL AS CITIES THE NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS WATER
SEWER ELECTRICAL HOOKUP OR SOME
OF HE LARGEST DRIVERS.
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION COSTS.
AND WE LEARN FROM THE LESSONS OF
THE PAST CENTRE BELL HAS BEEN
ADAMANT TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THOSE.
AND BRINGING FORWARD THIS
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
THE BILL ALSO HOLES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE THEY DO
NOT SPEND THESE FUNDS AS THEY
SAID THEY WOULD -- SB FIVE
PROVIDES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
AN ONGOING REVENUE SOURCE TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT IT
DOES SO IN THAT RESPONSIBLE WAY
THAN INSURERS THE STATE'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRIORITIES
ARE MET.
I AND WE WOULD SPECIFICALLY
ASKED FOR AND I ABOUT MISSED
HERE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND
AGAIN THANK YOU CENTER.
THEN I'D LIKE TO TURN OVER THE
WEIRDNESS JASON RYAN IS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CITIES AND DâN DOWNTOWN
MUSHI FROM THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS.
REGIONAL COUNCIL AND DANCE GOING
TO PRESENT THE RESULTS FROM A
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS.
OF IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
THAT WAS DONE ON SB FIVE SOLTERO
TO WITNESSES AND YES THANK YOU
SIR ABOUT THE MEASURE MEMBERS
JASON RHYNE LEE CALIFORNIA
CITIES.
AND WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE LAST TIME MSM SO
WE'RE BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
SB FIVE IS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
AND THAT IT BUILDS OFF OF ALL OF
THE GREAT EXISTING TOOLS THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED WITH
PAST FIVE SEVEN YEARS -- WHAT'S
REALLY BEEN MISSING THOUGH.
IS THAT PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
STATE CITY COULD FORMA DE I FTA
COULD FORMER CREA -- BUT THEY
HAD TO DO IT ALONE AND THEY
REALLY DIDN'T HAVE THAT
FINANCIAL LIFT.
SB FIVE IS A GAME CHANGER IN
THAT IT'S GOING TO ALLOW THE
STATE TO ENTER THE SPACE --
THROUGH A AN APPROVAL PROCESS
THROUGH IT OVERSIGHT PROCESS A
COMMITTEE PROCESS I'M DEBT
REALLY CHANGES ON THE WITH WHAT
WE DID IN THE PAST IN THE NEW
PARADIGM HERE IS.
NOBODY IS FORCED AND CITIES ARE
ENFORCED AND COUNTY SPECIAL JUST
CANNABIS FORCED IN THE STATE'S
NOT FORCED AND WE CAN ALL COME
TOGETHER AND FORM THAT
PARTNERSHIP AND THEN THE STATE
CAN COME IN A AND DECIDE WHICH
PROJECTS THEY WANT TO APPROVE --
AFTER WE GO THROUGH THAT LINK
THE EDIFICATION PROCESS AND THEN
IT'LL BE AN ONGOING FORM OF
FUNDING THAT CITIES WILL BE ABLE
TO USE IN ORDER TO BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR A HOUSING.
AND REVITALIZE OUR COMMITTEES --
IN WITH THAT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE TURN OVER THE NEXT
GUEST.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS -- DANKO
MUCCI I'M A RESEARCHER WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS
REGIONAL COUNCIL -- AT CENTRE
BELL NOTED IN COLLABORATION WITH
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP.
WE USE IT IN PLAN INPUT OUTPUT
MODEL TO EXAMINE THE POTENTIAL
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF DIRECT
INVESTMENTS AND ADDITIONAL
LEVERAGE FUNDS FROM SENATE BILL
FIVE AS IT WAS INTRODUCED.
OUR MODEL IS BASED ON AN
ANALYSIS OF THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
AND LIKE THE PROGRAM WE EXPECT
THE STATE'S DIRECT INVESTMENT
FROM SB FIVE TO BE LEVERAGE OVER
THREE TIMES FROM LOW INCME TAX
CREDITS.
OTHER FEDERAL FUNDS LOCAL FUNDS
AND OTHER PRIVATE SOURCES.
THESE INVESTMENTS COULD
TRANSLATE INTO OVER SIXTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY THROUGH.
TWENTY TWENTY NINE ARE NOW ALSO
IS ALSO SET ALSO SHOWS THAT OVER
THE NEXT DECADE THESE
INVESTMENTS CAN PRODUCE OVER
EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND NEW AND
REHABILITATED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS. TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE AND LOCAL
INCOME TAX REVENUE. TWENTY THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN LABOR INCOME
AND SUPPORT APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
JOBS INCLUDING ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND FAMILY
SUPPORTING PREVAILING WAGE
CONSTRUCTION JOBS WITH HEALTH
AND RETIREMENT BENEFITS.
THANKS TO EXISTING PUBLIC WORKS
APPRENTICESHIP REQUIREMENTS
PROJECTS THAT RECEIVE INVESTMENT
SOME SB FIVE WILL SUPPORT
WORKFORCE TRAINING FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE FOR VETERANS AND FOR
OTHERS JUST BEGINNING THEIR
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS.
APPRENTICESHIP IS BOTH AN
ESCALATOR TO THE MIDDLE CLASS
AND IT'S MOST IMPORTANT TO WE
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT THE STATE
HAS A SKILLED CONSTRUCTION
WORKFORCE WE NEED. TO ADDRESS
OUR HOUSING SHORTAGES.
SB FIVE WILL NOT ONLY HELP US
MEET THE STATE'S URGENT NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS.
IT'S AFFECTS WILL RIPPLE
THROUGHOUT OUR ECONOMY.
IT WILL RESULT IN MORE JOBS
INCREASED CONSUMER SPENDING AND
MORE TAX REVENUE IT'S AN
INVESTMENT IN THE STATE'S
CURRENT AND FUTURE WORK FORCE.
AND THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CARPENTERS ARE PLEASED TO OFFER
OUR SUPPORT THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OF TESTIMONY.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE PAUL GETS ALL OF US
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF THE CITIES
OF LAKE WOULD ROSE MADE AND
VALLEJO WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE LEAGUE AFTER
SUPPORT.
WHICH REMEMBER DIVISIONS OF HALF
CITIES OF BURBANK PASADENA SOUTH
PASADENA SUPPORT.
SENATE GEORGE REFERENCE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
AND OVER ON A WITH -- STRATEGIES
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ROSS BUCKLEY ABOUT THE BIG CITY
MAYORS COALITION SUPPORT.
YOU MIGHT IS MEADOWS WITH A
COUNCIL WE SUPPORT INCREASE
RESOURCES FOR JUST IN OUR
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS.
GENOCIDE TODAY FOR THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TWENTY THREE A CALIFORNIA PART
SITUATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CAN DOWNEY
WHO DROWNED THE STATE COUNCIL
LABORS IN SUPPORT.
WE WERE TOP ON BEHALF THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
MIKE MONEY GOING TO BE HALF F
THE METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
ELECTRICAL WORKERS A CALIFORNIA
STATE PATRIOTS COUNCIL.
AND WESTERN STATES COUNCIL SHEET
METAL WORKERS SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TYRONE BUCKLEY
WITH HOUSING CALIFORNIA SUPPORT
CONCEPT VERY ENCOURAGES SEE A
FUNDING BILL GO FORWARD.
CAITLYN VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT.
YOUR MEMBERS AS ARE THE AS WE
HAVE THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
STRONG SUPPORT.
SENATORS PAT ACKLAND WITH THE
CITY OF NEVADO THE CITY DID SEND
YOU A LETTER INDICATING THAT WE
SUPPORT SB.
FIVE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OF
THE TESTIMONY.
HI THREE NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION I'M I AM VERY
APOLOGETIC WE DO HAVE A LATE OP
THE OPPOSE POSITION ON THE
MEASURE OUR STATE COUNCIL JUST
TOOK A POSITION ON SUNDAY
AFTERNOON.
WE DO HAVE AN OPPOSE PHYSICIAN
BUT I DO NEED TO NOTE THAT THE
WHAT THE AUTHORS HAVE BEEN
DILIGENTLY TRYING TO WORK WITH
US TO COLLABORATE AND WORK OUT
CONCERNS AND WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE.
OF SOME OF THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS THAT HVE BEEN PUT
INTO THE MEASURE TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT SCHOOL FUNDING IS
PROTECTED THE PROBLEM THAT CTA
HAS WITH THE METHODOLOGY THAT'S
BEING USES THE ONLY WAY THAT
SCHOOLS CAN BE PROTECTED IN THE
EVENT.
OF ANOTHER RECESSION IN A
DOWNTURN IS THAT WE HAVE TO RELY
ON FUTURE LEGISLATORS AGREEING
TO BACK FILL UP PROPERTY TAXES
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND THE
LAST RECESSION THAT WE HAD
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT WAS
SUSPENDED TWICE.
I'M SO IF WE COUNT ON THE
PROMISE OF A FUTURE LEGISLATURE
NOT TO SUSPEND PROP NINETY EIGHT
AND TWO GUARANTEED THAT PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE IS GOING TO BE BACK
FILLED FOR SCHOOLS.
WE WOULD BE PUT IN A GREAT
SITUATION BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THERE ARE NO GUARANTEES -- FOR
SCHOOLS AND SO SHOULD THERE BE
AN ABSOLUTE GUARANTEE WE
WOULDN'T HAVE A PROBLEM BUT WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO RELY ON
ABSOLUTE PROMISES -- IN THE BACK
FROM FUTURE LEGISLATURE'S AND SO
THAT IS THE REASON THAT WE
OPPOSE WE WILL CONTINUE TO TRY
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHORS TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY WAY THE SITUATION
CAN BE RESOLVED.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE ONLY WAY
THAT WE CAN HELP OUR CONCERNS
ADDRESS IS IF WE WEREN'T.
IF THE BILL WERE USING PROPERTY
TAX REVENUES FROM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
THANK YOU NEXT RECORD.
I THIRD I JUST HEARD A FEW WORDS
THAT I JUST WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
SO YOU ARE RESURRECTING IN A WAY
STATEWIDE REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
THAT ENDED UP WITH A DEBT OF A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS.
AND WE THE PEOPLE WERE LIED TO
ALL THE TIME.
ON'T TAX INCREMENT FINANCING FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW WHO
IT IS.
IT'S ABOUT STEALING PROPERTY
TAXES.
AND GIVING THEM TO ANOTHER
AGENCY.
THAT MEANS OUR POLICE FIRE.
ALL SPECIAL DISTRICTS DO NOT GET
MONEY PARKS LIBRARIES I OPPOSE
THAT NOT EVEN READING THE BILL
BECAUSE I KNOW HOW CORRUPT.
STATEWIDE REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
WERE AND IT WAS ALL ABOUT
STEALING TAKING PROPERTY BY
EMINENT DOMAIN WHICH EACH ONE OF
THESE BILLS BY THE WAY.
ARE REQUIRING IT'S ABOUT
DEMOLITION I DO NOT SUPPORT THIS
AND I'M BEGINNING TO WONDER WHAT
KIND OF A GOVERNANCE.
WE HAVE UNDERNEATH THIS DOME I
THINK YOU REACH THE LEVEL OF
COMMUNISM THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
ABSURD AND YOU LAUGH MISTER BELL.
BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU IF YOU'RE
TAKING TAX INCREMENT FINANCING
AGAIN AWAY FROM THE PEOPLE IT
MEANS MORE AND MORE TAXES FOR
THOSE OF US WHO OWN PRIVATE
PROPERTY RIGHTS YOU CREATE MORE
BONDS YOU CREATE MORE PERSONAL
TAXES.
AND THIS IS DISCRIMINATION ABOUT
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO OWN PRIVATE
PROPERTY LIKE HOMES IN SUBURBAN
NEIGHBORHOODS ESPECIALLY THANK
YOU.
NO THANK YOU.
OKAY IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HAILING STEPHENS SUNNYVALE
PLEASE REQUIRE CORPORATE TO DO
THEIR FAIR SHARE.
LET'S JUST A TINY BIT OF THEIR
PROFIT THEY CAN GIVE US BILLIONS
FOR LOW INCOME HOUSING.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION COMMON.
SIGNAL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AYE AYE FOR LONG AS I
HAVE FOR THE BILL AND I LIKE IT
A LOT SO -- CALLERS OF ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MOTION BY
SENATOR ROSS -- CENTER CABALLERO.
I JUST HAVE A QUESTION AND I I
AM.
IT IT IT'S RELATED TO THE THE
FUNDS FOR THE PROGRAM -- SO SO
WHAT WHAT THE ANALYSIS SAYS IS
THAT -- THERE ARE A SERIES OF
PRIORITIES AT THE COMMITTEE.
IS GOING TO BE USED TO DETERMINE --
WHAT PROJECTS GET FUNDED?
AND AND ONE OF THE PRIORITIES IS
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
IT'S DEFINED AS A 120% OF THE
MEDIAN INCOME AND SO -- ONE OF
THE ISSUES I THINK THIS GOING TO
BE REALLY IMPORTANT IS TO HAVE A
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS.
BECAUSE IN SOME COMMUNITIES WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU'RE SUBSIDIZING UP
TO A 120% OF THE MEDIAN INCOME
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SPENT ON THE
MEDIAN INCOME IN SOME OF THE BAY
AREA CITIES IS A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SUBSIDIZING
SOMEONE WHO'S EARNING A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN ONE REGION AND AS OPPOSED TO
FARMWORKERS AND A BLUE COLLAR
WORKERS IN IN MY COMMUNITY AND
SO IT SEEMS TO ME THAT YOU GET
MORE BANG FOR YOUR BUCK.
IF YOU'RE SUBSIDIZING THOSE THAT
REALLY CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE IN
NYC IN THE COMMUNITY -- AND I'D
LIKE TO SEE SOME KIND OF EQUITY
RATHER THAN SUBSIDIZING SOMEONE
WHO EARNS A HUNDRED AND 20% OF
THE MEDIAN INCOME WHEN IT'S A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO
REALLY SUBSIDIZE -- JANITORS AND
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND FIVE
FIREFIGHTERS AND POLICE OFFICERS
AND SO I I I AM I'M NOT I DON'T
HAVE THE ANSWER IN TERMS OF WITH
THE FORMULA.
SHOULD LOOK LIKE BUT I'M I WANT
TO PUT THAT PLUGIN THAT THERE BE
A COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS THAT THE
COMMITTEE WILL LOOK AT BECAUSE
OTHERWISE AS THEY TRY -- TO TO
HAVE GEOGRAPHICAL -- COVERAGE IN
THE STATE YOU'RE GONNA RUN INTO
THESE ANOMALIES BUT OTHER THAN
THAT I THINK IT'S GREAT AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL YEAH THE THE
EACH COMMUNITY THIS IS AN OPT IN.
SO EACH COMMUNITY HOUSES SUBMIT
A AND I THINK THE IDEA THAT YOU
HAVE ABOUT THE LOOKING AT THOSE
KINDS OF FACTORS SO.
COULD BE PART OF THE PLAN
REQUIREMENTS WE WILL WELL WORK
WITH YOUR OFFICE IN [inaudible]
OTHERS.
TOO SEE WE CAN -- ACCOMMODATE.
GREAT THANK YOU I THINK YOU'RE
IN THE RIGHT PLACE WHERE WE ARE.
SIMILAR FEELINGS ABOUT THE
SUBJECT [inaudible]
SENATOR RUSSELL.
YES -- COULD YOU -- PLEASE
RESPOND TO THE ISSUE OF THE
FUNDS BEING DIVERTED FROM PUBLIC
EDUCATION OBVIOUSLY.
NO WILL VERY PROTECTIVE OF OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SO IF YOU COULD
RESPOND TO THAT.
I THINK THE THE FEAR OBVIOUSLY
IS.
GOING BACK TO REDEVELOPMENT OKAY.
AND REDEVELOPMENT IS YOU KNOW
WAS -- TAX INCREMENT FINANCING.
THAT SIMPLY -- ALLOW THE CITY TO
CREATE A REDEVELOPMENT SAYING
AUTOMATICALLY -- TOOK
REDEVELOPMENT FUNDS -- ENDED UP
BY THE TIME THAT -- WE DISSOLVE
REDEVELOPMENT IT WAS OVER FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR OF
PROPERTY TAXES WERE USED
STATEWIDE AND REDEVELOPMENT.
THERE'S A LOT OF UNCONTROLLED.
OF REDEVELOPMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SOME COUNTIES HAD AS
MUCH AS A FOR A 30% OF THE TOTAL
PROPERTY TAX.
WENT TO REDEVELOPMENT WHAT THIS
PLAN DOES INSTEAD IS TO NOT
ALLOW THAT KIND OF SITUATION TO
OCCUR AGAIN WITH THIS ALLOWS IS
A COMMITTEE. TO BE CREATED AND
EACH CITY WOULD SUBMIT AN
APPLICATION AND THE COMMITTEE
WOULD LOOK AT THAT APPLICATION
TO SIDE.
OF THE LEVEL OF TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING TO BE ALLOWED IN THAT
APPLICATION FOR THAT CITY.
OR COUNTY OR OR OTHER ENTITY
THAT THAT CREATES THESE WE ALSO
HAVE A PROVISION IN THIS LAW.
AND WE HAVE A LETTER FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WHICH EXAMINED SB FIVE AND THE
LETTER BASICALLY SAYS.
THAT SB FIVE WOULD HAVE -- IF IF
IMPLEMENTED THE WAY WE HAVE IN
THE STATUTE IT WOULD HAD A
SUMMARY THIS IS UNDER SB FIVE
THE STATE WOULD.
BE REQUIRED TO RE BENCH THE RAF
REDUCTIONS PART TO RISE BY THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT IT WAS IT INVESTMENT
PROGRAM.
THIS REQUIREMENT MEANS THE STATE
EFFECTIVELY WOULD BE COVERING
THE COSTS OF THE PROGRAM.
THROUGH THE ADDITIONAL JENNER
FRONT GENERAL FUND SPENDING
RATHER THAN A REDUCTION IN
SCHOOL FUNDING SO IT'S IT'S IT'S
A MATTER IF THE SCHOOLS WOULD BE
MADE WHOLE UNDER THIS
LEGISLATION.
SO SO THAT'S THE LETTER FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND THEN WE
ALSO PUT -- PROVISIONS
ADDITIONAL SET UP PROVISIONS IN
THE LOBBY ON EVEN EVEN WHEN THE
LETTER WAS WRITTEN DATED MARCH
EIGHTEENTH WE ADDED SOME
ADDITIONAL PROVISIONS IN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT RECENTLY WE'RE
DONE.
I'M SORRY SIR SO THE FUNDING
WOULD CONTINUE TO COME THROUGH
THE GENERAL FUND.
EVERY YEAR ON ONGOING BASIS SO
IT WOULDN'T TAKE AWAY FROM
FUNDING TOWARDS THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION.
WE WOULD HAVE -- TO DECIDE HOW
MUCH MOEY WE WANTED TO PUT.
IN THIS PROGRAM WITH THE JOB THE
THE BILL ALLOWS FOR A RAMPING UP.
FROM TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR UP TO TWO BILLION DOLLARS
OVER TEN YEARS. TEN YEAR PERIOD
SO IT'S A RAMP UP.
IT DOESN'T GO UP ALL OF A SUDDEN
RAMPS UP TO TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
IT -- IT ALSO -- OF COURSE --
DEALS WITH -- SCHOOLS IN ANOTHER
WAY THE ECONOMIC ANALYSIS UC.
OF AND I THINK YOU HAVE A COPY
SHOWS THAT.
THIS BILL WILL GENERATE --
SIGNIFICANT LOCAL STATE REVENUES
IN AND TAXES AND THEN.
I THINK THE ANALYSIS THAT WAS
DONE I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
NUMBER WAS IN IN YOUR REPORT.
FOR TAX INCOME.
FROM THE LEGISLATION IT WAS A
TOTAL OF TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS. TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS.
AND WE ALSO HAVE IN THE BILL.
A WHAT WE CALL AN OFFRAMP OF
WHAT I CALL A BUTTON THAT CAN BE
PUSHED BY THE LEGISLATURE. TO
STOP.
THE PROGRAM IF THERE'S A FISCAL
DOWNTURN.
SO WE HAVE A A PROCESS FOR THAT
AS WELL THAT IN A BUDGETARY
PROCESS WE CAN DECIDE -- TO STOP
THE THE THE SPENDING ON THIS
PROPOSED THIS PROGRAM -- DURING
A FISCAL -- PROBLEM PERIOD IN
THE STATE SO YOU CAN YOU CAN.
ACTUALLY HAVE THAT IMPLEMENTED
IT ACTUALLY SAYS IS IMPLEMENTED --
BY THE LEGISLATURE -- WHEN --
WHEN -- FISCAL EMERGENCY SICK
PLACE SO FOR YOU TO SEE ANY.
DANGER OR THREAT TO THE FUNDING
TO PUBLIC EDUCATION AS I DON'T
BUT I THINK I THINK THE RAISE
LEGITIMATE ISSUES ABOUT THE
OVERALL LACK OF FUNDING FOR
PUBLIC EDUCATION I I CERTAINLY
AM SYMPATHETIC.
AND THAT'S AN ISSUE I MEAN
THAT'S LIKE I THINK THE FEAR IS
BASED ON JUST THE LACK OF
OVERALL.
FUNDING AND I'M VERY SYMPATHETIC --
HOWEVER IT'S UP TO US.
TO DEAL WITH THAT QUESTION.
THIS WOULD ALLOW A PROGRAM FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN CALIFORNIA.
TELL AN ONGOING MAJOR SOURCE OF
OF FUNDING WITH CITY GOVERNMENTS.
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
AN ATTACK OF ANY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPER AND TO ATTACK POVERTY
THAT'S WITH THIS PROGRAM WOULD
DO.
AND IF THERE'S ANY WAY THAT WE
COULD MAKE THAT CLEAR THAT
THERE'S NO THREAT TO THE PUBLIC
FUNDING THAT.
IN IF IT'S OKAY WITH MISTER BELL
DAY TRIP TO TO SENATOR ALSO.
WE'VE WE'VE TAKEN THE CONCERNS
VERY SERIOUSLY THE EDUCATION
COALITION.
ON IN WE HAVE GREATLY
APPRECIATED OUR TIME SITTING
DOWN WITH HIM SEVERAL TIMES.
THAT'S WHY WE WENT TO
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
BE ABLE TO GET A REVIEW OF THE
ENTIRE BILL.
AND WE'LL BE HAPPY TO BE TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE IN A REVIEW OF
THE BILL AND WHY THEY BELIEVE
THERE WILL NOT BE A FISCAL
IMPACT.
TWO K. THROUGH COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EDUCATION.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE ALSO
IMPLEMENTED VERY SIMILAR ARE
FRANCE THAT WE HAVE SEEN WITH
FOR EXAMPLE -- OTHER FUNDING
PROGRAMS IT'S IN THE STATE THAT
WOULD HAVE TRIGGERS. TO BE TO
STOP THE FUNDING DURING TIMES OF
THE DECLARED FISCAL EMERGENCY.
I COULD DO WE TAKE IT VERY
SERIOUSLY AS I KNOW EVERYONE ON
THE STATUS DOES A MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE KEEPING SCHOOLS HOLD.
WILL PROVIDE THE LA ANALYSIS.
ONE SENATE ROTH.
JUST A FOLLOW ON ON WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE WAS JUST OF ASKING
ABOUT I MEAN MY UNDERSTANDING.
THE CITY IS COMMON AS THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE I AGREE
RECESSION IN THE SUSPENSION OF
PROP NINETY EIGHT IS A RECALL.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE LAW
K. TO TWELVE IS IT DO IT
AUTOMATICALLY REQUIRES A BACK
FILL FROM PROPERTY TAX.
BY ME FROM THE GENERAL FUND WHEN
THE PROPERTY TAX REVENUES LESSEN
ANTICIPATED AT LEAST TWO CASE OF
TWELVE FOR THE MEDICALLY
REQUIRES IN THE ANALYSIS.
TO THIS BILL. TO FOLLOW ALONG
WITH THAT.
PROVIDES THAT -- THIS BILL
STATED BACKFILL SHALL ENSURE
THAT SCHOOLS RECEIVE THE SAME
LEVEL OF REVENUE AS THEY WOULD
HAVE IN ABSENCE OF THE BILL.
SO IT SEEMS TO ME THAT AT LEAST
IS TWO K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION.
OF THE FUNDING STREAM IS SECURE --
IN ANY EVENT ABSENCE --
CATASTROPHE AS WE EXPERIENCE
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX
SEVEN EIGHT I THINK THAT'S
CORRECT IS IT NOT -- SERVO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- OKAY -- ONE THING --
CENTER BILL YOU INDICATED THE
BEGINNING THAT YOU ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AND ANALYSIS I JUST
WANNA COVER ONE OF THOSE A MA'AM
AND SIR -- IS IT WAS A LITTLE
MORE GENERAL IN THE ANALYSIS BUT
YESTERDAY WERE ABLE TO REACH
AGREEMENT ON A FIVE IN ALICE'S
TALKS ABOUT -- MACHINE
JURISDICTIONS AN ELIGIBLE IF
THEY VIOLATED STATE HOUSING LONG
LAST FIVE YEARS -- WE AGREED TO
THAT TO IT TOO LIMITED TO THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT AND
THE DENSITY BONUS -- SO YOU'RE
YOU ACCEPT THAT A MOMENT IS ALL
OVER.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION --
AND WITH THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
BILL THAT DIED IN THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL I'M NOT DYING
BOTH AUTHORS FOR THE DILIGENT
WORK UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'LL BE
A CONTINUING PROCESS -- WE NEED
TO DO -- AS I'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR
IN MY WORK AROUND STREAMLINING
REZONING REFORM WE ALSO NEED TO
BE SUPPORTING.
LOCAL COMMUNITIES NOT JUST
TELLING THEM BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT HELPING THEM -- PAY
FOR A HELPING THEM PAY FOR THE
PLANNING STAFF WHEN THEY NEED IT
CETERA.
IN THIS IS IMPORTANT -- STOP --
THE AMENDMENTS ARE IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THEY WILL ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ACTUALLY
READY TO CREATE THE HOUSING AND
WE'LL DO IT QUICKLY AND AND IN A
STRONG WAY -- WILL GET.
PRIORITY AS A SHOW BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO SEE THE HOUSING ACTUALLY --
DELIVERED SO I'M RECOMMENDING --
AND I DO IT AS AMENDED -- I CAN
RECALL HAS THERE BEEN -- A
MOTION SENATOR ROTH GREAT
EMOTION AND THAT'S AS AMENDED
CENTER.
OKAY -- SO -- THERE'S NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION -- SENATOR BILL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
OF THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY THAT'S
HELP THE FORMAT THIS BILL THIS
WILL PROVIDE A ONGOING SOURCE.
OF REVENUE FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND HOUSING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- I ALSO I
ALSO THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE.
THAT -- THE LEAGUE CITIES IN THE
BIG CITY MAYORS -- SUPPORT THIS
BILL IT'S TIME THAT WE DE.
FOR TAKE TAKE A A PRIORITY FOR
OUR LAND USE PANNING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND ANYTHING
WE CAN DO TO REDUCE POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA -- AND MAKE A THE
LAND USE -- REFLECT OUR VALUES
REDEVELOPMENT DID NOT DO THAT IT
ACTUALLY.
WAS TO ELIMINATE BLIGHT IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE
REDEVELOPMENT LAWS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT ELIMINATE
BLIGHT THIS BUILDING ELIMINATES
THE FORD OR HOUSING.
DEFICIT IN A AND IS ATTACKING.
POVERTY IN THE HUMAN BEINGS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE NEED TO HELP
SO DESPERATELY AND GET GET HIM
OFF THE STREETS -- I REGION I
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WITH
THAT -- THE BILL FIVE BY SENATOR
BILL THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND WE WERE FOR THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER HI.
WIENER HI MORRELL.
MORRELL NO BATES.
BATES AYE CAMARO.
THERE ALSO I DRAWS -- AYE
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI MORE LOCK.
ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER I UMBERG.
CASKEY.
OKAY THE VOTER SIX TO ONE THAT
IS ENOUGH FOR THE BILL TO BE
VOTED OUT AND WE WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
SENATORS [inaudible]
YEAH DOT.
HELLO.
ACTUALLY A CENTER.
YES CENTER BILL WILL STICK WITH
YOU AND ACTUALLY BEFORE WE GET
TO CENTER BILLS NEXT BILL WHEN
WE TAKE THE CONCERNS.
A CALENDAR WHICH IS ITEMS FOR
AND TEN SB SIX IS -- AND SB --
THREE THIRTY THREE SO CAN I HAVE
A MOTION MOVED.
WE ALREADY DID IT DIDN'T WE I'M
SORRY.
WILL IT WILL OPEN AT WILL OPEN
LATER WHEN EVERYONE'S HERE.
MY APOLOGIES ON THAT I WAS SO
EFFICIENT AT THE BEGINNING THAT
I FORGOT THAT I DID IT
[inaudible]
BUT ONE OKAY -- BOOK BUT WE ARE
YOU A MEMBER.
A PROBLEM OKAY THE THREE OF THAT
ROOM.
OKAY I WILL NOW CALL -- ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB TWO EIGHTY TWO BY
SENATOR ABOUT -- MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS.
OF MY PLEASURE PRINT PRESENT AS
BE -- TWO EIGHTY TWO SB TWO
EIGHT CHIU CRATES THE SUPPORT OF
HOUSING. FOR PERSONS ON PAROLE
PROGRAM TO BETTER SERVE
INDIVIDUALS ON PAROLE.
WITH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS FACING
HOMELESSNESS.
NOW SUPPORT OF HOUSING IS AN
EVIDENCE BASED INTERVENTION
PROVEN TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM --
MISTER CHAIRMAN -- LAST FRIDAY
OF MANY OF OUR STATE CELEBRATED
OR SAYS ARE CHAVEZ CELEBRATIONS.
OF WHAT I DID TO CELEBRATE SAYS
ARE CHAVEZ IS I TOOK.
THE THE TIME.
FRIDAY TO SPEND WITH STATE
PRISONERS AND THE DONOVAN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY IN SAN
DIEGO.
AND TALK TO INMATES TALK TO THE
WARDEN -- AND THE STAFF AT THE
DONOVAN FACILITY IT'S MY TWENTY
FIFTH PRISON I VISITED.
AND TALKED ABOUT HOW TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM WHAT THEY THOUGHT.
AND WHAT THE CHARGE WAS THAT
PEOPLE DATED JOBS -- A TRANCE
FRMATION TO THE COMMUNITY JOBS.
THEY NEEDED HOUSING.
SUPPORT OF HOUSING WHERE THEY
CAN HAVE PEOPLE THAT CAN HELP
THEM TRANSITION.
AND THEY NEEDED HEALTH CARE THEY
NEEDED THE THEIR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM -- TO HELP WITH THEIR
PROBLEMS THEY'VE HAD IN THE PAST
WITH.
MENTAL HEALTH ADDICTION AND
OTHER HEALTH CARE ISSUES.
THIS BILL SB.
TWO EIGHTY TWO ACTUALLY FITS IN
VERY NICELY WHAT I HEARD FRIDAY
AT THE DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY.
HOUSING IS STABILITY IS CRITICAL
THIS BILL PROVIDES INCREASE
ACCESS. TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT DOES NOT LIMIT THE LENGTH
OF STAY AND AND PROVIDES
WRAPAROUND SERVICES STABILITY.
PEOPLE ON PAROLE EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS SEVEN TIMES MORE
LIKELY.
THEY ARE THEY ARE TO THE
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AND
THERE SEVEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
RESERVE A THEN THOSE HOUSE.
AS WE KNOW IS VERY EXPENSIVE TO
TO HELP SOMEBODY RESERVE A IT'S
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
A YEAR PER INMATE PER YEAR.
AS OF THOSE OF US ON THE PUBLIC
SAFETY BUDGET COMMITTEE NO.
AND WE ARE TRYING TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
RECIDIVISTS.
THIS BILL ACCOMPLISHES THAT IT
RECOGNIZES STRONGLY BETWEEN
INCARCERATION HOMELESSNESS
ESTABLISHED IN THE INTEGRATED
SERVICES FOR MENTALLY ILL
PROGRAM.
ESTABLISHES IN CALIFORNIA'S
200-072-0008 BUDGET THE
PROGRAMMERS THIS PROGRAM.
RECEIVES FUNDING. TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT OF HOUSING IN AND IN
INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT FOR
PEOPLE ON PAROLE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS EXPERIENCING
PROGRAM OF HOMELESSNESS.
HOWEVER THE PROGRAM RIGHT NOW IS
NOT IN LINE WITH THE THE CURRENT
PROGRAM IS NOT IN LINE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
NOW USES FUNDS.
THIS IS MADE OF FUNDS IN A TO
PAY FOR A 100% OF THE COST OF
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT.
INSTEAD OF IN ROLLING THE PEOPLE
IN MEDI CAL WHICH CAN DRAW DOWN
A FEDERAL MATCH OF 5290%.
OF THE IS NO PARTICIPANTS ONLY A
SMALL NUMBER ARE HOMELESS.
AND THE HOUSING -- THE PROVIDE
THAT ARE PROVIDED BY THE
CORRECTIONS DEPARTMENT IS ONLY
TEMPORARY A UCLA STUDY.
ON OF THIS PROGRAM THAT THE THE
CURRENT PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE
FEELS IS SAYS IT FAILS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
THE MAIN GOAL.
AND AND THAT PARTICIPANTS
PARTICIPANTS ONLY RECEIVE TEN
MONTHS OF TREATMENT ON THE
AVERAGE BEFORE DROPPING OUT OF
THE PROGRAM.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO REDIRECT THE
CURRENT PROGRAM.
IT WILL PROVIDE FUNDS FOR THE
THAT THOSE FUNDS TO BE RE
DIRECTED BETTER SERVING THE
POPULATION.
WITH THOSE FUNDS IT REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT.
ADMINISTERS THE FUNDS TO
COUNTIES TO ENSURE THE
PARTICIPANTS CAN ACCESS MENTAL
HEALTH.
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
THROUGH MEDI CAL SB -- TWO
EIGHTY TWO PAINS TO REDUCE THE
RECIDIVISM.
AND PROMOTE REENTER SUCCESSFUL
REINTEGRATION TO SOCIETY BY
PROVIDING SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND
WRAPAROUND SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS ON PAROLE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS IS A BETTER
WAY.
THAN CURRENTLY EXIST HIGHER CHEN
AYE VOTE AND I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO MY WITNESSES.
WHO ARE HERE TO TO SPEAK TO YOU
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON REPORT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT
OF HOUSING -- S. SENATE BILL
NOTED -- THERE IS A STRONG LINK
BETWEEN INCARCERATION
HOMELESSNESS AND RECIDIVISM --
PEOPLE EXITING PRISON HAVE
SIGNIFICANT OF COLD HE'S
ACCESSING HOUSING ESPECIALLY
HOUSING THEY CAN AFFORD.
AND WHEN YOU ADD IN PEOPLE WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS THAT JUST --
COMPLICATES THE THE DIFFICULTIES.
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
ALSO EXPERIENCE RESTRICTIONS AND
ACCESS TO OTHER FUNDS THAT COULD
BE USED FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE
FOR EXAMPLE MANY FEDERAL
PROGRAMS RESTRICT -- ACCESS TO
FOR EXAMPLE SECTION -- EIGHT
BECAUSE THE PERSON IS ON PAROLE
OR PROBATION.
WITH 40% OF OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION BEING AFRICAN
AMERICAN.
THE AN EQUITIES IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM TRANSLATE TO AN
EQUITIES AND ARE HOMELESS
POPULATION.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE DO KNOW HOW
TO SOLVE HOMELESSNESS AMONG THE
VERY VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AS
PAROLEES.
MULTIPLE -- JURISDICTIONS ACROSS
THE NATION HAVE CREATED
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PROGRAMS FOR
PEOPLE ON PAROLE AND PROBATION.
AND AS SENATOR BELL -- DESCRIBES
THESE PROGRAMS PROVIDE HOUSING
WITHOUT LIMITS ON LENGTH OF STAY
AS WELL AS INTENSIVE SERVICES TO
PROMOTE HOUSING STABILITY
INCREASE INCOME AN INCREASE
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH AND
OTHER -- HEALTH CARE TREATMENT.
ONE EXAMPLE IS THE OHIO
RETURNING HOME PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES SUPPORTIVE HOUSING TO
PEOPLE ON CRUEL WHO OF
EXPERIENCE OR AT RISK OF
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
THIS PROGRAM WAS CREATED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AND AN EVALUATION
WAS DONE TWICE ON THE PROGRAM
FOUND SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS.
BY MOVING PEOPLE INTO SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IS ACTUALLY A CONTROL
GROUP AND THE STUDY FOUND THAT
OF THE PEOPLE PARTICIPATING IN
THE PROGRAM HAD 60% FEWER DAYS
INCARCERATED.
THAN THE CONTROL GROUP HAD AND
HAD THE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER --
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AND TO HIGHER INCOME
LEVELS AS A RESULT OF THE
PROGRAM.
AFTER FIVE YEARS OHIO -- MADE
THIS PROGRAM PERMANENT AND THE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM HAS
INCREASED EVER CENTS EACH YEAR
TO PROVIDE MORE -- SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FOR THE POPULATION.
OTHER STATE AND LOCAL PROGRAMS
HAVE DONE SIMILAR VALUATIONS AND
OVER TWENTY STUDIES HAVE FOUND
VERY SIMILAR RESULTS.
WITH DECREASE COSTS -- OF
SIGNIFICANT COST AVOIDED BY --
REDUCING SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
RECIDIVISM.
I'M LIKE SB TEN TEN WHICH PASSED
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUSLY AND PASSED ON
CONSENT ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
AB TWO EIGHTY TWO WE USE
EXISTING RESOURCES TO CREATE
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR PEOPLE ON
PATROL.
WITH SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
SB TWO EIGHTY TWO WILL NOT ONLY
PROVIDE THE EVIDENCE BASED MODEL
TO SOLVE HOMELESSNESS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
IT WILL ALSO CONNECTS PEOPLE TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT.
SO AND TO CLARIFY THIS BILL DOES
NOT -- REALLY -- HAS PEOPLE
TRANSFERRING THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT TO MEDI CAL MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEMS SO IT THE PROGRAM
WOULD NO LONGER BE FUNDING
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT I WANTED
TO CLARIFY THAT IT WOULD ONLY
FUNDS SUPPORT OF HOUSING -- SB
TWO EIGHTY TWO WILL ALSO MOVE
THE FUNDING TO THE STATE AGENCY
THAT HAS THE MOST CULTURAL
COMPETENCY AROUND HOUSING.
AND THEY ARE CURRENTLY FUNDING A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE
SERVING PEOPLE ON CRUEL.
A WELL PEOPLE -- WILL NEED TO BE
ON PRO WHEN THEY'RE INITIALLY
ELIGIBLE THERE IS NO LIMIT ON
LENGTH OF STAY BUT THAT DOES NOT
MEAN THAT THEY WOULD LIVE IN THE
SUPPORT OF HOUSING FOREVER.
THE AVERAGE LENGTH OF STAY IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING IS THREE
YEARS AND PEOPLE TYPICALLY MOVE
ON TO OTHER PERMANENT HOUSING
AND HOUSING STABILITY.
OHIO DOES HAVE A PROGRAM CALLED
MOVING ON AND IT DOES PROVIDE
SERVICES TO HELP PEOPLE GROW
THEIR INCOMES. TO TRANSITION OUT
OF THE SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND
THAT -- MODEL HAS BEEN USED
SUCCESSFULLY IN OTHER STATES AS
WELL.
SB TWO EIGHTY TWO WILL ESTABLISH
AN EFFECTIVE EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACH TO REDUCING RECIDIVISM
AND FRONT TRANSFORM HOW WE
PROVIDE HOUSING TO PEOPLE ON
PAROLE. THREE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT RECORD WITH.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS LENDING CROWDY AND
I'M A POLICY FELLOW WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PERSONS WITH
CHILDREN ALL OF US ARE NINE
ORGANIZATION.
EMPLOYING AND WORKING SO HOLD
THE DIGNITY OF FORMALLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS I'M
ALSO FORMALLY INCARCERATED.
I LIKE TO SHARE MY STORY ABOUT
TE DIFFICULTY OF FINDING AND
KEEPING HOUSING AS A PERSON RE
ENTERING SOCIETY POST
INCARCERATION.
I WAS INCARCERATED I TOOK THE
TIME TO WORK ON MYSELF AS HAVE
NUMEROUS CLASSES FACILITATED
CLASSES ADDRESS IT THINGS FROM
MY PAST AND FOCUS ON BEING A
BETTER ME.
I REALIZE THAT IT WAS MY POOR
CHOICES THAT LANDED ME IN MY
SITUATION.
AND I WAS READY TO MOVE FORWARD
IN MY NEW BEGINNING AND BETTER
ME.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
POWERFUL THINGS THAT KEPT ME
MOTIVATED AND GROUND IT.
PLANNING MY FUTURE.
AFTER A LITTLE OVER EIGHT YEARS
MY THEY HAVE FINALLY COME AND I
WAS READY TO BE PRODUCTIVE SAY
SAY THE ST.
EAGER TO BUILD A PRODUCTIVE LIFE.
I WAS GIVEN FOUR MONTHS INSIDE A
TRANSITIONAL HOME.
THEY SEEM LIKE THE MOMENT I STE
STEP THROUGH THOSE DOORS I WAS
GREETED WITH A HARSH REALITY.
USUALLY WHEN A PERSON FINDS OUT
THAT YOU JUST CAME HOME ONE OF
THE FIRST QUESTIONS IS HOW DO
YOU FEEL.
YES I WAS EXTREMELY GRATEFUL TO
BE HOME BUT I WAS FULL OF
ANXIETY WORRY.
AND FEAR.
I QUICKLY LEARNED UPON MY
RELEASE THAT THE AVERAGE RATE
WAS AT LEAST A THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR MORE.
I KNEW THAT FIND AN ADEQUATE
HOUSING WAS A VITAL COMPONENT IN
THE SUCCESS OF MY FUTURE.
BUT I WAS GIVEN JUST FOUR MONTHS
TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
WITH TRYING TO FIND A LIVABLE
WAGE JOB CLOTHING AND MONEY FOR
FOOD I FOUND MYSELF WAS SMART
FOUND MYSELF LOSING CONFIDENCE
AT TIMES.
LIVING IN THE COAL WHERE
TRANSITIONAL HOME THE MAIN TOPIC
OF CONVERSATION WAS HOUSING.
I QUICKLY LEARNED THAT I WAS FAR
FROM LOAN ALONE IN MY ANXIETY
AND WORRIES OUR CASE MANAGERS
HAD LITTLE TO NO RESOURCES TO
ASSIST SAYS SO WE WERE ALONE IN
FIGURING IT OUT. ONE OF MY-ROOMMATES WHO WAS OPEN ABOUT HER
MENTAL HEALTH ILLNESS WITH ME.
A SURPRISE TO ME THAT THIS WAS
HER SECOND TIME IN A
TRANSITIONAL HOME.
SHE SAID THAT.
WHEN SHE WAS THERE THE FIRST
TIME SHE RAN OUT OF TIME BEFORE
FINDING HAVE A BEFORE SHE HAD
TIME TO FIND A HOUSING?
AND SO SHE HAD TO LIVE IN A CAR
FOR A WHILE.
DUE TO HER MENTAL HEALTH SHE WAS
GRANTED ANOTHER FOUR MONTHS
INSIDE THE TRANSITIONAL HOME.
I WATCH MY ROOMMATES SAID SEARCH
FRANTICALLY FOR HOUSING
OFTENTIMES ENGAGE IN WHAT I
THOUGHT WERE SKETCHY SITUATIONS.
SHE USE A CRAIGSLIST AMONG OTHER
SOURCES TO FIND ROOMMATES
SOMETIMES A LOOK LIKE SHE WILL
FIND GOOD LEADS.
BUT THEY WERE NEVER CALL HER
BACK AFTER MEETING HER.
OTHER TIMES I WILL HEAR HER
COMMUNICATING WITH MEN WHO WERE
RENTING AND SOMETIMES HERE RED
FLAGS.
THERE WAS NO ONE REALLY THERE TO
HELP HER AN ASSIST HER WITH HER
SPECIAL NEEDS OR THOSE OF US WHO
ARE FACING HOMELESSNESS AFTER
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING.
AFTER FOUR MONTHS IN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING I WAS
FORTUNATE TO FIND A PROGRAM THAT
HELPS FORMALLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE.
IN THE COMMUNITY FOR UP TO SIX
MONTHS.
BUT AT THAT TIME I OTHER
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE I
WILL AGAIN FACE THE POSSIBILITY
OF HAVING TO SECURE HOUSING.
AND ONE OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE
AREAS IN THE COUNTRY AND IN THE
STATE IN WHICH IS GENERALLY IS
LEGAL TO DENY HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
SOLELY BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
CRIMINAL RECORD.
BECAUSE OF THESE CHALLENGES I
FACE THE REAL POSSIBILITY OF NOT
SECURING SAFE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AT ALL.
MANY OF MY HOUSE MAY SUFFER FROM
SOME FORM OF MENTAL ILLNESS
INCLUDING THE TRAUMA OF
INCARCERATION AND THE MENTAL AND
EMOTIONAL SCARS THAT.
ON ONE EXPERIENCE IS GOING
THROUGH THE SITUATION WHICH I'M
ALSO DEALING IN HAILING WITH AT
THIS MOMENT. FOR US FINALLY
HOUSING IS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
WITH A CRIMINAL CONVICTION NOT
TO MENTION THE EXTREME COSTS OF
HOUSING.
WE ALL DESIRED TO MAKE IT ON OUR
OWN AND MOVE FORWARD IN A
PRODUCTIVE WAY.
HOUSING IS NOT A PRIVILEGE IS A
NECESSITY PLEASE VOTE YES FOR SB.
TWO EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY AND
SPEAKING TO SUPPORT IS IMPORTANT
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HI SO WE'RE
MOVING -- TO ME TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS SO PLEASE COME FORWARD
AND STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M LUIS BROWN
JUNIOR WITH POLICY LINK OF THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS -- WE DIED AND
A GREAT JOB OF TRYING TO REFORM
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE POLICIES TO
BRING PEOPLE HOME.
WE'VE ALSO TAKEN SOME
SIGNIFICANT STEPS. TO ADDRESS
OUR HOUSING CRISIS BUT WE
HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH TO ADDRESS
THE HOUSING CRISIS FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE CRIMINAL RECORDS.
SO FOR THAT REASON WE ARE CO
SPONSORING SB TWO EIGHT TWO AND
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN --
NAME OF ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT.
CHRIS MARTIN WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA -- CO SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT.
LOUIS MARIN TEN BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE BEING ACROSS CITY WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PERSONS WITH
CHILDREN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RUGOVA WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE SOCIAL HER NAME WITH THEWESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BRIAN AUGUSTA WITH CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS KATIE DIXON I'M A
POLICY FELLOW WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN AND ALL OF US AND THEN.
NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OF POOR
TESTIMONY.
I SEE NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
IF SO PLEASE COME FORWARD
.
HI MY NAME IS JAMES SWEENEY.
I REPRESENT THE BLACK AMERICAN
POLITICAL ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE'D LIKE YOU TO KNOW THAT IN
TERMS OF STATE CONTRACTS.
AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE LESS THAN.
1%.
I PERSONALLY HAVE SERVED FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS ON CALL ME --
COUNCIL ON MENTALLY ILL
OFFENDERS.
AND WHAT THIS CONTRACT DOES.
IS IT TAKES IT AWAY FROM THE
PROVIDERS WHO ARE AFRICAN
AMERICAN.
AND MANY OF THOSE SUB
CONTRACTORS WHO ARE AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND IT DOES NOT
[inaudible]
ADDRESS.
THE PROBLEM.
OF THOSE PROVIDERS THE BILL
TALKS ABOUT.
BUT YOU WILL MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT IT MAKES NO
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
PROVIDERS.
AND I KNOW SENATOR BILL AND I
HAVE WORKED WITH HIM WITH HEALTH
STUFF BEFORE AND THIS IS ONE OF
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
MOVING QUICKLY AND FAST.
I AM NOT LOOKING AT THE IMPACT
ON PEOPLE WHO WERE DOING THIS
JOB.
THANK BERMAN NEXT SPEAKER.
BENEDICT LOU BON WITH -- BLACK
CALIFORNIA BLACKSMITH CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND THE CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
LOOK TO AMEND IT -- I HAVE A
PERSONAL INTEREST IN THIS I RUN
ONE OF THESE HALFWAY HOMES.
IT'S A MAGNANIMOUS SIDE BILL.
YES ARE YOU REGULAR PAROLE LEE.
CAN GO INTO THIS TYPE OF HOUSING.
BUT THE MENTALLY ILL NEEDS MORE
HELP.
I FIND.
AT TIMES.
I'M NOT CAPABLE OF HELPING THESE
PEOPLE.
I DON'T SEE THEM GOING INTO A
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING SUPPLIED BY
YOUR BILL.
THAT WILL SUPPORT THEM ENOUGH --
THROUGH MY EXPERIENCES I HOPE TO
WORK WITH YOU. TO FILL THESE
GAPS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER.
HELLO SIR THOMAS AS A PROVIDER A
SERVICE PROVIDERS IF THE
PROVIDER CURRENTLY -- ONE OF THE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL.
OF REGARDING MEDI CAL SERVICES
ARE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WITH.
FUNDED THROUGH MEDICARE AL.
OVER THE LAST. TEN YEARS WE'VE
CONSISTENTLY BEEN DENIED BY SAT
COUNTY SO ALLOW OUR MEMBERS WHO
ARE CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN THE
PROGRAM TO RECEIVE SERVICES.
THROUGH SEC COUNTY.
THEY'VE BEEN REFERRED BACK TO
THE PAROLE OUTPATIENT CLINIC
WHERE THEY'RE CURRENTLY RECEIVE
SERVICES.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARVIN
ALL THE IN THE CLINICAL DIRECTOR
OF FROM -- CONSORTIUM FOR
COMMITTEE SERVICES WE ARE ONE OF
THE S. MINT PROVIDERS IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
WE ALSO PROVIDE SERVICES IN
SACRAMENTO FRESNO COUNTY.
WE ALSO OPPOSE THE BILL -- ONE
OF THE STUDIES THAT TESTED A
BILL TALKED ABOUT WITH THE UCLA
STUDY I BELIEVE THAT THE UCLA
STUDY WAS PREMATURE.
BECAUSE THE STUDY WAS ACTUALLY --
CONDUCTED BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN AND OUR CURRENT
CONTRACT HAS CERTAIN BENCHMARKS
THAT IS IN PLACE AND THAT HAS
FIFTEEN DOMAIN AREAS THAT WE ARE
MEASURE TO GAINES.
AND NONE OF THOSE DOMAIN AREAS
WERE MEASURED BY THE UCLA STUDY
SO THE OUTCOMES MEASUREMENTS
THAT UCLA STUDY IT YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU IS OUTDATED AND
DOES NOT EQUALLY REPRESENT.
THE SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE
ALSO THE FUNDING SOURCE THAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE COST OF FIVE
PROVIDING -- INCARCERATING A
MENTALLY ILL OFFENDER IN
CALIFORNIA ABOUT CLOSE.
TO NINETY THOUSAND UPWARDS OF
810-002-90000 DOLLARS THE
CURRENT IS MY PROVIDERS WE
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AND HOUSING WITH HOUSING WE OUR
COST IS.
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND AND WE HAVE
INTEGRATED SO SERVICES APPROACH
SO WE COLLABORATE WITH THE
PAROLE AGENT THE PEARL
OUTPATIENT CLINIC WHICH IS THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
WE ARE THE HOW THE WE ARE THE WE
COORDINATE HOUSING SERVICES BUT
WE ALSO PROVIDE THE DIRECT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
PARTIALLY IN IN RESULT OF THAT
MEDI CAL COULD WE CAN PARTNER
WITH MEDI CAL WE'VE TRIED
EXCLUSIVELY BUT WE COULDN'T --
AND SO WE PROVIDE INTEGRATED
SERVICES AND WE HAVE HOUSING
COURT IT IS THAT IDENTIFIES
CERTAIN HOUSES THAT THESE
MEMBERS AT THESE HARLEYS CAN GO
INTO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SPEAKER THERE FOR HOUSTON AND
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT CCS.
AND THAT'S MAYA.
I HAVE A MENTAL ILLNESS.
AND THEY HELPS ME.
THERE DURING THE WEEK
[inaudible]
AND TO GET OVER THE WEEKENDS AND
I'LL LOOK FOR IT EVERY DAY.
TO TAKE WANTED -- CCS AND AT
GETTING HELP WITH GROUP AND AND
AND OTHER THINGS LIKE SOCIAL
SECURITY AND IN WELFARE.
AND ADD.
OTHER THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND THE HELPS ME ALIVE NOW IN
AND I LOOKS FOR IT EVERY DAY TO
GOING THERE.
AND AT US ABOUT IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
SPEAKER.
HI MY NAME IS CHRIS GEIGER --
MIND SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
QUALITY GROUP HOMES WHICH IS ONE
OF THE PROVIDERS.
THAT DOES THE IS THE PROGRAM.
I THINK WHILE THE LEGISLATION
VERY WELL INTENTIONED AND THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE MORE MONEY FOR
HOUSING -- FOR OFFENDERS WHO
WERE COMING OUT OF PRISON AND ON
PAROLE -- THE PROGRAM THAT HAS
BEEN THAT THE MONEY IS BEING
TAKEN FROM.
IN ORDER TO FUND THIS IS A
WORTHWHILE PROGRAM IN AND OF
ITSELF IS MADE UP.
IS A PROGRAM FOR SERIOUSLY
MENTALLY ILL ROWLEY'S IS NOT FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ANXIETY
DISORDERS BECAUSE THEY HAD A
ROUGH TIME BEING INCARCERATED OR
JUST FOR YOU KNOW DEALING WITH
LIFE ON LIFE'S TERMS.
TURNED LAWYER ON PAROLE THIS IS
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE ACCESS ONE
DISORDERS DAY HALF OF SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS THEY HAVE.
OF SCHIZOPHRENIA CYCLE NILES
GETS AFFECTED DISORDER DIAGNOSES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT THE IS MY
PROGRAM PROVIDES STRONG
WRAPAROUND SERVICES. TO THOSE
PEOPLE AND IT HAS A HOUSING
COMPONENT BUILT INTO IT.
THOSE FOLKS ARE REFERRED FROM
THE IS MADE PROGRAM INTO THE
HARM ON GLIDERS AND WHERE THEY
GET -- SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
THAT'S A SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PIECE THANK YOU VERY SIMILAR TO
THE OHIO PROGRAM.
EXCEPT WE ALREADY HAVE A HEARING
CALLING YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL -- SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
CASING NON WILL BRING IT BACK TO
I'M SORRY DID YOU [inaudible]
BY MARK.
MISTER CHAIR I APOLOGIZE KERR
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA NOT IN OPPOSITION I
WAS -- CUT UP ACROSS THE HALLWAY
THAT WE'RE STRONG SUPPORTER THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL -- AN
ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS.
HOUSING NORMAL CLOTHES PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BRING IT BACK. TO
THE COMMITTEE -- I WANT TO THANK
US CENTER BILL FOR REINSTALL
FORWARD -- I AM A SUPPORTIVE AND
RECOMMENDING -- AND I BOTH --
AND COLLEAGUES ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY THING -- NINE SENATOR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES IN THE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN AND TWO THOUSAND IS --
SEVENTEEN WE WE DID JOB PROPOSE
BILL SIMILAR TO THIS BILL.
AND THIS BILL HAS GONE THROUGH.
EXTENSIVE PUBLIC INPUT PROCESS --
I THINK THE I THINK YES IT'S
GOING TO BE A CHANGE OKAY
THERE'S GOING TO BE PEOPLE THAT
OPERATE CURRENT PROGRAMS THAT
MAYBE HAVE.
TO OPERATE DIFFERENTLY BUT I
THINK -- THE INTENT OF THE BILL
AND THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL IS.
TO TO THE MORE SUCCESSFUL AT
REDUCING RECIDIVISM IT'S CLEAR
THAT WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS NOT --
IT'S CLEAR THAT -- THE
RECIDIVISM.
DONE BY THE IN PRISON PROGRAMS
IS NOT WE JUST HAD AN AUDIT.
DONE OF THE IN PRISON --
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS THAT
SHOW THAT THE RECIDIVISM.
WAS NOT AFFECTED BY THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE
SPENT.
SO I THINK WE HAVE TO DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY.
SO -- I REGION I VOTE ON THIS OF
THE WOULD BE CHANGES WILL
INVOLVE ALL THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SPOKE HERE TODAY.
AND THE TRANSITION -- SHOULD
HAPPEN ARJUNA VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR --
MOVED TO BILL THE BILL IS THE
MOVE I CENTER LIKE CAL SKI AND
WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ON A BILL TO THE TO BY
SENATOR BILL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND RE REFER TO COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
SENATOR WIENER HI WIENER AYE
MORRELL AYE MORRELL AYE BATES.
BATES I COVER -- THERE ALSO HI
RUSSEL I MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I AM MORE LUCK.
MORE LIKE I ROTH[inaudible]
SKINNER.
SKINNER HI UMBERG.
CASKEY.
HAS THE AYE. FIVE EIGHT SIDE
VOTERS EIGHT TO NOTHING BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN -- HI YES -- EIGHT
TO NOTHING WILL BE THE ROLE OF
THE CROPS A MEMBERS OF BEFORE
YOUR NEXT BILL I JUST WANT TO RE
OPEN -- THE CONSENT CALENDAR CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS FOR AND
TEN FOR THE TRAVELING HI MORRELL.
HI MORRELL HI MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
I NUMBER [inaudible]
OKAY -- NUMBER VISIT HERE
DIGITAL CABLE.
HUESO TOLERANCE.
ZERO ZERO THREE TEN VOTERS TEND
ZERO WILL BE THE ROLE OF AN FOR
CENTER ON BURKE.
OKAY -- NEXT TO I WILL CALL ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB TWO THIRTY FIVE
BY SENATOR DODD.
A MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY TAKING
THE CHAIR IN HIS STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME TO ADDRESS THE
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES SURROUNDING
AN IMPORTANT HOUSING PROJECT IN
MY DISTRICT.
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY FIVE IS A
DISTRICT BILL.
THAT ALLOWS THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF NAPA TO EXPEDITE THE
PRODUCTION OF CRITICALLY NEEDED
HOUSING UNITS.
INCLUDING DEED RESTRICTED UNITS
FOR VERY LOW LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
CITY AND COUNTY TO REACH A
MUTUALLY ACCEPTABLE AGREEMENT TO
ALLOW.
ONE OF THOSE JURISDICTIONS TO
REPORT ON ITS ANNUAL PRODUCTION
REPORT THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
THOSE ENTITLEMENTS.
BUILDING PERMITS IN CERTIFICATES
OF A POCKET BUT SEE ISSUED BY
THE OTHER JURISDICTION FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING IF
CERTAIN CONDITIONS ARE MET.
THE BILL NEAR A VERY NARROWLY
CONSTRAINTS THESE CONDITIONS TO
APPLY SPECIFICALLY TO THE NAPA
PIPE PROJECT INSURING THAT NO-OTHER JURISDICTIONS TRY TO
CREATE.
A LOOPHOLE OUT OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
THE NAP BY PROJECT.
THAT THIS BILL ADDRESSES IS
FINALLY BE REALIZED AFTER TEN
YEARS OF CONVERSATIONS.
IN COLLABORATIONS WITH THE
DEVELOPERS THE CITY AND COUNTY
AT WHICH TIME I WAS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR.
THE CITY AND COUNTY ENTERED INTO
NUMEROUS AGREEMENTS OUTLINING
FUTURE ENTITLEMENTS EXCISION TAX
REVENUE SHARING.
IN THE PROVISION OF MUNICIPAL
SERVICES AND POTABLE WATER BY
THE CITY OF NAPA IN LIEU OF
USING GROUND WATER ALL MOVED THE
BILL.
ALL THIS WAS WORKED OUT THROUGH
A MULTI FAITH BASED DEVELOPMENT
AGREEMENT WHICH IS ALREADY AWAY
UNDER WAY -- SB TWO THIRTY FIVE
WILL ENSURE TE CRITICAL HOUSING
PROJECT IS ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD --
WITHOUT PENALIZING THE COUNTY
FOR WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AS A SUPERVISOR GREGORY AND VICE
MAYOR -- SENSUALLY FROM CITY MAP.
HI THANK YOU AND I'D LIKE -- I
AM SUPPORTIVE OF THIS AS AMENDED
AND SO WE KEEP THE STATIONS
YOU'RE VERY TOBY TERRIFIC THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU
SOON WAS READY GREGORY OR CHAIR
THE BOARD THIS YEAR.
I WANT TO THANK OUR SENATOR DODD
AND SENATOR WIENER YOUR STAFF
YOUR COMMITTEE FOR OPENNESS GET
HERE THIS IS THE GOOD TWO STORY
THE DAY I THINK -- THIS IS ABOUT
HELPING US GET A PROJECT
APPROVED THAT'S READY TO GO.
A LOT OF TALK TODAY ABOUT WHAT
KIND OF PROJECT WHERE WHO
APPROVES BUT TODAY'S ABOUT WE
HAVE A PROJECT READY TO GO AND
YOU'RE GONNA HELP US GET IT DONE.
THE OTHER IS THE PARTNERSHIP ITS
REFLECTION OF THE STRONG
PARTNERSHIPS THAT NAPA COUNTIES
HAD TO HAVE HAD WITH OUR CITIES
BECAUSE A LARGE PART OF OUR
CORPORATE OR IS IS PROTECTED
WITH AN AYE PRESERVED WE GOTTA
GET REALLY CREATIVE.
THIS IS A REFLECTION OF
CONTINUED STRONG WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH HER CITY
PARTNER SO TO THAT AND ALAS MY
COLLEAGUE COUNCILMAN SUCH WITH
US IF YOU WERE.
TO THANK YOU RAJ OF A TO
RESURRECT RADIANCE UNDERDOG FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- THIS
PIECE OF PROPERTY OF LIVED IN A
NAPA MY ENTIRE LIFE THIS IS A A
FORMER INDUSTRIAL SITE IT'S IT'S
AN AMAZING SIGHT FOR HOUSING IN
A LOT OF OTHER USES WILL --
RIGHT ON OUR CITY BORDER SO WITH
THE ANNEXATION INTO THE CITY
PHASED ANNEXATION TO BRING THESE
THOUSAND FRUITION IT'S JUST THAT
AS CENTER DOT SAID. TEN YEARS IN
THE WORKS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OF
PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY RYAN WROTE
A COUNTY REPRESENTS A
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL US SUPPORT OF
PUBLIC COMMENT I SEE NINE IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY SAYING NINE WILL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE -- I WANT TO
THANK US CENTER DODD AND THE
COUNTY AND THE CITY FOR WORKING
VERY CLOSELY.
WITH OUR HOUSING COMMITTEE STAFF
IN WITH ME -- THIS IS A WINDOWS
MY FIRST CAME TO US I THINK WE
WEREN'T SURE WHAT.
TO MAKE OF IT BUT IT BECAME VERY
CLEAR TO ME ONCE OF BOILED IT
DOWN -- THAT THIS IS A SITUATION
WHERE THE COUNTY AND ENTITLED --
THE HOUSING AND NOW IT'S BEING
ANNEXED INTO THE CITY SO THIS IS
A VERY UNIQUE HIGHLY UNIQUE
SITUATION -- AND SO THIS IS NOT --
SITUATION WHERE SOMEONE'S TRYING
TO GET OUT OF THERE -- RENO
OBLIGATION THIS IS A ABOUT --
JUST A VERY UNIQUE SITUATION IS
NOT LIKELY TO REPEAT ITSELF VERY
OFTEN IF EVER SO I'M.
COMFORTABLE SUPPORTING THE BILL --
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE -- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS COLLEAGUES
YES CENTER MORE LOOK.
RESEARCHERS IT IS NOT UNIQUE --
IN ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE A
CORPORATE AREA.
CALLED BOLSA CHICA WHERE THE
COUNTY WOULD APPROVE HOUSING AND
THEN IT WOULD BE.
ANNEXED INTO.
THE CITY IT'S THE PROJECT WAS
CALLED BRIGHT WATER -- AND
IRONICALLY IT'S THE CITY THAT
THE STATE IS DECIDED TO SUE
THAT'S HUNTINGTON BEACH.
BY I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
FOR THE RECORD.
WAY TO GO.
AS I SAID UNIQUE -- ALMOST
UNIQUE ALMOST.
NOT NOT LIKELY TO HAPPEN VERY
OFTEN -- BUT HERE'S AND GLAD TO
THE PROJECT IS PROCEEDING I KNOW
THAT CENTERDAUGHTERS BEEN
INVOLVED WITH THE FOR A VERY
LONG TIME -- SO ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS ARE COMMON.
OKAY SEE NINE WE WILL -- CALLED
OR WE HAVE A MOTION -- TUNES
[inaudible]
PASSAGE.
TO THE RESOLUTION TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ON WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
THE SENATE BILL 235% I'M SORRY.
YES WE HAVE A WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO SENATE BILL TWO THREE FIVE A
SENATOR DODD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND RIVER FOR THE COMING IN
FOR CREATIONS SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER HI MORRELL MORRELL AYE
BATES.
CARRILLO [inaudible]
DORADO.
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MORLOCK [inaudible]
ROUGH SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE ON
BURKE.
WHO CASKEY?
BECAUSE HE I OKAY WITH A FIVE
FIVE BOATS BUT WE HAVE SEVERAL
NUMBERS ABSENCE OF ALL THE ROLE
OPEN. SEVENTY EIGHT IN THE WE
WITHIN KALASHNIKOV.
AT THE RAZA HI.
ALTHOUGH I OKAY THREE SIX BOTH
IT'S ENOUGH TO PASS OUT BUT
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OF CONTRACTS
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I
SAW SOMEONE ELSE HERE.
THANKS FOR CENTER CHIANG IS HERE
GREAT -- SO WILL CALL ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN SB.
FIVE SEVENTY THREE WHERE.
TO HOLD ON ACTUALLY -- CENTER
ONE MOMENT PLEASE -- WE'RE GONNA
OPEN THE ROLE ON SB FIFTY IN US
BEFORE NOW -- THE TEAM.
FOR BEFORE WE GET TO THE CENTER.
CONSOLE FIRST OPEN THE ROLE ON
SB.
FIFTY THE SENATE BILL FIFTY BY
SENATOR WINNER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE.
SENATOR OSLO YES BROWSER I
MCGUIRE -- BURKE.
NUMBER HI KATHY.
BECAUSE HE I YEAH.
OKAY ARE THE VOTES HONESTY FIFTY
NINE IN FAVOR ONE AGAINST -- THE
BILL IS OUT.
WHEN A GOOD AS BEFORE?
THIS IS ON A BILL FORMER SENATOR
MCGUIRE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND RE REFER THE COMMITTEE AND
GOVERNANCE AD FINANCE.
SENATOR WIENER [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BICYCLE.
SKINNER.
AYE SKINNER AYE AMBERG.
NUMBER I CASKEY.
CASSIE I OKAY THE VOTER EIGHT TO
ONE SO AS BEFORE IS AND EVERYONE.
PRESIDENT BILL IS OUT -- OKAY
CENTER CHIANG THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
SB FIVE SEVENTY THREE WILL
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATE TO HER
AND TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION TO THE HOMELESS
EMERGENCY AID PROGRAM OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS HE THIS YEARLY
ALLOCATION WILL ENSURE THAT THE
PROGRAM WILL CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S.
HOMELESSNESS NEEDS.
AS WELL NO CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
STRUGGLING TO ADDRESS ITS
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS FOR QUITE
SOME TIME.
AS OF LAST YEAR ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS.
ARE HOMELESS NEARLY A QUARTER OF
THE NATION'S TOTAL HOMELESS
POPULATION.
AS CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTS FOR ONLY
12% OF THE NATION'S POPULATION
THIS STATISTIC IS BOTH STARTLING
AND CONCERNING.
A SLIGHTLY UNDER 70% CALIFORNIA
HAS THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF UN
SHELTERED HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
IN THE NATION.
A RECENT SURVEY FOUND THE
PROBLEM IN NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
WHICH I'M PROUD TO REPRESENT WAS
EVEN WORSE THAN WE THOUGHT.
IT FOUND IN ONE IN NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY ALONE MY DISTRICT ONE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED SEVEN
PEOPLE WERE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. 80% OF THEM
HUNDRED AND ONE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR PEOPLE ARE
A SHELTERED.
AT LEAST A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
HOMELESS PEOPLE WERE COUNTED AS
VETERANS NINETY SEVEN OF THEM
LIVED ON THE STREETS
[inaudible]
IN. TWENTY EIGHTEEN GOVERNOR
BROWN AND LEGISLATURE AGREED TO
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO CREATE THE
HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID PROGRAM
BLOCK GRANT.
HE HAS PROVIDED DIRECT
ASSISTANCE TO CITIES COUNTIES
AND CONTINUE WHIMS OF CARE. TO
BEGIN TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
THEY KEEP GRANT PROGRAM HAS
ALREADY ASSISTED COMMUNITIES IN
BETTER SERVING THEIR HOMELESS
POPULATIONS THROUGH SERVICES
SUCH AS STREET OUT WHICH IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE DIVERSION
PROGRAMS.
HOUSING VOUCHERS RAPID RE
HOUSING PROGRAMS JUST TO NAME A
FEW.
AS WE ARE ALL AWARE ON MARCH
TWENTIETH MAYORS FROM
CALIFORNIA'S.
THIRTEEN LARGEST CITIES MET WITH
GOVERNOR NEWSOME TO ADVOCATE FOR
ADDITIONAL STATE RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS THE ON GOING
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
THE MAYOR'S HIGHLIGHTED THE
SUCCESS OF THE HEAP PROGRAM
WHICH A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WENT DIRECTLY TO
CITIES WITH A POPULATION OF TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR MORE.
THAT IS ON TRACK TO PRODUCE MORE
THAN FOUR THOUSAND NEW SHELTER
BEDS ACROSS THE STATE.
LA MAYOR CARCETTI SAN FRANCISCO
MAYOR BREED.
AND HARRIS TO DO MAYOR OF
ANAHEIM WHICH I'M PROUD TO
REPRESENT OUR GREAT SUPPORTERS
OF THE HEAP PROGRAM AND TEN
OTHER BIG CITY MAYORS STATED THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF HE FUNDING AND
HOW IT HAS BEEN USED TO SISTER
CITIES IN ADDRESSING THE
HOMELESSNESS NEEDS.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT THE STATE
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO FUND THE
HEAT BLOCK GRANT ANNUALLY IN
ORDER TO DIRECTLY ASSIST CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO ADDRESS THE
PERVASIVE ALL MRS CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY WITNESS TOM
HERNANDEZ.
CHIEF HOMELESS OFFICER FOR THE
COUNTY SAN MARINO THANK YOU SAID
SENATOR KING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TOM RIGHT AND IS
COUNTY SUMMER DINO OFFICE ALMOST
SERVICES.
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY SAN
MARINO I AM PLEASED TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SEVEN
THREE LEGISLATION THAT WILL
PROVIDE A CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION.
OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION TO
THE HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID
PROGRAM TO ASSIST LOCAL AGENCIES
INCLUDING INCLUDING COUNTIES AND
CITIES. TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE SEVENTY NO COUNTY OFFICE
ALMOST SERVICES AS THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ENTITY FOR THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE RECEIVED ABOUT
NINE POINT THREE MILLION IN ONE
TIME FUNDS THROUGH THE HEAP.
THE PROGRAM WILL BE PROVIDING
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR TWENTY TWO
AGENCIES FOR TWENTY FIVE
PROJECTS WHICH INCLUDE SEVEN
CITIES AND THE COUNTY
UNINCORPORATED AREAS.
THE PROCESS IS REALLY SPARKED
THE DEVELOPMENT OF PARTNERSHIPS
AND MULTI JURISDICTIONAL
COLLABORATIONS.
THIS IS ACTIVELY ENGAGED A
CONTINUUM OF CARE TO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER WITH
OUR PARTNERS.
THE SEVENTEEN COUNTY CONTINUE OF
CARE HAS EXPANDED TO INCLUDE A
GOVERNING BOARD COMPOSED OF WORK
FORTY MEMBERS.
WHICH RANGE FROM CITY COUNTY
AGENCY BOTH PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
NONPROFIT FAITH BASED
PARTICIPATION.
AS WELL AS OVER TWO HUNDRED
NONPROFIT PROVIDER
REPRESENTATION WITHIN OUR
CONTINUE OF CARE.
THE FUNDING IS MEANT TO
TERMINATE BY JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AT THIS POINT THERE IS NO
LONGER AN ONGOING PROVISION FOR
CONTINUED SERVICE.
THIS FUNDING WILL DEFINITELY
ASSIST TO ADDRESS THE IMMEDIACY
OF HOMELESSNESS IN OUR REGION.
HOWEVER ONCE FUNDING IS OVER THE
ADDED PROGRAMS STAFFING SERVICES
ENDS WHICH PROVIDES ONLY A
TEMPORARY RESPITE TO THE
INCREASING NUMBER OF
HOMELESSNESS AND OUR COMMITTEE
ARE HOMELESS IN OUR COMMUNITY.
DESPITE THE ONGOING MEET THE
REGION HAS SEEN POSITIVE CHANGES
AS A RESULT OF INVESTMENT IN
PROGRAMS SUCH AS PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING HOMELESSNESS
OUT REACH AGGRESSIVE USE OF
HOUSING FIRST.
AND RAPID RE HOUSING PROTOCOLS.
OUR OVERALL DECREASED.
POINT IN TIME COUNT FROM TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THROUGH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN DEMONSTRATES OUR
SUCCESS AND COMMITMENT AS DOES
THE HOUSING OF OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED HOMELESS VETERANS AND
SUPERVISORS.
IMPLEMENTED A HOUSING INITIATIVE
SPECIFICALLY TARGET.
TO HOUSE HOMELESS VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
HOWEVER OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS ARE REGION'S POINT TIME
COUNT NUMBERS HAVE BEEN-INCREASING CONSISTENT WITH THE
INCREASES SEENAND WITHIN
CALIFORNIA.
HE FUNDS WILL HELP TO PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED EMERGENCY SHELTER
RAPIDLY HOUSING SERVICES
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION SERVICES
AND BRIDGE HOUSING TO THE REGION
WHICH FOR US IS TEMPORARY
ACCOMMODATIONS PROVIDED TO
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
WITH THE CLEARLY DEVELOPED
HOUSING PLAN.
NATIONALLY ACCORDING TO HUG THE
AVERAGE LENGTH OF TIME IT TAKES
FOR AN INDIVIDUAL OR FAMILY TO
MOVE INTO PERMANENT HOUSING IS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE DAYS. FOR
SEVENTY NO COUNTY CONTINUOUS
CARE THE NUMBER RANGES FROM A
HUNDRED AND FOUR TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY DAYS AND THAT WAS TAKEN
FROM HOUSING AND DISABILITY
ADVOCACY PROGRAM DATA.
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
MANDATING THE USE OF HOUSING
FIRST ALONG WITH THE NATIONAL
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE USE OF
LOW BARRIER.
MINIMAL PENALTY HOUSING
EXPEDIENCY THE NEED FOR
CONTINUED FUNDS TO PROVIDE THESE
TYPES OF SERVICES IS IMPERATIVE
TO THE CONTINUED SUCCESS OF OUR
CONTINUE OF CARE.
AND I LIKE YOU -- AND A TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION ON
THE SUPPORT MEASURE AND I HOPE
YOU VOTE ACCORDINGLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORE TOP ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ANAHEIM IN
SUPPORT.
TONY BOY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION HERE
SUPPORT.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
PERSONALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OF PUBLIC
COMMENT SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. TO
NUMBER BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND SENATOR MORE LUCK
MOVES A BILL COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS -- CENTER
WHAT COUNTY.
I'M I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THIS IS AN EMERGENCY AID BILL
AND NOW WERE BEFORE AND I'M NOT
DISPUTING THAT THE HOMELESS
PEOPLE TODAY DURING THE CRISIS
ONE OF WIRE WE GOING WE TAKE AN
EMERGENCY BILL.
AFTER A YEAR AND MAKING IT AND
THEY CAN'T AN ANNUAL CONTINUE
APPROPRIATION WITHOUT THE
BENEFIT OF FINDING OUT THE BILL
BILL IN THE ATKINS BILL THESE
OTHER.
ALSO GO WINTER DRESS THE
HOMELESS CRISIS.
RIGHT SO I KNOW THAT WE ARE A WE
ARE ON WAITING FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY REPORT BUT WITH FEE THAT
THE FUNDING HAS BEEN ALLOCATED
TO CITIES COUNTIES AND
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE.
WITH THE INTENTION SUPPORTING
EXISTING PROGRAM SO WE DO HAVE
DATA THAT IT'S WORKING WITH WITH --
THOSE -- AGENCIES AND SO I
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
OUR FUNDING.
BUT I GUESS MY MISTER CHAIR WHEN
WE DID THIS THIS WAS A BANDAID
THIS WAS A BANDAID THIS IS
EMERGENCY FUND THE WE'RE GONNA
THROW TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OUT AND LET IT
GO GO OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY.
NOW YOU'RE MAKING A PERMANENT
WITHOUT HAVING. TO THE GUTS OF
THE PROGRAM THAT WE NORMALLY
WOULD HAVE WORK SOME
COORDINATION WITH -- WITH --
AGAIN THE ATKINS BILL THAT SHE
HAS CONTINUOUS CARE WE'VE GOT A
BILL LATER ON WITH EMERGENCY
SHELTERS SOMETHING ELSE I MEAN
I'M RIGHT NOW I'M NOT PREPARED
THAT. TO SUPPORTED NOT THAT I
DON'T THINK THAT THERE'S NOT A
HOUSING CRISIS ISSUES THIS IS
A ONE UP QUITE A ONE YEAR IDEA
OR TO YOUR IDEA I GUESS IT IS AN
AND MAKE ITS CONTINUOUS THAT'S
USUALLY NOT THE WAY TO WE'D LIKE
TO MAKE LEGISLATION HERE REGIS.
TAKE A BANDAID TO MAKE IT
PERMANENT SO.
I GUESS.
NO I WILL LOOK FOR TO THE REPORT
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
I AM -- RECOMMEND UNITED VOTE
TODAY THIS WILL TO MILLION AS A
BUDGET -- ISSUE -- AND THIS WILL
GO TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WHICH WHOSE JOB IT IS.
TO DEAL WITH -- BUDGETARY
IMPLICATIONS AND BILLS IN TERMS
OF THE HOUSING ISSUE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I
SUPPORTED AND I THINK MANY OF US
SUPPORTED LAST YEAR I DON'T NEED
ANY DISPUTE THAT THE MONEY IS
IMPORTANT AND THAT THE NEED IS.
HUGE AND OF COURSE THE GOVERNOR
HAS PUT SIGNIFICAN ALMOST
RELATED FUNDING IN HIS PROPOSED
BUDGET -- SO UNDERSTANDING THAT
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A SIGNIFICANT
APPROPRIATIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL.
ANALYZE AND ASSESS AND I'M SURE
CENTER YOU'LL BE WORKING IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS ON THIS -- AS A
POLICY MATTER I'M COMFORTABLE
SUPPORTING THIS AND I DO
RECOMMEND THAT I BUILT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO FIVE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SURE YEAH I I I BELIEVE THAT IF
IT IS MORE OF A SEMANTICS ISSUE
WITH.
YOU KNOW THE I GUESS WHATEVER
YOU CALL IT BUT I BUT MY FOCUS
IS REALLY ON THAT THE PERVASIVE
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE.
AND WHATEVER FUNDING THAT WE
NEED TO DO TO ALLOCATE -- TO TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT YOU KNOW I I AM
GOING TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT SO
WITH THAT I I WOULD URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
IN MY MOST CENTER MAROC.
THE SENATE BILL FIVE SEVENTY
THREE BY SENATOR CHIANG THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CENTER WIENER.
AYE WIENER AYE MORRELL.
BATES.
BATES I COVER.
DORADO.
DORADO AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE I ROUGH [inaudible]
SKINNER.
NUMBER.
NUMBER I CASKEY.
GUSTY NOW. FOR A VOTER SIX ONE
THAT'S ENOUGH TO PASS A BILL --
BUT WE'LL KEEP THE ROLL OPEN FOR
UP TO MEMBERS THANK YOU.
I SEE THE CENTER PORTANTINO'S
HERE SO WE WILL GO -- TO AND
THERE ARE AM I MISSING ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE NOW CENTER
PORTANTINO ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE SB.
SIX NINETY FIVE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE CHAIRS.
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH MY OFFICE I KNOW --
EVERYBODY WORKED HARD ON THIS
BILL -- AND SO I APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT -- VISUALLY ASKS -- SB --
SIX NINETY FIVE WELL LET ME JUST
START BY SAYING YOU KNOW
SOMETHING THAT'S ALWAYS.
SORT OF INTRIGUED ME -- ABOUT
FOSTER YOUTH I MEAN I I'VE DONE.
ALMOST EVERY YEAR IN OFFICE I
HOLD THE FOSTER YOU TOWN HALL MY
DISTRICT OFFICE IS VERY CLOSE.
TO THE FOSTER YOUTH COMMUNITY
AND NUMBER OF GROUP HOMES AND
IT'S JUST A IT'S JUST A A
COMMUNITY THAT I JUST DEEPLY
CARE ABOUT AND I'VE.
BEEN STAGGERED BY THE STATISTICS
OF WHAT HAPPENS AFTER MANSA
PATIENT -- WITH MANY FOSS YOUTH --
ENDING UP IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM -- I'VE ALWAYS
THOUGHT WE COULD DO MORE AND AND
TRY TO ENCOURAGE LASTING FAMILY
RELATIONSHIPS AND SO.
I WAS INTRIGUED BY THIS IDEA OF
MAYBE WE CAN INCENTIVIZE --
FAMILIES TO TAKE IN FOSTER YOUTH.
BY CREATING A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM --
ANTI IT.
SERENA AND SO.
YOU KNOW WHEN THE STAFF CAME
BACK AND SAID YOU KNOW CAN WE
LOWER FROM 10% 25% I SAID
ABSOLUTELY I MEAN I I I JUST
WANT TO SEE.
IF IF AN INCENTIVE WORKS.
BECAUSE I HAVE THIS CRAZY IDEA
THAT IF WE CAN CREATE.
THIS PROGRAM.
AND CREATE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
FAMILIES BEYOND EMANCIPATION
THAT WE MIGHT BE HELPING A CHILD.
YOU KNOW ONCE THEY'RE OUT OF THE
SYSTEM AND SO THAT'S SORT OF THE
THEORY BEHIND IT AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND THE
STAFF WORKING WITH US TO GET
THIS.
IN A POSITION WHERE I BELIEVE
THE CHAIR -- WILL HAVE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY BUT THAT'S THE
WHOLE THEORY BEHIND IT IT'S NOT.
TO TO TO GIVE ANYBODY RELIEF
IT'S NOT TO GIVE ANY SPECIAL
TREATMENT JUST TO TRY TO CREATE
SOME SYSTEM. TO HELP INCENTIVIZE
PLACING FOSTER YOUTH IN.
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES AND SO
THAT'S THE HEART OF IT -- AT THE
SAME TIME WE WERE APPROACHED BY
THE SENIOR LEGISLATURE -- TO
TALK ABOUT -- HOW SHARING
ARRANGEMENTS FOR LOW INCOME
SENIORS WHO FIND THEMSELVES
HOMELESS OR ABOUT TO BE HOMELESS
ARE HARM HURTING WHEN THEY'RE
RENTING OR BUYING -- AND SO YOU
KNOW WE WANT ALSO HELP THAT
POPULATION BY -- GIVING SOME --
COMMONSENSE TO HOME SHARING WITH
SENIOR SO THIS BILL DEALS WITH
BOTH OF THOSE ISSUES -- I THINK
THEY'RE BOTH YOU KNOW WHERE THE
EFFORTS AND SO WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
BALANCE IS FOR YOU TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE MAP SELECT THANK YOU.
OKAY -- IS THERE ANY SUPPORT OF
TESTIMONY.
I SEE NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
WERE YOU.
WITHIN THE STANCE BEFORE.
YES IS THE CENTER HAS SAID WE
HAVE BEEN HERE BEFORE BRIAN
AUGUSTA.
WHICH CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
IN AS A SENATOR PORTANTINO NOTED
WE HAVE HAD A SIMILAR POSITION
ON HIS PRIOR BILL AND WE'VE SEEN
OTHER BILLS FROM OTHER AUTHORS.
AND IT JUST NOTE FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION -- NOW
OBVIOUSLY WE REGRET OPPOSING
THIS BILL BECAUSE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOAL OF
INCREASING FOSTER YOUTH
PLACEMENTS AND SHARED HOUSING
ARRANGEMENTS.
WE DON'T AGREE WITH THIS
APPROACH AND IT'S YOU KNOW
COMING ON THE HEELS OF A A LONG.
DISCUSSION THIS AFTERNOON ABOUT
HOW DO WE INCREASE THE HOUSING
SUPPLY.
THIS BILL WOULD.
DECREASE.
OUR POTENTIAL SITES FOR THE
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING AFFORDABLE
TO LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
BECAUSE IT WOULD IT WOULD TAKE
OUR REGION HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION AND ALLOW THE CITY TO
REDUCE IT EVEN BY THE 5% THAT --
THE COMMITTEE IS REQUESTED.
REDUCE IT BY 5% WHICH WOULD
CORRESPOND TO REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF LAND THAT A CITY MUST
IDENTIFY ITS HOUSING ELEMENT TO
MEET THAT NEED.
AND WE THINK THAT'S THE WRONG
APPROACH. TO ADDRESSING THE NEED
THAT MISTER PORTANTINO HAS
IDENTIFIED -- WOULD LOVE TO
FIGURE OUT SOME OTHER INCENTIVES
BUT ALLOWING A CITY TO REDUCE
ITS PLANNING FOR HOUSING TO DO
THAT.
WHO DON'T SEE THE CONNECTION
THAT WILL HELP ENSURE THAT OUR
HOUSEHOLD AGREES TO TAKE EITHER?
A MEMBER OF EITHER POPULATION
BUT WE WILL SEE A LOSS OF
PRODUCTION OF NEW HOUSING WHICH
WE DESPERATELY NEED AND AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WERE OPPOSED.
ANNUAL OR WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY --
JUST ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ZERO F. WE NEED
MORE SITES FOR HOUSING NOT FEWER
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE UPSHOT OF
THIS BILL IS THAT CITIES A TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS PROGRAM WILL.
BE ALLOWED TO PRE PROVIDE FEWER
SITES FOR NEEDED NEW HOUSING WE
WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH THE
SENATOR TO FIND WAYS. TO GET
MORE FOSTER PLACEMENTS BUT THIS
IS THE WRONG APPROACH. THIRTY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
I'D LIKE TO RESPOND IF I COULD.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND
BEFORE IN YOUR CLOTHES PERHAPS
YOU COULD.
RESPOND ARE I JUST WANT TO
RESPOND TO SOME SPECIFIC.
ISSUES MEASURE SIR I'LL ASK YOU
TO RESPOND WITH A FIFTY FOUR I
THINK THE KEY THING.
WORD WAS POTENTIAL SO UNDER THE
CURRENT HOUSING LAW.
WHEN YOU PLAN FOR HOUSING IT'S?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO ACTUALLY BUILD
IT AND SO WE'RE NOT REDUCING.
ANYTHING WERE PLACING
[inaudible]
POR.
FOSTER CHILDREN IN HOMES IN
ORDER TO GET.
THE 5% IN ORDER TO QUALIFY IT'S
NOT A THEORETICAL PLACEMENT.
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO PLACE.
THIS NEEDY CHILD IN A HOME.
YOU DON'T GET A 5% REDUCTION IN
YOUR HOUSING ELEMENT JUST
BECAUSE YOU SAY YOU WANT.
TO IF YOU ACTUALLY PLACE A CHILD
IN A HOME.
IT UP 25%.
YOU CAN MEET YOUR HOUSING
REQUIREMENTS OR NOT GETTING OUT
OF ANYTHING.
AND WE'RE TAKING SOMETHING
THAT'S IN THEORY.
AND WE'RE ACTUALLY SAYING IT HAS
TO BE HAPPEN AND I THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT DISTINCTION -- AND
I THINK THIS IS A POPULATION
THAT'S POOR.
A POPULATION THAT SOMETIMES
DOESN'T HAVE A FAMILY UNIT.
IT'S A POPULATION THAT'S
OFTENTIMES FORGOTTEN.
AND IF WE CAN CREATE AN
INCENTIVE FOR THAT ACTUALLY
PLACES KIDS IN A HOME. FOR A
MERE 5% IN CENTER OF I THINK
THAT'S A LAUDABLE GOAL IN A
LAUDABLE PURPOSE AND YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH WHAT.
YOU KNOW HOW TO PLACE FOSTER USE
FOR FIFTY YEARS.
AND YEAH IT'S AN OUT OF THE BOX
THING IT DOESN'T BUILD ANYTHING
BUT IT DOESN'T TAKE AWAY
ANYTHIG BUT TO PROVIDE SHELTER
FOR A FOSTER YOUTH [inaudible]
ANYWAY.
I CENTER MY COUNTY.
OF RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH
WITH YOUR COMMENT -- I KNOW THAT
WE'VE HAD A PROBLEM WITH UNDER
RENO HAVING CITIES PRODUCE
HOUSING AND AND WE ALL AGREE
MAYBE WELL DONE AGREE BUT WE WE
REALIZE IT JUST IDENTIFYING
SITES.
THAT WE'VE DONE FOR HOUSING
ELEMENT AFTER HOUSE MANAGE TO
HOUSING ELEMENT ISN'T ISN'T
ENOUGH IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WHAT
YOU WANT IS.
YOUR THIS THIS MECHANISM WILL
NOT PRODUCE ANY NEW HOUSING
YOU'LL JUST SAY IT WILL JUST SAY
FOLKS THAT IF YOU PUT TOGETHER
SOME FORK FOSTER USE THE PUT HIM
THERE IN A STABLE ENVIRONMENT.
THEN YOU CAN COUNT THAT TOWARDS
TOWARDS THE THE THE NUMBER I
PERCENT.
WHEN THE WAY IT EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT YOU GET A CREDIT TOWARDS
THE PRODUCTION UNDER RENO BUT
YOU DON'T ACTUALLY BUILD THE ANY --
OF OF THAT THE HOUSING I THINK
THAT'S YEAH WE JUST HAD A
PREVIOUS BILL THAT WANTED. TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
CONTINUOUSLY I DIDN'T SUPPORTER
BUT MAYBE THAT'S A POT OF MONEY
THAT YOU CAN GO IN AND GET THAT
TYPE OF WORK THAT YOU'RE THAT
YOU'RE ASKING FOR BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO HAVE.
YOU WANT TO CREATE THAT
STABILITY AND ALSO EXTEND THE
TIME I BELIEVE YOU WANT YOU WANT
THE PEOPLE TO BE IN A STABLE
FOSTER.
ENVIRONMENT PROVIDING A HOME.
WE'RE NOT BUILDING A HOUSE.
PROVIDING A HOME WE'RE NOT
BUILDING A HOUSE REGRETTED ME
REGRETTABLY MISTER CHAIR I'M NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO SUPPORT I SEE
THAT THE RENO AVENUE -- I I I'M
JUST NOT THERE I'M AND IN ORDER
TO QUALIFY.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE YOUR HOUSING
ELEMENT.
ALREADY STE.
CERTIFIED SUFFICE SO IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY GOING FORWARD.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE YOUR HOUSING
ELEMENT ALREADY CERTIFIED.
IN AND YOU GET A FLOW AGAIN
WE'RE NOT GIVING [inaudible]
RELIEF OR PROVIDING HOMES. 45%.
ANY OTHER A COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS -- SENATOR BATES ADMIN
CENTER MORE LOCK.
I'LL SEND YOU PORTANTINO I LIKE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING ABSOLUTELY BUT
THE WAY WE READ THE BILL IN OUR
ANALYSIS IS THAT ALL YOU HAVE TO
DO IS HAVE A PLAN.
BUT YOU SAID YOU ACTUALLY HAVE
TO MAKE A PLACEMENT SO I THINK
THAT LOOKS TO BE.
REALLY CLARIFIES.
IN THE BILL AND WHAT I LIKE IS
THE FACT THAT ALL OF THIS
HOUSING ISSUES ABOUT THE HOME OF
SO YOU'RE TAKING AN INDIVIDUAL.
WHO'S HOMELESS AND PROVIDING A
DOMICILE FOR THEM.
ON A PERMANENT BASIS.
AND WE KNOW FROM THE POINT --
BECAUSE THE POINT.
ACCOUNT.
THAT A NUMBER OF OUR FOSTER KIDS.
WHO ARE EMANCIPATED LET'S SAY
FALL INTO THE THE DRUG CULTURE?
AND THEY BECOME SUBSTANCE
ABUSERS AND THEY'VE ALSO DEVELOP
IF THEY DIDN'T ALREADY HAVE
PHONE.
HEALTH ISSUES WE HAVE THAT I
MEAN THE SOBER LIVING HOMES
PERFECT EXAMPLE SO I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
BUT I'D LIKE YOU TO MAKE IT FIT
MAKES IT TO THE FLOOR TO MAKE
THAT CLEAR BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
I THINK THAT FROM THE SKI
PACKAGE WE JUST HAVE TO PUT A
PLAN.
NO NO NO IT'S MY INTENTION THAT
YOU ONLY.
GET THE FIVE FOR UP 25%.
IT'S COMMENSURATE WITH THE
ACTUAL NUMBER OF CHILDREN YOU
PLACE IN HOMES SO YOU HAVE A
LEANER REQUIREMENT.
AND THEN YOU'RE ABLE TO COUNTING
YOU HAVE TO REACH THE 5%.
IF YOU HAVE THEM PLACE TO GET A
5% UP TO FOUR AND YOU GET THE
PERCENTAGE OF HOW MANY CHILDREN
YOU ACTUALLY PLACE. 255% THAT
YOU'VE MADE OUT OF THE 1100%
RENO REQUIREMENTS GOT IT OKAY
THERE'S NO THEORY YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE TO PLACE AND IT'S VOLUNTARY
FOR THE CITY STOP IN
[inaudible]
SO ANYWAY.
FERGUSON REMOTEST THE SYSTEM
THAT AND THAT IS THE IMPORTANT
POINT PLACE NUMBER SERVICE NOT
PLAN OR I'LL CLEAR THAT UP
THAT'S OKAY SO IF YOU'LL YOU'LL
ACCEPT THAT AMOUNT I'M SON OKAY
SO WILL WORK OR NOT.
CAPTION IS NEVER BEEN MY INTENT
TO MAKE THIS THEORY YOU ONLY CAN
MEET THE THE THE NUMBER IF YOU
ACTUALLY PLACE MUCH OLDER AND IN
HOMES.
THANK YOU CENTER MARK RESEARCHER
CENTER PORTANTINO FOSTER CARE IS
A COUNTY.
PROGRAM.
AND THEY USUALLY PLACE YOUTH IN
HOMES [inaudible]
SO. ONE WHAT IT WHAT WHAT MEDIA
WE TRYING TO FILL WITH IF THEY
ARE IN HOMES.
IN THE EARLY ARE YOU SAYING THAT
IF WE DON'T PLACE IN THERE AND
LIKE WE HAVE ORANGE WOULD IN
ORANGE COUNTY THE COUNTY OFFICE
HOUSES EMINENT.
NOT EVERY FOSTER YOUTH AS IN A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME MANY ARE IN
GROUP HOMES.
BUT I HAVE A SAY IN A GROUP HOME
SO AND THEN THEY GET EMANCIPATE
SEVEN OUT OF TEN OF AMEND UP IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
YOU'RE USING THE TERM YOUTH SO
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT KIDS
EIGHTEEN AND OLDER THAN.
I'M HOPING THAT IF WE PLACE
YOUNGER FOSTER YOUTH INTO SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES THE FAMILY BOND
WILL CARRY.
FORWARD BEYOND EMANCIPATION.
SO I'M HOPING TO CREATE A WHOLE
NEW INCENTIVE PROGRAM OF
NONTRADITIONAL FOSTER YOUTH I
ENVISION COMMUNITIES WORKING
WITH THEIR CHURCH COMMUNITIES
GOVERNOR QANTAS CLUB OUT OF THE
BOX BUT I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
THE CORRELATION BETWEEN.
GIVING A CITY IN AND SENATE WHEN
REALLY WE GOT WE GOT TO GET THAT
THE HOMES THE PARENTS THE THE
CATALYTIC BUT THAT'S THE
INCENTIVE FOR THE CITIES SO.
COMMUNITY MINDED ORGANIZATIONS
WITHIN THE CITY.
CAN CREATE THIS ON A VOLUNTEER
BASIS AND THE INCENTIVE FOR THE
CITY IS TO GET. 5%.
FROM THEORY ON THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT WHICH HAS ALREADY BEEN
APPROVED TO ACTUALLY PLACING
THESE KIDS IN HOMES [inaudible]
SO.
YES COUNTIES THE ONLY DOWN TO MY
PERSONAL LEVELS I GOT THIRTY
FOUR CITIES SO NOW I'VE GOT A
CITY THAT'S REALLY ACTIVE TRYING
TO FIND PARENTS ARE DOING
COMMUNITY ARE ALL BASED ON THEIR
OWN VOLUNTEER EFFORT AND IT CAN
BECAUSEMAYBE WE THE KIDS ARE
NOW HOUSE.
MORE IN ONE CITY ABOVE THE
NORMAL AVERAGES.
THEY SAY HEY WAS OUR EFFORTS. TO
GET THESE KIDS AND HOMES IN OUR
CITY THEREFORE WE SHOULD GET
ARENA CREDIT.
OF UP 25% MY GETTING IT UP OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND IT'S ALL
VOLUNTEER.
IF THEY DON'T PLACE THE KIDS
THEY DON'T GET THE BENEFIT AND
NO HARM NO FOUL IN.
THE RAIN THERE ARE HOUSING
ELEMENT IS.
APPROVED TO START WITH SO. EIGHT
IT'S JUST AN OUTSIDE THE BOX
INCENTIVE TO TRY TO HELP KIDS
GET HOME SO YES WE'RE NOT
BUILDING ANYTHING BUT WE'RE
PROVIDING HOMES.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY -- THANK YOU TO EVERYONE
INTO.
AND TO SENATOR -- I AS CENTER
KNOWS I SOME QUESTIONS ON THE
SPOKE FIRST CAME TO US AND I
STILL THINK IT'S GOING TO TAKE
SOME WORK -- IN THE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE IN TERMS OF
DEFINING PARTICULARLY THE NEW
ELEMENT -- THAT THE SENIOR
CONGRESS HAS TO PUT IN -- AND
BUT I AM COMFORTABLE WITH THE
REDUCTION FROM 10% 25% -- AND
SOME OF THE GUARD RAILS SO WE
PUT IN-- PASSING THIS OUT OF
COMMITTEE -- SO IS THERE -- A
MOTION -- BY SENATOR BATES --
AND I'M SORRY DID NOT KEEPING UP
SOONER CLOSE NO I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE WE'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT HOME VERSUS
HOUSE AND SO I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO HAVE.
AND I JUST THINK THIS LITTLE
TINY ELEMENT.
WILL HELP SOME KIDS I I I I WAS
STRUCK WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
I HAD A GROUP OF TEENAGERS COME
TO SEE ME WHO ARE ABOUT TO BE
EMANCIPATED AND THIS ONE YOUNG
WOMAN SAID TO ME DURING THE
MEETING WITH MY STAFF SHE SAID
LISTEN.
I'VE GOT MY APPLICATION I'M
GETTING EMANCIPATED I'VE GOT MY
APPLICATION AT EVERY STARBUCKS
IN TOWN AND IF I DON'T GET A JOB
WITHIN THE NEXT SIX MONTHS.
I'M GONNA HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN.
PROSTITUTION AND SELLING DRUGS.
AND I JUST SAID TO MYSELF NO
TEENAGER SHOULD BE EVEN
COGNIZANT OF MAKING THAT TYPE OF
A FAMILY DECISION FOR HERSELF.
AND YOU KNOW SINCE THEN WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO HELP FOSTER YOUTH
EVERY CHANCE WE CAN.
I JUST THINK THIS IS A LAUDABLE
EFFORT TO DO IT AND I APPRECIATE
THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF FOR
HELPING.
I WITHOUT WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL SIX NINE FIVE A
SENATOR PORTANTINO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
MORRELL.
BATES.
BATES I COVER DORADO.
REQUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MORLOCK [inaudible]
ROUGH [inaudible]
SKINNER.
NUMBER.
NUMBER HI BUT CASKEY.
CASTING NOW.
SO THE VOTERS -- FOUR TO ONE BUT
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN
THANK YOU BETTER THANK YOU --
NEXT -- TO WE WILL GO TO SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE HIS BILL ITEM FIVE
SB THIRTEEN CENTER YOU READY
.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'D
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS CONTAINING
COMMENT SIX AND SEVEN IN THE
ANALYSIS.
SB THIRTEEN IS IMPORTANT BILL
THAT WILL ENSURE THE DEVELOPMENT
OF AFFORDABLE ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS AND LIKE SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES.
WERE MULTI FAMILY BUILDINGS
EIGHTY USER CHEAPER THERE
QUICKER TO BUILD AND THEY
REQUIRE NO PUBLIC SUBSIDY
HOWEVER HUNDREDS OF HOMEOWNERS
ARE STOPPED IN THEIR TRACKS WHEN
THEY HAVE WHEN THEY'RE HANDED
THE SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLAR.
A BILL FOR DEVELOPMENT IMPACT
FEES -- SB THIRTEEN CREATES A
TWO YEAR FEE STRUCTURE WELL
WHICH CHANGES EIGHTY USE --
BASED ON THEIR SIZE TO TAKE IN
CONSIDERATION THAT THE IMPACT OF
THE EIGHTY YOU ON THE
NEIGHBORHOODS INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SERVICES IN IS INHERENTLY
DIFFERENT.
FROM OTHER TYPES OF NEW HOUSING
THESE EXCESSIVE FEES COUPLED
WITH A STRINGENT CODE STANDARDS
HAVE PROMPTED MANY HOMEOWNERS TO
BUILD A TO USE WITHOUT PERMITS
WE ALL KNOW SOMEBODY IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD AROUND THE CORNER.
IT HAS AN PERMITTED EIGHTY YOU --
RECENT STUDY PUBLISHED BY THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
ESTIMATES THAT THERE ARE THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND PERMITTED
EIGHTY USING THE GREATER LOS
ANGELES AREA ALONE.
SARAH SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY CREATING
AN AMNESTY PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS A
HOMEOWNER TO BRING EIGHTY YOU
INTO COMPLIANCE IF LOCAL
OFFICIALS DETERMINED THAT THE
NEEDED FIXES ARE NOT NECESSARY
TO PROTECT.
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
RESIDENTS SENATE BILL.
THIRTEEN HAS BEEN SUBSTANTIALLY
SLIM DOWN.
SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE LAST YEAR'S
SENATE BILL EIGHT THREE ONE BY
REMOVING REQUIREMENTS PERTAINING
TO FLOOR AREA RATIO IS.
SET BACKS AND LOT SIZE.
WITH ME TODAY IS SAMARA CISNEROS
FROM THE BAY AREA COUNCIL AND
STEVE ALEJO'S FROM.
I BUILDER OF PRE FAB EIGHTY USE
MISTER CHAIR [inaudible]
MY WITNESSES.
SAID HE ACT AFTERNOON.
FIVE AS HUMANS THE CENTERS OF
THE BAY AREA COUNCIL A NONPROFIT
PUBLIC POLICY ORGANIZATION
ADVOCATING FOR A STRONG ECONOMY
AND A BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
EVERYONE WHO LIVES HERE.
HOURS OF YOUR HOUSING SHORTAGE
CONTINUES TO DRIVE UP HOUSING
CRISIS ADDRESSING SHORTFALL OF
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION HOMES
WITHIN SEVEN YEARS SEEMS DON
TEEN.
BUT THIS AMBITIOUS GOAL SHOULD
MOTIVATE US TO TAKE BOLD ACTION
NOW.
WE HAVE SEVERAL BARRIERS TO
OVERCOME BUT WE SHOULDN'T
UNDERESTIMATE ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS AND SB THIRTEEN CAN HELP
PROVIDE A VIABLE SOLUTION TO OUR
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY PROBLEM.
FOR EXAMPLE EIGHTY USE OUR
FORMAL BY DESIGN BECAUSE LESS TO
BUILD AND RUN FOR LESS AND THIS
IS CRITICAL WHEN IN CALIFORNIA
THE AVERAGE COST FOR HOUSING IS
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS.
AND EVEN MORE SO IN METROPOLITAN
AREAS IN SAN FRANCISCO -- CLOSE
TO SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
ACCORDING TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TURNER CENTER REPORT ALMOST 60%
OF EIGHTY YOU OWNERS READ TO THE
UNITS AT BELOW MARKET RATES.
AN ENTRY TO MARKET IS AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY THE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS ARE SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES.
IF JUST 10% OF CALIFORNIA'S NINE
MILLION. NINE MILLION OWNERS OF
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES WERE TO
CREATE EIGHTY USE THAT COULD
EASILY AND QUICKLY ADD NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND MUCH NEEDED
HOMES.
ALTHOUGH WE MADE SOME PROGRESS
IN LOWERING AT RESTRICTIONS FOR
THE PASSAGE OF SB TEN SIXTY NINE
WHICH WE WERE PROUD TO SPONSOR.
SB THIRTEEN BUILT ON HIS
LEGISLATION AND PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL SOLUTIONS.
AND TAXIS ARE MAJOR BURDEN FOR
THE TYPICAL HOMEOWNER AND ARE
DESIGNED FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION
THAT TRIGGER INCREASE SERVICES
AND UTILITIES.
THE TIERED FEE REDUCTION
PROPOSED IN SB THIRTEEN STRIKES
A FAIR BALANCE FOR BOTH
HOMEOWNERS AND AGENCIES.
ELIMINATING A LOCAL REQUIREMENT
OF OWNER OCCUPANCY IT'S ALSO KEY
TO UNLOCKING ITS HOUSING
SOLUTION.
IN CALIFORNIA ALMOST TWO MILLION
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES ARE RENTER
OCCUPIED.
THIS IS AN UNNECESSARY
REQUIREMENT REDUCING OPTIONS FOR
HOMEOWNERS AND RENTERS.
IT'S FOR LEGISLATION WILL ADD
THOUSANDS OF NEW HOMES TO
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING STOCK. FOR
THESE REASONS AND MORE.
COUNSEL IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB.
THIRTEEN GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS STEVEN ELSE I'M THE PRESENT
OWNER OF VALLEY ON DEVELOPMENT
AND EIGHTY YOU CONTRACTOR AND
CREATIVITY YOU A EIGHTY YOU.
CAN FACTORY COMPANY BASED IN
FAIRFIELD CALIFORNIA -- WE'VE
BEEN BUILDING A USE FOR THE PAST
FOURTEEN YEARS.
SO WE'RE VERY INTIMATE WITH THE
PROCESS BOTH PRE AND POST --
LEGISLATION CHANGES -- WE BUILT
OVER  HUNDRED SEVENTY OF THEM
ACROSS PROBABLY MORE THAN NINETY
FIVE JURISDICTIONS.
SO WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS AND A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PROBLEMS -- THEY GO WITH EIGHTY
USE IN IN IN TERMS OF WHAT
CITIES ARE GOOD AND WHAT CITIES
ARE ARE BAD TO DEAL WITH.
JUST A QUICK -- JUST A QUICK
UNDERSTANDING WHAT WHAT EIGHTIES
ARE ON THE TYPICALLY RANGE IN
SIZE FROM ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY
SQUARE FEET.
ON UP TO ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET -- THEY CAN COST
ANYWHERE FROM THE LOW IN FROM
ABOUT SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND ON UP
TO ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO THERE'S A
THERE'S QUITE A RANGE OF BOTH IN
SIZE AND PRICING.
OF EIGHTY YEARS -- I'VE BEEN
SITTING HERE MRS DAY LISTENING
TO LOTS OF DISCUSSION ABOUT FOUR
BY HOUSING -- I DON'T.
I DON'T REALLY SEE ANY OTHER
SOLUTIONS OUT THERE THAT CAN
PERCENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNIT
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS I
MEAN THERE'S JUST NOT A LOT OUT
THERE -- I HEAR A LOT OF TALK I
SEE A LOT.
I WATCHED WHAT'S GOING ON WITH A
LOT OF DIFFERENT BILLS.
AND I SEE A LOT OF DEVELOPMENT
HAPPENING AND YOU KNOW WHEN IT
COMES RIGHT DOWN TO IT YOU KNOW
MOST OF THE THE FOR ONE THOUSAND
UNITS.
STAR OFFICE PROBABLY ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE BAY AREA AND IT'S
NOT UNCOMMON TO SEE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNIT HAVE A
PRICE TAG OF EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE BAY AREA.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT A TO USE
WERE LOOKING AT SOMETHING VERY
UNIQUE.
WE ALSO NEED TAKING
CONSIDERATION THAT THESE HOMES
DO NOT REQUIRE ANY SUBSIDIES SO
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT ANYTHING
WHERE WE'RE ASKING STATE TO HAND
OUT MONEY TO MAKE I IS HAPPEN.
HOMEOWNERS HAVE THE INCENTIVE ON
THEIR OWN EVERYBODY YOU KNOW.
HAS SOMEBODY IN THEIR LIFE THAT
COULD USE ONE OF THESE I CAN'T
GO ANYWHERE WITHOUT SPARKING
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT I DO FOR
A LIVING AND GATHER A GROUP OF
PEOPLE AROUND ME OR SHARE IN THE
PROBLEMS.
IN THIS IS JUST A IT'S IT'S JUST
A PRODUCT THAT IS SO NEEDED.
SO WITH THAT IN CONSIDERATION
WHY ARE WE BUILDING ANYMORE.
I MEAN WE WE SHOULD BE BUILDING
TONS OF RIGHT I MEAN IT'S JUST
IT THEY'RE THEY'RE AFFORDABLE --
EVERYBODY NEEDS SOME HOMERS
WANNA.
WE SERVE IMPEDIMENTS I MEAN
WE'RE STILL WHEN IT COMES RIGHT
DOWN TO IT WHEN YOU TAKE WHEN
YOU TAKE THAT EXAMPLE OF A SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR EIGHTY YOU.
AND YOU TACK ON FORTY FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF IMPACT
FEES.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR THAT
HOME OR TO MAKE THAT DECISION.
AND SAY YOU KNOW I WANNA GO AND
PULL THE TRIGGER FOR SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF ACTUAL
PHYSICAL CONSTRUCTION.
AND HERE.
THE MAN OR MONEY THAT GOES
NOWHERE IT'S IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND WHAT IMPACT FEES ARE
BECAUSE WHEN WE LOOK AT IMPACT
FEES WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY TALKING
ABOUT THE BUILDING.
PERMIT FEES OR THE THE
APPLICATION REVIEW FEES THESE
FEES ARE CHARGED INDEPENDENTLY
BY THE PLANNING THE BUILDING
DEPARTMENT.
IMPACT FEES OF THOSE OF THE FEES
ARE COMING FROM THE WATER
DISTRICT.
SCHOOL DISTRICT -- PARKS AND
RACKS OF FIRE SANITATION
DISTRICT -- SO SO END AND IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
THOSE FEES ARE ACTUALLY TO
PROVIDE A NEW SERVICE TO THAT
LOT THAT SERVICE READY EXISTS ON
THE A LOT.
IS READY HOME THERE AND AT THAT
PRIMARY HOMES ALREADY PAID FOR
THOSE SERVICES.
ADDING TO THIS PROBLEM ON A
DAILY BASIS WHAT WE SEE IS THAT
WHEN WHEN PEOPLE ARE CONFRONTED
WITH THE SITUATION.
AND THE QUESTION COMES UP WHY
DON'T I JUST DO IN ADDITION THAT.
THAT VERY SAME ADDITION OF THE
VERY SAME SIZE IS USUALLY NOT
CHARGE THOSE IMPACT FEES.
SO NOW WE HAVE THE SITUATION
WHERE A HOMEOWNER IS DECIDING.
WHETHER THEY SHOULD DO AN EIGHTY
YOU OR THEY SHOULD JUST DO A
SIMPLE ADDITION.
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT WITH THAT
SCENARIO IS THAT WERE
DISCOURAGING THEM FROM ACTUALLY
BUILDING AFFORDABLE UNIT.
AND WE'RE ACTUALLY WE'RE
ACTUALLY STEERING THEM TOWARDS A
SOLUTION WHICH BASICALLY FURTHER
EXACERBATE THE PROBLEM BY
CREATING MORE MAKE MANSIONS AND
BIGGER HOMES THAT COST MORE AND
MAKE THE DEVICE EVEN.
FURTHER SO I THINK WE REALLY
NEED TO DO -- DIDN'T DO THIS
OPPORTUNITY JUSTICE BY FINDING
WAYS TO REDUCE THOSE FEES AND
MAKE IT EASIER ON THE CONSUMER
MAKE A RELATIVE TO THE ACTUAL
COST THAT THE BURDEN WITH FOR
THE ACTUAL CONSTRUCTION OF THAT
UNIT.
ON A TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS UNIT FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR FEES IS IS.
IS APPROPRIATE BUT ON A SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR UNIT FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR FEE IS NOT
APPROPRIATE.
THE OTHER ISSUE THAT COMES UP
EVERY NOW AND THEN AS OUR
OCCUPANCY.
AND I JUST WANT TO DO A QUICK
POINT ON THAT IT'S IT'S IT'S
IT'S BROUGHT UP IN A LOT OF
CONVERSATION AND I KNOW THE THE
EPA AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS --
CAN REALLY WANTED.
WANT THE OWNER OCCUPANCY THERE --
I JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
THAT THE THE THERE ARE THERE ARE
FOUR CITIES IN IN A NORTH
AMERICA THEY'VE DONE OVER A
THOUSAND EIGHTY YEARS.
AND WHAT ALL FOUR OF THEM HAVE
IN COMMON THEY DON'T HAVE
DEMOCRACY REQUIREMENTS.
THEY ALSO REMOVED A LOT OF
PARKING RESTRICTIONS AND IMPACT
FEES AS WELL.
BUT THE BUT THE POINT IS THAT.
WE HAVE TO REMOVE THE BARRIERS
FOR THE HOMEOWNER TO MAKE THIS
DECISION IF WE WANT THESE TO BE
OUT THERE IN HIGH NUMBERS.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO SPEND A LOT
OF MONEY COMING FROM THE STATE
TO CREATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE NEED TO GET OUT OF THE
HOMEOWNERS WAY TO MAKE IT EASIER
TO DO THE SAME THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ARE TO
RESPECT ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WE ARE%
IN SUPPORT OF OF THE BILL WE DO
APOLOGIZE THAT OUR LETTER WAS
DELIVERED YESTERDAY -- AND URGE
YOU TO VOTE HI.
LOUIS MANTE WITH CALIFORNIA BE
WE WERE LATE IN GETTING OUR
LETTER IN AS WELL BUT AREN'T
SUPPORT THE BILL. TWENTY WITH A
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT SITUATION
WHERE SPORTS ALL.
YOUR LETTER WAS IN ON TIME.
THANK YOU PARTNERS OKAY ANY
ADDITIONAL SO ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT HER.
SORRY IT'S BEEN A KIND OF THAT --
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING SHARON MEMBERS I'M
SPEAKING OF THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION LAUREN
TABLE AND SAT REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
I'M WE DO HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION.
AMONG THE BILL BUT I DO FIRST
WANT TO APPRECIATE -- THE DIET I
GUESS YOU COULD SAY THAT SB
THIRTEEN IS AND THE WORK THAT
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE HE HAS DONE
TO SLIM DOWN -- SOME OF THE
CHANGES THAT WERE INITIALLY
PROPOSED IN PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF
THE BILL -- WE DO REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND SO FROM THAT
STARTING POINT PERHAPS WERE NOT
AS FAR APART ON SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE.
A GENERALLY SPEAKING A PA I'M IS
CONCERNED THAT WE DO SEE ANNUAL
CHANGES BEING PROPOSED EACH YEAR
TO THE EIGHTY LAW -- WE DO KNOW
AS EVERYBODY HAS -- SCENE THAT
WE HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE
IN I'M AT PROTECT PRODUCTION
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS WITH THE
CHANGES IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN I MEAN WE DO JUST
GET CONCERNED WITH GOING BACK
REVISING THOSE ORDINANCES THAT
EVERYBODY HAS ALREADY ADOPTED OR
IS IN THE PROCESS OF OF DOING
BUT AGAIN A PEAK IS NOT OPPOSED
EIGHTY USE WE DON'T WANT TO PUT.
ANY RESTRICTIONS OR WE DON'T
WANT THINGS TO BE IN PLACE THAT
LIMIT A D. AS WE JUST THINK THAT
THERE DOES NEED TO BE SOME
PARAMETERS AROUND CERTAIN THINGS
AND SO.
ON THE ISSUE OF HONOR OCCUPANCY
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT'S PROBABLY
THE BIGGEST CONCERN I THINK APA
HAS AND ONE THAT CERTAINLY IS
NEAR AND DEAR TO SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI -- WE ARE JUST
GENERALLY CONCERNS THAT -- WITH
THE REMOVAL AS OWNER OCCUPANCY
AS A TOOL FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND THAT IS -- THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO REQUIRE HONOR OCCUPANCY --
THE MORE LIKELIHOOD OF AN OWNER
THAT IS -- RESIDING IN THEIR
DWELLING WHETHER IT'S THE DO YOU
OR THE THE MAIN UNIT.
THAT WILL MORE THAN LIKELY
HOPEFULLY RENT OUT THEIR UNIT
FOR A MORE AFFORDABLE RENT AND
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT REMOVING
THOSE -- OWNER OCCUPANCY
RESTRICTIONS OUR ABILITY -- FROM
THE BILL DOES POTENTIALLY
INCENTIVIZE INVESTORS TO COME IN
AND EITHER RENTS HOW IT'S
PURCHASE A LOT WITH AN EIGHTY
YOU OR AT AN EIGHTY OR I'D BOTH --
AND THEN RENT THEM OUT FOR
WHATEVER THE MARKET WILL BILL
BEAR AND WE DON'T WE DON'T WANT
TO SEE THAT WE KNOW THAT SOME
JURISDICTIONS DO USE OWNER OF
ORDER OCCUPANCY AS A TOOL TO
THAN.
A PLACE AFFORDABILITY
RESTRICTIONS ON THE UNIT SO THAT
IF ON OCCUPANCY IS NOT REQUIRED
FOR EXAMPLE SANTA ROSA WILL
WAIVE UNDER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENTS.
I KNOW WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE OTHER JURISDICTIONS THAT DO
HAVE OTHER HARDSHIP WAIVERS IN
THE EVENT THAT THE OWNER MOVES
OUT OF THE IS THE MAIN OR THE X.
AT THE EIGHTY YEAR OLD -- OR
NEEDS TO MOVE FOR WORK RELATED
REASONS WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S BEEN SOME ISSUES WITH
FINANCING ON OWNER OCCUPANCY --
WE REALLY DON'T WANT THAT TO BE --
THE IMPEDIMENT TO THE TO BEING
ABLE TO STILL REQUIRES SO WERE
REALLY HELPFUL THAT WE CAN TRY
TO WORK WITH A SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI.
ON MAY BE FINE TUNING SOME
LANGUAGE IN THOSE INSTANCES SO
THERE ARE HARDSHIP WAIVERS AND
THERE IS THE ABILITY TO REQUIRE
THAT BUT HOPEFULLY WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE
AND AND FOR THE REASONS I'VE
STATED FOR NOW WE ARE OPPOSE
LESS AMENDED THANK YOU.
EVENING CROWNED ROSSI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION WE TOOK IN POST
POSITION ON FRIDAYS MY APOOGIES
FOR THE LATE OPPOSITION -- FOR
OUR PARKING FIRE DISTRICTS
IMPACT FEES ARE.
AN ESSENTIAL SOURCE OF REVENUE
IN PARTICULAR FOR A FIRE
DISTRICTS THE IMPACT FEES
TYPICALLY GO TO PAY FOR NEW
EQUIPMENT FOR NEW ENGINES TO
SERVICE.
AREAS AS POPULATION DENSITY
INCREASES FOR OUR PARK DISTRICTS
THE IMPACT FEES TYPICALLY GO
TOWARDS ESTABLISHING NEW PARKS
THIS POPULATION IN A I CITIES
AND IN INCREASE -- SO AGAIN WE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE ABILITY
FOR OUR DISTRICTS INTO NEW
PROVIDING A PUBLIC SAFETY
SERVICES AS WELL AS SERVICES FOR
QUALITY OF LIFE IF SB THIRTEEN
MOVES FOR THANK YOU.
PLEASE PRESS.
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
THING BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES AN
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANNA
CABALLERO.
VERY QUICKLY I'M I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE I
JUST A QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER
WOULD BE ANY RESTRICTION ON THE
UTILIZATION OF AN EIGHTY UNIT
FOR RENTAL PER FOR FOR SHORT
TERM RENTAL PURPOSES.
NO NOT IN THE HERE WE'RE LEAVING
THAT UP TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THEY'RE ALL OVER
THE BOARD OF WHAT THEY WANT
LIMóN IT DOESN'T [inaudible]
I'M AGNOSTIC.
YEAH I GUESS I WANT TO URGE YOU
NOT TO BE AGNOSTIC ON THIS --
ONE IF WE'RE GONNA COUNTED AS
PART OF OUR RENEWED NUMBERS AND
I THINK IT SHOULD FRANKLY -- I
THINK IT IT SHOULD BE RESTRICTED
BUT THAT'S JUST MY TWO CENTS
WORK THE NIGHT I PUT THAT IN
THERE.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES SENATOR
SKINNER -- I JUST NOTE THAT THE
A. P. A.'S PART OF THEIR
OPPOSITION WAS THE FACT THAT.
PEOPLE THAT ARE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WOULD HAVE TO ONCE
AGAIN REVISED THEIR AID YOU
ORDINANCES HAD WE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL LAST YEAR AS WE HAD
ATTEMPTED.
TO THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN REVISING
THEIR ORDINANCES AT THE SAME
TIME AND ALL TOGETHER.
SO IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT.
THE BILLS -- GOT HUNG UP LAST
YEAR BUT I THINK THIS IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF IT'S
MUCH EASIER [inaudible] TO GIVEN
THAT WE HAVE EXISTING
RESIDENTIAL UNITS.
AN EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE. TO
ADD ANOTHER RESIDENTIAL UNIT IS
MUCH EASIER THAN STARTING AGAIN.
WITH NEW CONSTRUCTION WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH ANY OF OUR OTHER.
BILLS THAT WE KNOW WE'RE GOING
TO NEED TO DO THOSE BUT THEY
IT'S GOING TO TAKE MUCH LONGER.
SO IN TERMS OF THIS HOUSING
CRISIS THIS IS VERY NEEDED BUT I
DO SEE HERE DISCOVER YEARS
CONCERNING THAT I WANT THESE
ADDITIONAL UNITS TO COUNT
TOWARDS ARENA.
I WANT THEM NOT TO BE.
SHORT TERM.
AND I ALSO THINK.
THE WHILE.
REQUIRING OWNER OCCUPANCY IS TOO
ONEROUS I THINK SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
THAT MINIMIZES THE SPECULATIVE
VALUE SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
MOTIVATION.
FOR THESE -- HOUSING
CORPORATIONS LIKE WHAT HAPPENED
IN SACRAMENTO WE HAVE A COUPLE
CORPORATION STEP BOUGHT UP
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES -- AND THEN OUR
RAINING IN THE MET QUITE HIGH
PRICES AND SO.
SOME LEVEL YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S
A RESTRICTION ON OF A YOU KNOW
LARGE LARGER CORPORATE OWNERS%
BUT ANYWAY OTHER NAT I THINK
IT'S A GREAT DEAL.
CAN I MOVE IT.
OKAY WITH MOTION -- I I WILL SAY
I'M.
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR TAKING
HIM INSIDE AMERICAN MONEY AND I
ON THE SIDE LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR A JOINT AUTHORED
WHATEVER YOU WOULD.
ADD ME AS STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
I WANTED TO SAY THERE ARE AS
SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN INVOLVED IN
HOUSING -- POLICY AND POLITICS
FOR A LONG TIME THERE ARE -- A
LOT A LOT OF ASPECTS OF HOUSING
POLICY POLITICS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE UPSETTING TO ME IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE'VE DONE IN
TERMS OF MAKING IT HARD TO
CREATE HOUSING AND HAVING
CHILDREN SLEEPING IN CARS AND
YOUNG PEOPLE CAN'T MOVE BACK TO
THE COMMUNITY GREW UP IN.
A VERY TOUGH SITUATION THERE ARE
A FEW THINGS THAT REALLY BUG ME
MORE THAN WHAT WE HAVE ALLOWED
CITIES TO DO IN TERMS OF FEEDING
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY. TO ALLOW.
YOU TO USE IT WAS I AM THIRTY
FIVE YEARS AGO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PASSED A LAW THEY
SAID YOU HAVE TO LET PEOPLE PUT
EIGHTY USE.
IN THEIR HOMES PERIOD.
AND FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS CITIES
IN THE STATE INCLUDING BY CITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO HAVE FLOUTED
THAT LAW.
NOR TO HAVE VIOLATED THE LAW.
AND THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE HOUSING SHORTAGE
WE HAVE THE EFFICIENCY OF
PUTTING IN LAW UNITS AND NOW
YOU'RE NOT.
YOU KNOW GETTING INTO HIGH
IMBOLC ISSUES THAT PEOPLE
SOMETIMES ARE UNHAPPY ABOUT WITH
NEW DEVELOPMENT.
AND YET WE HAVE ALLOWED CITIES
INCLUDING MY OWN TO OBEY THE LAW --
I WANTED HIM TO IN TERMS OF THE
EPA'S COMMENT THAT WHILE GOD
THEIR CHANGES EVERY SINGLE YEAR
WEATHER CHANGES EVERY YEAR
BECAUSE THIS IS TURNED INTO A
CAT AND MOUSE GAME.
WERE IN THE LEGISLATURE SAYS YOU
HAVE TO ALLOW EIGHTY USE AND
THEN NOT ALL BUT A LOT OF CITIES
FIND WAYS TO MAKE IT TOO
EXPENSIVE OR IMPOSSIBLE TO
ACTUALLY PUT THE VIEWS AND SEVEN
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE HERE CENTER
SKINNER CENTER TANGER CENTER OR
SOMETHING THEM BLOOM -- HAS TO
LIKE STEP IN WITH TO PASS
ANOTHER LAW TO CLUES CLOSE MORE
LOOPHOLES AND THEN THERE'S
ANOTHER LOOPHOLE SO THAT'S THE
REASON IT'S DOCTOR GRATUITOUSLY
WHICH IS DECIDING TO PASS NEW
LAWS FOR EIGHTY USE EVERY YEAR.
IT'S BECAUSE WE'RE SERIOUS WHEN
WE SAY THAT YOU HAVE TO LET YOU
USE -- GO IN -- AND UNTIL THIS
CAT AND MOUSE GAME ENDS THERE
ARE GOING TO BE MORE -- LAWS AND
THE IMPACT THE SOME SENSITIVE TO
THE NEEDS OF THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO RELY ON IMPACT FEES -- BUT
WHEN WE HEARD ABOUT THESE SOME
OF THESE FIFTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR OR MORE
IMPACT FEES BEING PUT ON EIGHTY
YOU -- IT'S IT'S JUST NOT IT'S
NOT REASONABLE AND SO
UNFORTUNATELY A COP.
IS I THINK REQUIRED -- AND AND
SO ON I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
FOR A BRING IT FORWARD -- AND IF
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS --
AND WE HAVE A MOTION WILL CALL
THE ROLL -- I'M SORRY.
THE ONLY PLEASE CLOSE THE
STRUCTURE ALL USER COMMENTS OKAY.
THANK YOU. FIVE THAT DUMB.
THE SENATE BILL THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR WITH CASKEY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE
REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE SENATOR
WIENER.
YES AS FIVE WIENER HI MORRELL.
BATES.
BATES I COVER.
COVER I DRAWS -- MCGUIRE MORLOCK
MORE LIKE I ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
I NUMBER.
NUMBER FIVE A CASKEY.
CASSIE I IT HAS ENOUGH BOTH
SPOKE OF THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER.
OKAY -- WILL NOW GO TO CENTER
SKINNER -- ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
.
EIGHTEEN THANKS SO MUCH MISTER
TURN MEMBERS SB EIGHTEEN THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILLS TO
RECOGNIZE THAT.
IN THIS HOUSING CRISIS THE
CALIFORNIA HAS WITH HOUSING
COSTS SKYROCKETING AND
UNFORTUNATELY WELL WE'VE
INCREASE THE MINIMUM WAGE --
WAGES HAVE MORE OR LESS STAYED
STAGNANT -- YOU'VE GOT MANY MANY
MORE PEOPLE WHO ARE.
REALLY COMPROMISED WHEN IT COMES
TO TRYING TO MEET THEIR RENT.
AND ARE JUST A FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLAR UNEXPECTED EXPENSE AWAY
FROM HOMELESSNESS.
HOMELESS POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA ROSE BY 16% FROM.
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE ON OUR IN OUR MANY
OF ARCHIMEDES DO THESE REAL TIME
COUNTS AND COLLECT A LOT OF DATA
AROUND ARE HOMELESS.
IN THAT.
THAT INCREASE THE MAJORITY OF
THEM.
WERE NEWLY HOMELESS NEVER BEEN
HOMES BEFORE.
HAD JOBS.
AND MANY OF THEM HAVE JOBS NOT
HAD HALF HAVE JOBS.
AND MANY OF THEM HAVE CHILDREN.
SO THESE ARE NOT PEOPLE WHO ARE
MENTALLY ILL OR ADDICTED THESE
ARE PEOPLE THAT JUST.
FROM.
BECAUSE THEY WERE PAYING MORE
THAN 50% POTENTIALLY.
OF THEIR INCOME ON RENT.
FACE TO DIFFICULTY MANY OF THEM
WERE NOT EVEN AFFECTED STATE
LEFT THEIR PLACE BEFORE BEING
AFFECTED.
BECAUSE TO HAVE AN EVICTION ON
YOUR RECORD ALMOST MAKES IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR YOU TO RENT AGAIN.
SO USE MANY TENANTS WILL LEAVE.
BEFORE THEIR AFFECTED AS SOON AS
THEY'RE ENOUGH LATE IN THEIR
RENT ENOUGH MONTHS.
SO WHAT SB EIGHTEEN WILL DO IS
INCREASE [inaudible]
CALIFORNIA'S FIND WE HAVE AN
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE FUND
NOW.
SO IF WE ARE SUCCESSFUL OWN
APPROPRIATION WILL INCREASE THAT
FUND SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE.
MORE EMERGENCY OR RATHER WE CAN
PROVIDE EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE TO MORE TENANTS.
THIS IS PREVENTATIVE MEDICINE TO
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS AND
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD INCREASE
THE LEGAL FUNDS THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE SOME LEGAL
ASSISTANCE.
BECAUSE IN SOME CASES THE
TENANTS DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR
RIGHTS ARE AND WE CAN AVOID WE
CAN KEEP THEM IN THEIR HOME JUST
WITH SOME LEVEL OF LEGAL
ASSISTANCE.
BUT MY PRIORITY FOCUSES ON THE
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
AND ADDITIONALLY IT HAS SOME
OTHER COMPONENTS BUT I WILL
ALLOW MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO
SPEAK WE HAVE KEREN ERICKSON
FROM CATHOLIC CHARITIES WHO IS
PART OF A PROGRAM IN MY DISTRICT
THAT IS RUNNING.
AN EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM AND ALSO ALEXANDER
HARDEN FROM THE WESTERN CENTER
LAN PARTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- FOR HAVING
ME COME AND SPEAK AND I'M I'M.
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL OF
SENATOR SCANNERS -- I WORK FOR
CATHOLIC CHARITIES AT THE EAST
BAY AND WE'VE BEEN PART OF A
PARTNERSHIP FOR THE LAST SIX
MONTHS CALLED KEEP OAKLAND
HOUSED.
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN US BAY AREA
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND EAST BAY
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER.
AND OUR PURPOSE IS HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION.
SO THERE'S SO MANY AND AND YOU
CAN SPEND ALL AFTERNOON HEARING
ABOUT.
INTERVENTIONS IN HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS -- AND WE JUST WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT PREVENTION
IS ANOTHER PIECE THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO FIND -- PREVENTION
IS THE LEAST COSTLY AND THE MOST
HUMANE.
SO BASICALLY IT'S AN ENABLES US
TO USE CASE MANAGEMENT EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE AND LEGAL
ASSISTANCE TO KEEP PEOPLE IN
THEIR HOUSING.
SO NOT ONLY ARE PEOPLE AND
FAMILIES NOT BECOMING HOMELESS
WE'RE NOT LOSING THE UNITS.
ISN'T WHICH IS A REALLY HUGE --
PROBLEM BECAUSE THEN WHERE ARE
YOU GOING TO GO -- IN THE SIX
MONTHS THAT WE'VE BEEN.
OPERATING WE'VE SERVED OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE
HOUSEHOLDS WITH AN AVERAGE OF
LESS THAN THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
A MONTH -- AND THAT JUST SHOWS
HOW -- AFFECTED IT CAN BE IN
TERMS OF IN COMPARISON -- TO IF
YOU WERE TRYING TO BUILD.
THAT MUCH HOUSING -- ACTUALLY
FOR THE SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
HOUSEHOLDS -- YOU WOULD ONLY BE
ABLE TO BUILD A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY UNITS.
SO IT'S ABOUT FIVE TIMES AS
EFFECTIVE -- WE JUST REALLY
BELIEVE IN AND GETTING GETTING
UPSTREAM WITH THIS PROBLEM NOT
NOT REPLACING BUILDING HOUSING
BUT ADDING TO WHAT I COLOR TOOL
BOX SO THAT WE HAVE A LOT MORE
TOOLS.
IN OUR HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING TERM MEMBERS I'M
ALEXANDER HER NAME WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY PLEASED TO BE HERE TO
SUPPORT SB -- EIGHTEEN THIS BILL
CONTAINS A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT
INTERVENTIONS TO PROVIDE
STABILITY TO STRUGGLING RENTERS
AND A TIME OF UNPRECEDENTEDHOUSING COSTS -- THE FIRST OF
THE BILL EXTENDS IMPORTANT
PROTECTIONS FOR TENANTS LIVING
IN FOR CLOSE PROPERTIES WHICH
WILL OTHERWISE EXPIRE THIS YEAR --
AND WHICH SHIELD INNOCENT
TENANTS FROM ARBITRARY
AFFECTIONS AFTER FORECLOSURE --
WELL.
NOT AFFECTING EVICTIONS BASED ON
TENANT FAULT FOR REASONS SUCH AS
NON PAYMENT OF RENT OR VIOLATION
OF THE LEASE -- IN ADDITION THE
BILL PROVIDES NEEDED.
RENTAL ASSISTANCE EDUCATION AND
LEGAL SERVICES FOR TENANTS AT
RISK OF DISPLACEMENT.
ACROSS THE STATE WE KNOW OVER
HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S TENANTS ARE
RENT BURDEN -- WITH ALMOST ONE
THIRD LIVING WITH EXTREME RENT
BIRD AND MEANING THEY'RE PAYING
OVER HALF OF THEIR INCOME JUST
FOR HOUSING -- AS WE WORK TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF RISING
RENTS AND HOUSING SUPPLY.
NEAR TERM INTERVENTIONS LIKE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND LEGAL
RESOURCES ARE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL TO MAKING SURE THAT
TENANTS AT RISK OF DISPLACEMENT
AREN'T FORCED.
PREDICTABLY INTO HOMELESSNESS
AND WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S A SIMPLE COMMON.
CASEY LAID ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF OAKLAND SANTA ANA
BERKELEY IN EMERYVILLE ARE
STRONG SUPPORTERS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU FOR SPEAKER.
ROSS BUT THE ON BEHALF OF THE
BIG CITY MAYORS COLLECTION
SUPPORT.
SAYS THE MATTER NOT LIKE HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALFOF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY EAST BAY
SILICON VALLEY AN AFFILIATE OF
HABITAT CALIFORNIANS PARK.
WE'RE TOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
IN A ROW WITH EAST BAY FOR
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT.
FEDERAL GULF ON BEHALF OF THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
LOUIS MONDAY WITH CALIFORNIAN BE
IN SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
IRAN TO RUN THE ENTIRE TIME.
THE BILL TODAY SANDY GEORGE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
OKAY SEE NINE OPPOSITION.
TONY BE WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
PERMANENT SOLUTION WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
BUT WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE SENATOR.
AND THE CENTERS OFFICE AND WE
FEELCONFIDENT THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO REMOVE OPPOSITION SOON.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIS OPPOSITION.
A GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF CREAM THREE CM BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IS INTRODUCED WE DID
HAVE AN OPPOSING WAS AMENDED
POSITION ON SB -- EIGHTEEN BUT
WITH THE MARCH TWENTY FIFTH THE
MOMENTS WE HAVE MOVED TO A
NEUTRAL POSITION SO JUST ANT TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO THANK
THE AUTHOR.
AND HER STAFF -- FOR WORKING TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS WE GREATLY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
CASEY NONE WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND TO MOVE BY
CENTER OFF A CENTER WHAT CAL SKI.
SO I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND ON
THE THE SUNSET PROVISION IN
NINETY DAYS.
FORECLOSURE SAID NINETY DAY
PERIOD WHEN IS THE NOTICE OF
WHEN DO YOU WHEN HAS TO NOTICE
BEEN DONE IN THE PROGRAM IS IT
ON DAY.
ONE OR DAY.
NINETY WHEN THAT WHEN THAT LAND
WHEN THE OWNER OF THE HOME GIVES
NOTICE TO THE TENANTS THEY JUST
NEED TO GIVE A NINETY DAY.
AFFECTION NOTICE IT SO.
IF YOU ARE EVICTING AS A RESULT
OF FORECLOSURE.
YOU NEED TO GIVE THE TENANT
NINETY DAYS NOTICE THAT WAS
UNDER THE THE ORIGINAL
FORECLOSURE BILLS WERE GONNA
JUST REMOVE THAT SUNSET SO THAT
CONTINUES.
BUT ON THE PROBLEM -- THERE WAS
CONCERN.
EXPRESSED THAT.
THE WHAT IF THE TENANT JUST
DECIDES TO GET A NINETY DAY
NOTICE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
AFFECTED IN NINETY DAYS SO THEY
JUST STOP PAYING RENT.
IF THEY JUST STOP PAYING RENT
THE LANDLORD CAN PROVIDE A THREE
DAY NOTICE THE EVICTION PROCESS
CAN START IF THE TENANT HAS NOT
PAID RENT.
RIGHT SO THE NOTICING OF NINETY
DAYS DOES NOT ABSOLVE THE TENANT
OF THE RENT OBLIGATION.
I GUESS MY QUESTION IS BECAUSE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS --
EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS IN THE THE
CATHOLICS ALWAYS WANT TO HELP
OUT WHENEVER THEY CAN -- THE THE
AND THEN FORECLOSURE PROCESS YOU
KNOW THE LANDLORD OR THE
HOMEOWNER HASN'T PAID THE
MORTGAGE HAS FAULTED UNDERGO THE
I'M WONDERING IF THEY'VE
DEFAULTED THEY GET THE NOTICE
FROM THE BANK.
IS THE IS THE POINT OF IS THE
DESIRE THAT OKAY YEAR IN NINETY
DAYS IF NINETY DAYS YOU THE LAND
OR THE HOMEOWNER HAVE NINETY
DAYS TO CURE IF YOU GIVE NOTICE
TO THE TEN AND THAT I'M UNDER
FORECLOSURE HAS BEEN COMPLETED
YET.
BUT IT'S GOING DOES DO YOU
ANTICIPATE YOUR PROGRAM THE
EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS THE COME AND
SAY -- WITH THIS PERSON COULD
LOSE THE HOUSE WE'LL QUEUE --
THE DEFAULT IN THE TEN IT
CONTINUES TO PAY OR THIS IS IT'S
FOR CLOSE THE SALE HAS OCCURRED
AND TENANTS JUST THERE IS.
THERE IS NOTHING IN THE BILL
THAT WOULD PROVIDE THE HOMEOWNER.
ANY MONEY TO AVOID THEIR FOR
CLOSURE THAT MAY BE A LEGITIMATE
POLICY CONSIDERATION BUT THAT IS
NOT IN THIS BILL.
THIS BILL THAT [inaudible]
PORTION OF REMOVING THE SUNSET
FOR THE NINETY DAY NOTICE.
REGARDING AFFECTION UNDER
FORECLOSURE IS A SEPARATE
PROVISION OF THE BILL.
AND THEN THERE IS THE DISTINCT
PROVISION FOR EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE BUT EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE WOULD NOT BE PROVIDED
TO THE MORTGAGE HOLDER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
YES CENTER CABALLERO.
LIKE I JUST HAVE A QUESTION IN
REGARDS TO THE FINDS IT WOULD
COME FROM THIS C. S. H..
AND THE IT LOOKS LIKE THE
RECOMMENDATION IS THEY GO TO THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE.
AND I'VE I'VE HAD SOME CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED IN MY
COUNTIES AROUND -- THE LACK OF
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY IN SOME OF THE SOME
OF THE COMMUNITY OF KERR'S SO I
JUST WANT TO RAISE THAT IS AN
ISSUE BECAUSE WE ALSO TOOK THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE HOMELESS MONEY.
AND AND I'M I'M VERY CONCERNED
WITH THIS ACTUALLY SETTING GOALS
SO THAT WE HAVE A WAY TO KNOW
WHETHER THE MONEY IS REALLY
GOING TO WHAT WE WANTED TO GO TO
SO I I RAISE THAT I I AM GOING
TO BE TALKING ABOUT THAT MORE IN
THE FUTURE.
BECAUSE I'M I'M REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT IT.
BUDGET AMID CONCERN WHAT WE DID
SO FAR IN THE BILL WAS RECOGNIZE
THAT EACH CD DOES HAVE AN
EXISTING.
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM.
WHICH WAS AUGMENTED.
LAST YEAR WITH THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION SO WE MADE A CONSISTENT
BUT WE DO SHARE A CONCERN ABOUT
WHETHER IT SHOULD BE BROADER
THAN JUST THE CONTINUINGCARE
AND AS WE MOVE THE BILL THROUGH.
WE WILL BE LOOKING AT THAT.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
OKAY SING NOW WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR ROTH AND THE
AND I AM RECOMMENDING AND AYE
VOTES.
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
CLOSE [inaudible] FOR CALDERON.
THIS IS SENATE BILL EIGHTEEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY SENATOR
WIENER AYE.
WIENER AYE MORRELL [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
CAMARO.
CAMARO I DRAWS -- MCGUIRE.
MORE LUCK.
ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE
AMBERG.
NUMBER I CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE.
OKAY THAT IS SIX BOTH WHICH IS
ENOUGH BUT WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WILL NOW
GO TO OUR SECOND THE LAST ITEM --
ITEM -- THIRTEEN BUT SB SEVEN
FORTY FOUR BY CENTER CABALLERO
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AS WE ALL KNOW WHEN
WE'VE HEARD IT VER AND OVER
TODAY CALIFORNIA FACES A DOUBLE
CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS AND A
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SO THE RESULTING BURDEN FALLS
PARTICULARLY HARD ON PEOPLE
LIVING WITH MENTAL ILLNESS.
NEARLY A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
ARE HOMELESS ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT
AND ABOUT A THIRD OF THOSE ARE
ESTIMATED TO BE LIVING WITH A
MENTAL ILLNESS.
IN MONTEREY COUNTY ARE BY ANY
ACCOUNT FOUND HOMELESSNESS GREW
23% BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
HIGHEST LEVEL IN TEN YEARS.
WE KNOW THE PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS
HEALTH CONDITIONS SUCH AS MENTAL
ILLNESS LIVING ON SHELTERED OR
CYCLING IN AND OUT OF HOSPITALS
IN AN INCARCERATION IS COSTLY TO
THE PUBLIC.
AND RESULT IN NEEDLESS SUFFERING
RESEARCHING COMMON SENSE TELLS
US THAT PROVIDING HOUSING WITH
SUPPORT SERVICES IS AFFECTED IN
AND ENDING HOMELESSNESS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT LAST FALL
VOTERS OVERWHELMINGLY APPROVED
PROPOSITION TWO THE NO PLACE
LIKE HOME INITIATIVE WHICH
AUTHORIZED THE STATE TO ISSUE
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN BONDS TO
CREATE TWENTY THOUSAND UNITS A
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
FOR HOMELESS MENTALLY ILL
INDIVIDUALS.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT SUCH HOUSING
KEEP PEOPLE INSIDE REDUCES
ILLNESS AND SUFFERING AND LOWERS
PUBLIC COSTS.
SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR HELPS
FULFILL THE INTENT OF THE VOTERS
BY CLARIFYING AND STREAMLINING
THE LOCAL APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND
ASSOCIATED SERVICES LIKE THOSE
THAT NO PLACE LIKE HOME BONDS
ARE FUNDING.
SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR UTILIZES A
STREAMLINING APPROVAL PROCESS
FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING PROJECT
ENVISIONED IN LAST YEAR'S.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO AND
APPLIES THIS PROCESS TO THE
PROPOSITION TWO NO PLACE LIKE
HOME SUPPORT OF HOUSING THE BILL
EXPANDS THE DEFINITION OF THE
SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND INCLUDES
A BY ITS USE BY RIGHT IN STONE
FOR MULTI FAMILY AND MIXED USE
ARE PERMITTED.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL PROVIDES
THAT APPROVAL OF A PROJECT
SUBJECT TO STREAMLINE REVIEW
SHALL NON NOT CONSTITUTE A
PROJECT FOR PURPOSES OF SEAQUEST
NOR DOES THE DECISION BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. TO SEEK NO PLACE
LIKE HOME FUNDS -- ALSO A BET
SUBJECT IT TO SEE WHAT.
FINALLY ANY SECRET CHALLENGE
SHALL BE RESOLVED BY A COURT OF
COMPETENT JURISDICTION WITHIN
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DAYS.
THUS EXPEDITING THE PROCESS
CALIFORNIA VOTERS MADE IT CLEAR
THEY WANT PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOMELESS AND HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS TO BE SHELTERED AND
CARE.
FOR OPPOSITION TO GOT MORE VOTES
THAN ANY OTHER MEASURE ON THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT AND I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BELIEVE ME IN THE SENATORS --
ADRIN SULTAN WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE WE ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR SENATE BILL -- SEVEN
FOUR FOUR CALIFORNIA DOES FACE
AN IMMENSE HOUSING AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS.
AND WITH UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
LIVING ON OUR STREET ANY GIVEN
NIGHT A THIRD OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
MORE HAS TO BE DONE.
AND SENATE BILL SEVEN FOUR FOUR
WILL STREAMLINE THE STUDY
PROCESS FOR THE TWENTY THOUSAND
UNITS THAT WAS PROMISED BY NO
PLACE LIKE HOME.
IT'S TIME TO TAKE ON
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESSNESS YOU
AND BREAK THE CYCLE OF CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS AND SB SEVEN FOUR
FOUR PROVIDES ARE HOMELESS
LIVING WITH A MENTAL ILLNESS
WITH THE PLAN.
AND FUNDING TO EXIT FROM THE
STREETS THAT WE BELIEVE THIS IS
A HUMANE AND EFFECTIVE SOLUTION
TO ENDING HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND SB SEVEN FOUR FOUR POINTS
ARE HOMELESS TOWARD A PATHWAY OF
RECOVERY AND WELL BEING LAST
YEAR I VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
CHRIS PUT YOUR THOMAS LAW GROUP
I'M HERE IF THE COMMITTEE AS ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OF PUBLIC
COMMENT.
DELTA DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIAN WERE SUPPORT -- AS
YOU KNOW -- HAS BEEN REPEATED
THROUGHOUT THE DAY TODAY THAT WE
ARE.
IN THE MIDST OF AN EXTRAORDINARY
HOUSING CRISIS AND NO ONE REALLY
OF IS IMPACTED BY THAT AS MUCH
AS THE PERSONS WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS.
SO AS YOU'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE FROM US MANY TIMES -- THAT
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
WHO ARE LEFT ON THE STREETS --
OFTEN ARE SUBJECT TO MORE
RESTRICTIVE -- OPTIONS THAT ARE
MADE BY -- LOCAL GOVERNMENT SO
WE THINK THIS IS -- AN IMPORTANT
TO MEASURE TO GET THE DOLLARS
OUT -- AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE --
ONE OTHER PIECE THAT WE WOULD
KNOW IT -- AS ARE A FRIENDS IN
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE DO --
HAVE CONCERNS WHEN THERE ARE
CALENDAR PREFERENCES -- FOR
SYKORA -- BECAUSE THAT THEN
MOVES OTHERS TO THE FRONT OF THE
LINE IN IN LITIGATION AND THOSE
OF US THAT HAVE DIFFERENT CASES
IN LITIGATION WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE CASES CAN MOVE AS
QUICKLY AS OTHERS THANK YOU.
TWENTY BILLION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT SORRY FOR THE LATE
SUPPORT LETTER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
SEE NOT OPPOSITION [inaudible]
FOR GOOD EVENING TURN MEMBERS
TEN PLAN FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL.
THE DISTRICT COUNCILS OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BUT ONLY THE EXPEDITED
JUDICIAL REVIEW PROVISIONS --
THAT WERE JUST REFERENCED IF THE
PROVISION WERE REMOVED FROM THE
BILL THE COUNCIL WOULD READ
WITHDRAW ITS OPPOSITION IS ALL
OF THE REMAINING ISSUES IN THE
BILL.
OR OUTSIDE THE COUNCIL'S PURVIEW
JUST AS A PRELIMINARY MATTER.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHY THE EXPEDITED
JUDICIAL REVIEW PROVISION IS
STILL INCLUDED IN THE MEASURE
SINCE THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE
BILL AS THE AUTHOR INDICATED.
MAKE SUCH PROJECTS USED BY RIGHT
AN EXEMPT FROM SEA QUEST SO
WE'RE JUST.
KIND OF PUZZLED OF WHY YOU WOULD
NEED TO MAINTAIN THE EXTRA
JUDICIAL REVIEW PROVISIONS IN
LIGHT OF THE LATEST AMENDMENTS.
THAT BEING SAID AS WITH THE
OTHER PENDING BILLS THAT CONTAIN
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW
REQUIREMENTS.
THE COUNCIL'S OPPOSITION IS
LIMITED TO THE COURT IMPACTS OF
SUCH LEGISLATION AND IT
SIGNIFICANT INTERFERENCE WITH
THE COURTS FUNDAMENTAL DUTY TO
BRIGHT X. EQUAL ACCESS TO
JUSTICE.
IN ALL OTHER CASES ON THE
COURT'S DOCKET SO THESE OLDER
CALENDAR PREFERENCES HAVE THE
PRACTICAL EFFECT OF PUSHING ALL
OTHER CASES ON THE COURT'S
DOCKETS TO THE BACK OF THE LINE.
EVEN CASES THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
HAS ALREADY PRIORITIZED --
ESSENTIALLY THE THIS TYPE
APPROACH PICKS WINNERS AND
LOSERS EVEN AMONG CASES
INVOLVING HOUSING RIGHTS THAT
FALL WITHIN THIS COMMITTEE'S
JURISDICTION.
JUST A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES.
IF A HOMEOWNER BILL OF RIGHTS
ACTION FOR IMPROPER FOR CLOSURE
IS BROUGHT OR AN INSURANCE BAD
FAITH CASE.
OR OTHER CLAIMS BROUGHT BY
HOMEOWNERS WHO LOST THEIR HOMES
IN THE RECENT DEVASTATING FIRES.
IN SANTA ROSA -- THE MUD SLIDES
IN SANTA BARBARA THOSE CASES
WILL TAKE LONGER TO DECIDE IF A
HOUSING DISCRIMINATION OR EIGHTY
A LAWSUIT IS BROUGHT BY PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL AND OTHER
DISABILITIES IN FACT THERE'S A
ARTICLE IN TODAY'S LA TIMES
ABOUT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
URBAN DEVELOPMENT GOING AFTER LA
FOR NOT INSURING THAT THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS.
IN LA ARE NOT DISCRIMINATING
UNLAWFULLY AGAINST PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES SO EVEN IF THOSE
KINDS OF LITIGATION WERE BROUGHT
THOSE AGAIN MOVED TO THE BACK OF
THE LINE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ULTRA CALENDAR PREFERENCE.
JUST A COUPLE OF NON HOUSING
RELATED CASES. FOR EXAMPLE A
PERSONAL INJURY ACTION INVOLVING
A SEVERELY BRAIN DAMAGED CHILD
THOSE DO NOT GET THE SUPER X..
WE DO ELDER ABUSE LITIGATION
INVOLVING DYING PLAINTIFFS CIVIL
ACTIONS INVOLVING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WAGE THEFT.
THESE AND OTHER IMPORTANT CASES
ON THE COURT DOCKETS WILL ALL
TAKE LONGER. TO DECIDE SYNDICATE
EARLIER WERE NOT JUST CLEAR AT
ALL AND WHY YOU NEED TO MAINTAIN
THIS EXTRA JUDICIAL REVIEW IN
THE FACE OF THE USE BY RIGHT.
AND SECRET EXEMPTION.
FINALLY THE THE ASSUMPTION THAT
UNDERLIES THE EXTRA.
JUDICIAL REVIEW AS WE UNDERSTAND
IT IS THAT THE DEVELOPERS AND
FIND ANSWERS INDICATE THATTHEY
NEED THE CERTAINTY THAT WOULD
COME WITH A THE QUICK TURNAROUND
TIME THAT HAS BEEN IMPOSED ON
THE COURTS.
WE'RE HERE TO TELL YOU THAT IN
THE REAL WORLD THAT DOES THAT
CERTAINTY DOES NOT EXIST IN THE
TWO CASES THAT BEEN LITIGATED TO
DATE UNDER A. B..
NINE HUNDRED THEY WERE BOTH SEE
QUIRK AND NON SEQUEL CAUSES OF
ACTION LAWSUITS FILED FOR THE
SEQUEL COULD.
LITIGATION PERVERSELY GOES ON
THE SUPER ACCELERATED TRACK BUT
THE NON SEQUEL CAUSES OF ACTION
ANOTHER LAWSUIT PROCEED NORMALLY.
IN FACT THE MOST RECENT CASE
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY SUNSET
BOULEVARD PROJECT IN LA HAD FOUR
SEPARATE LAWSUITS.
FILED BY FOUR SEPARATE GROUPS
THE PLAINEST NOT COORDINATED IN
ANY FASHION.
THEY HAD SECRET AND NON SEQUEL
CAUSES OF ACTION THE SEQUEL
LITIGATION WAS ALL CONSOLIDATED
MOVED ON A FAST TRACK.
THE BAR FOR CATERED OFF THE NON
SEQUEL CAUSES OF ACTION IN EVEN
AFTER ALL OF THE SEQUEL
LITIGATION PATHWAY WAS CLEARED.
THE REMAINING LITIGATION IS
STILL PENDING IN THE LA SUPERIOR
COURT AND THE LOCAL PLANNING
COMMISSION HISTORICAL COMMISSION
HAS NOT SIGNED OFF.
ON THE PROPOSED DEMOLITION OF
THIS BEAUTIFUL MID CENTURY BNK
BUILDING THAT HAPPENS TO BE ON
THE SITE.
THAT IS PROPOSED FOR THIS
PROJECT SO THAT THE CERTAINTY WE
WOULD SUBMIT RESPECTFULLY.
THAT UNDERLIES THE WHOLE
ASSUMPTION FOR THESE EXTRA
JUDICIAL YOU SIMPLY DOES NOT
EXIST IN THE REAL WORLD. FOR
THOSE CASES THAT GET SUED WHEN
THEY'RE IT'S REALLY CONTENT TO
LITIGATION AND PEOPLE ARE WELL
RESOURCE IN ORDER TO DO THAT
THEY WILL.
BRING ALL CAUSES OF ACTION
SEQUEL AND NON SEQUEL.
AND THAT WE RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT
THAT THAT JUST AS FUNDAMENTALLY
AT ODDS WITH OUR COURT SYSTEM IS
SUPPOSED TO OPERATE IN ITS FOR
THOSE REASONS THAT WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION AND AGAIN.
IF THAT PROVISION WILL REMOVED
WE WOULD WITHDRAW OUR OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
BRENNAN DAWSON I'LL BE OF THE
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA WE WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS IS A
REALLY TO SEE COLLUDED CATION TO
WITH OF JUDICIAL COUNCIL --
ADDITIONALLY WE WANT TO ADD THAT --
MOST OF THE HOUSING PROJECTS AS
RELATES TO DISABILITY CATION --
ACTUALLY ONLY NEED -- HI THERE I
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORTS OR
NAKED NECK DACHSHUNDS A NEGATIVE --
DECORATIONS THEREFORE THEY DON'T
REALLY HAVE TO GO TO THE C.
COLOURATION PROCESS -- BUT EVEN
THEN WE WOULD ACTUALLY ASKED
THAT THE AUTHOR REMOVED THE
SECRET EXEMPTION ALTOGETHER --
PORTING THE SICKLE PROCESS IN
OUR VIEW -- SEVERELY LIMITS A
COMMUNITY'S ABILITY TO ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCESS OF
WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR COMMUNITY
AS IT RELATES TO HOW MUCH
POLLUTION EVERYTHING THAT COULD
BE -- HOW THAT COULD HAPPEN --
WHEN CONSTRUCTION OCCURS AND SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE OPPOSE
THANK YOU CARD FOR LONDON AND
DID YOU SAY THAT THE I. R. AS IN
NEGATIVE DECLARATIONS DON'T HAVE
TO GO TO THE C. COMPRESSIBLE
MANY BOOKS SO BECAUSE BECAUSE
MANY?
BECAUSE MANY -- HOUSING PROJECTS
ONLY HAVE TO DO YEAH I OURS OR
NAY THEY HAVE NEGATIVE
DECORATIONS THE ACTUALLY JUST
REVIEW IS UNNECESSARY BECAUSE
THOSE POSIT JONES PRODUCTS.
ARE PROJECTS SORRY THOSE
PRODUCTS USUALLY DON'T TAKE AS
LONG AS IT WOULD TAKE TO GO TO
THE COURT SYSTEM.
BIGGER BIGGER THROUGH THE AUTO
OKAY THANK YOU I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
FOR THANKS BIGGER.
AARON RIGHT BURKE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION ALIGNING OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND AGAIN IF THE
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW WERE
TAKEN OUT OF THE BUILDING WE
WOULD HAVE NO.
POSITION ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
IT WILL BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
HOW CAN I SUCCESS OPPONENTS TO
RESPOND TO THE ISSUE OF WHY THE
ACCIDENT A REVIEW IS AN AND THE
BILL.
NUMBER PATELLAR CODE.
SURE THANK YOU -- I'M A FIRST I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE LANGUAGE IN
PUBLIC RESOURCE CODE TWO ONE ONE
SIX THREE POINT FIVE AS PROPOSED
WOULD SAY TO THE EXTENT FEASIBLE
IT'S NOT A MANDATE ON THE COURT
IT'S A IT'S AN ENCOURAGEMENT
THAT THEY DO IT IF IT IS
POSSIBLE.
I THINK THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION -- SECONDLY THAT AS
I'M SURE ALL OF YOU ARE AWARE
THERE ARE MULTIPLE OR NUMEROUS
LAWSUITS EVERY YEAR AGAINST
EXEMPTIONS.
SO HAVING EX BUT I REVIEW FOR
PROJECT IS EXEMPT FROM SEQUEL IS
STILL HELPFUL TO GET IT THROUGH
THE LITIGATION PROCESS.
IN ADDITION NOT ALL --
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PROJECTS.
ARE COVERED BY THE BY RIGHT
PROVISIONS IF IT WAS.
REQUIRED TO REZONE TO ALLOW FOR
HOUSING FOR EXAMPLE WHICH THERE
ARE SOME JURISDICTIONS A MAY BE
INCLINED TO DO THAT PROJECT MAY
VERY WELL STILL REQUIRE ANY AYE
ARE.
AND COULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
STREAMLINED LITIGATION PROCESS --
IN ADDITION I WAS ONE OF THE
COUNCILS AND THE WORKERS ARENA
CASE AND WHILE THEY WERE ABLE TO
GET DOWN INTO AND SEVEN DAYS
THEY WERE VERY CLOSE SO I CAN
SAY FROM MY EXPERIENCE.
IT WAS AN EFFECTIVE PROCESS.
FINN ROTH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WILL MAKE
THIS VERY LONG BUT I JUST HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL I MEAN CERTAINLY THE
CODE OF CIVIL PROCEDURE ALLOWS.
IN FACT REQUIRES SOME.
PRIORITY IN TERMS OF LITIGATION
DOES IT NOT IT IT DOES IN FACT
SEQUEL CASES ARE ALREADY
ENTITLED O'FALLON BUT FRIENDS
BUT NOT FORGET SINGLE TO RICK
CELEBRATED FORGET SEQUEL
[inaudible]
WHAT ELSE?
AND UNLAWFUL DETAINER.
OLD PEOPLE WHO ELSE KATE CASES
WHERE PEOPLE AS YOU INDICATED
AND IN DANGER OF OF DYING
CERTAIN ELECTION MATTERS THAT
AFFECT STATEWIDE ELECTIONS THAT
KIND OF THING SO SO OVERSEE SORT
OF TIRED WITH THE LENGTH OF TIME
THAT IT TAKES FOR THIS PROCESS
TO OCCUR.
WE DON'T WANT TO MINIMIZE THE
PROCESS WE DON'T WANT TO CUT ANY
SHORT WE'VE GOT A COUPLE.
HAVE SHORT CUTS BUT WE WANT THE
STUFF DECIDED AND WE WANT IT
DECIDED QUICKLY.
AND SINCE WE FIND YOU.
WHAT IS IT EXACTLY THAT YOU
REQUIRE IN ORDER TO HAVE
EXPEDITED SEQUEL LITIGATION IF
YOU SAY YOU CAN'T DO IT AND IT'S
KIND OF FEAR INTERFERE WITH
OTHER CASES IN THE?
IN THE TWO CASES THAT BEEN
LITIGATED UNDER A. B..
NINE HUNDRED FROM THE FROM THE
INFORMATION THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE AVAILABLE THE THE TO THE
TWO ATTORNEYS IN THE WARRIORS
CASE RATHER THAN THE ONE
SUPPORTING THE JUDGE -- THEY
WERE ALL WORKING NIGHTS AND
WEEKENDS AND THE REST OF THE
CASES ON THEIR DOCKET.
GOT SHORT SHRIFT THEY HAD TO
WAIT LONGER IN ORDER TO BE
DECIDED.
IN THE IN THE LITIGATION DOWN
SOUTH.
SIMILAR THE THE JUDGE AND THE
SUPPORT STAFF THAT WAS REQUIRED
TO HANDLE THAT CASE WAS
EXTRAORDINARY IN NATURE AND THAT
MEANS THAT ALL THE OTHER CASES
ON THEIR DOCKET TOOK LONGER TO
DECIDE WELL COURSE THOSE ARE TWO
THAT SOUNDS LIKE THOSE ARE. TWO
ONE USUAL CASES CERTAINLY THE
WARRIOR CASES UNUSUAL AND THAT
DIDN'T ANSWER MY QUESTION WHAT
WOULD YOU IS A JUDICIAL COUNCIL
REQUIRE IF WE WANT TO IMPOSE.
SEQUENCE STREAMLINING WITH
REGARD TO LITIGATION.
CAN MORE JUDGES.
TWENTY WELL ANY MILLION DOLLARS.
THE DIFFICULTY WITH THAT IS THAT
AND I KNOW YOU KNOW BECAUSE YOU
YOU'VE BEEN A STRONG SUPPORTER
IN TERMS OF GETTING US
ADDITIONAL JUDGES.
I HAVE NOT HEARD FROM ANY OF OUR
JUDGES ARE THE SUPPORT STAFF
THAT WE NEED MORE SECRET JUDGES
ARE FUNDING SPECIFIC THE SEQUEL
BECAUSE THE WE DON'T CONTROL.
THAT DOCKET HOW OFTEN CASES GET
FILED HOW MANY AND HOW COMPLEX
THOSE CASES ARE WE CERTAINLY
COULD BENEFIT.
FROM HAVING MORE JUDICIAL
OFFICERS AS YOU KNOW AND HAVE
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF BUT
THERE'S NOT TO MAGIC NUMBER THAT
IF WE BECAUSE WE AGAIN WE HAVE
NO CONTROL OVER THE DOCKET WHICH
CASES GET FILED.
WELL I'M NOT GOING TO BELABOR
THIS TODAY BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE A SEPARATE CONVERSATION
WITH YOU ON THE SUBJECT BECAUSE
I FRANKLY BOTHERED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCILS POSITION IN
THIS CASE.
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE AND I'D
LIKE TO EXPLORE.
HOW WE CAN RESOLVE THAT IN THIS
AND OTHER CASES WHERE WE'RE
TRYING TO STREAMLINE THE SECRET
PROCESS THANK YOU MISTER?
CENTER LIKE HEALTHY.%
CAN WE TURN OUR ATTENTION TO
PAGE EIGHTEEN LINE TWENTY FIVE
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK MISTER
POND HAS HIT THE ENTIRE NAIL ON
THE HEAD.
BECAUSE HE'S TALKING ABOUT CASES
THAT WILL BE STREAMLINED FOR
SEQUEL BUT IT SAYS AFTER NO
PLACE LIKE HOME PROJECTS WITH
THE GRANTING OF ANY APPROVAL FOR
THAT PROJECT.
SO WAS I READ THAT NOT ONLY IS
IT IS SEEK WHAT CHALLENGE IT'S A
IT'S ANY.
POSSIBLE ACTION WOULD HAVE TO
GET THE TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
DAY SPA FAST TRACK FOR THE
SUPPORT OF HOUSING PROJECT.
THERE'S A NOR THERE OR THE
GRANTING OF ANY APPROVAL SO ANY
OF THE SUPPORT OF PROJECTS IN
ANY OF THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
AT ANY TIME.
ANY LAWSUIT FOR WHATEVER MATTER
THAT GOES FOR THE APPROVAL GETS
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DAY.
FASTRACK.
THAT'S HOW I READ THAT.
WHAT COULD YOU SAY THAT THE PAGE
IN THE LINE AGAIN AGE EIGHTEEN
LINE TWENTY FIVE WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT IT STARTS UP THE INCLUSION
THE RULES OF THE COURT TO BE
AMENDED FOR THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL?
SHALL APPLY TO ANY ACTION OR
PROCEEDING AND IT GOES REGARDING
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT FOR
THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME PROJECT
WHICH IS WHAT MR.
TONE IS TALKING ABOUT FOR THE
GRANTING OF ANY APPROVAL FOR
THAT PROJECT.
BUT EVERYTHING.
ANY LAWSUIT I MEAN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE WAR YEARS CITY STADIUM
ANOTHER PROJECT ON THERE THIS IS.
ANY LAWSUIT ON ANY THESE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES ON ANY SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING [inaudible]
THAT'S BIG.
AM I READING THIS WRONG.
THAT'S WHAT IT SAYS NO PLACE
LIKE HOME PROJECTS FOR THE
GRANTING OF ANY APPROVAL FOR
THAT PROJECT NOT FOR THAT SEEK
WHAT THAT PROJECT.
IN A PLACE LIKE HOME PROJECT.
WE GET TO TO ONE SEVENTY DAIS.
I GOT A BIG PROBLEM WITH THAT.
I MEAN IT THIS IS NOT JUST FAST
A CHALLENGE AND SEEK WITH THIS
IS ANY.
ANY WAS LAWSUIT.
THIS THIS THIS IS INTENDED AND
AND THE WAY I READ IT IT'S IT'S
IF YOUR USING NO PLACE LIKE HOME.
PROJECT FUNDS.
THAT -- HAT IS -- CONSISTENT.
WITH THE GRANT.
AND CONSISTENT WITH THE THE THE
WAY THAT -- IT EXPEDITED WHICH
IS THAT IT'S ALREADY BEEN SOWN
FOR APARTMENT IT'S ALREADY BEEN
SOWN IT FITS EVERYTHING IN THE
CITY.
THAT IT CAN'T BE IT CAN'T BE
DENIED BECAUSE IT'S IT'S A
PROJECT FOR THE MENTALLY ILL.
AND WAITED WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
IF YOU'RE GOING TO FILE A SEQUEL
LAWSUIT HE GETS A EXPEDITED NO
NO IT'S IT'S IT'S SAYING MORE
THAT IT'S SAYING YOU DON'T HAVE
TO FILE A SEQUEL LAWSUIT YOU CAN
FILE ANY LAWSUIT.
BECAUSE IT'S APPROVAL THAT YOU
DON'T.
FORGET SEQUEL.
FORGETS TO QUIT SAYING IF YOU GO
ONE OF THESE PROJECTS ARE
GETTING BETTER ARE EXEMPT HERE
IT'S IT'S IT'S FAST TRACK FOR
EVERYTHING YOUR PROBLEMS A
JUDICIAL COUNCIL JUST GOT
MULTIPLIED BY.
FIVE HUNDRED THAT'S THIS IS
NOTHING I MEAN THAT'S WHAT HOW
IT READS AS IT IS I GOT A
PROBLEM WITH THAT.
THE THE GOAL OF THE GOAL OF THE
LANGUAGE I BELIEVE WAS TO INSURE
THAT THESE PROJECTS DEVELOP
QUICKLY SO IF YOU AS WAS
MENTIONED IF IF SOMEONE COULD
pACTION HAVE A BIFURCATED INTO
SEVERAL CASES.
THAT DOESN'T ACHIEVE THE GOAL SO
IF IF THE GOAL IS TO GET THESE
IN A FAIRLY NARROW CLASS OF
PROJECTS THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
PROJECTS TO THE PROP TO FUNDING --
APPROVED AND THROUGH LITIGATION
QUICKLY AYE I DO THINK THAT
THERE'S VALUE IN MAKING SURE
THAT THE PROJECT THAT THE
LITIGATION ISN'T SEPARATED INTO.
MULTIPLE MATTERS AND THAT A
COURT DOES HERE ALL OF THAT ONCE
I I PERSONALLY DON'T BELIEVE
THAT IT WOULD TAKE THAT MUCH
LONGER TO DEAL WITH A SEEK A
LAWSUIT.
IN ADDITION TO OTHER CLAIMS AS
IS OFTEN DONE IN SECRET
LITIGATION.
YES SIR MY LOCK.
MICHELLE TO COULD YOU -- HELP ME
OUT HERE A LITTLE BIT JUST TAKE
IT INTO LAYMAN'S TERMS THE
COUNTY.
FILE SO GRANT. FOR THE NO PLACE
LIKE HOME FUNDING.
WITH THAT GRANT INCLUDE THE
SPECIFIC REAL ESTATE AND THE
PROJECT AND BE VERY CLEAR.
AND AND THEREFORE HOPEFULLY A
LOT OF THE APPROVAL.
PROCESS IS ALREADY BEEN.
TAKING CARE OF SO I'M I'M I'M
WONDERING.
IF THIS SEQUEL LAWSUIT COME OUT
OF NO WHERE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PROCESS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
[inaudible]
YES.
SO WE'RE ALL MOVING ALONG WITH
FOUND THE PROPERTY WERE. FOR
HAPPY WITH BUILDING A FACILITY
FOR MENTALLY ILL HOMELESS PEOPLE
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN.
A SERVICE FOR LAWSUIT SHOW UP.
AND YOU'RE SAYING.
SPEEDED UP GET IT DONE AND
THAT'S THAT'S THE GIST OF THIS
BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU I ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS OKAY --
MIGHT.
HA.
HA MY OUR RECOMMENDATION IS AN
ALLY ON THIS BILL -- YOU KNOW
WHATEVER THE ISSUES ARE WITH
EXPEDITED REVIEW.
PERHAPS YOU AND CENTER OFF CAN
FIGURE IT ALL OUT AND WE CAN FIX
IT -- BY I THINK IF WE'RE GOING
TO GRANT EXPEDITED SEQUEL
LAWSUITS TO SPORTS ARENAS WE
SHOULD RUN AT THE HOMELESS
PEOPLE.
TO AND I THINK WE HEAR THIS --
ACTUALLY ALIVE A LOT OF I THINK
VARIOUS AREAS MEMBERS TALKING
ABOUT THIS THAT WERE.
CONTINUALLY STREAMLINING SEQUEL --
FOR THESE MAJOR.
ARENA PROJECTS WHICH AND I'M
SUPPORTED -- THAT STREAMLINING --
BUT WHY CAN'T WE DO IT FOR
HOUSING.
TOO AND YOU KNOW WITHOUT GETTING
INTO THE GROUND THE BATES ABOUT
SEQUEL BECAUSE HE PUT THOSE SIR
MANY VALUABLE PURPOSES WE ALSO
KNOW THAT IT TO BE USED AROUND
INFILL HOUSING.
AND IS PARTICULARLY ABUSE IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO SLOW DOWN AND
STOP -- SUPPORTER PROJECTS FOR
HOMELESS PEOPLE IN FACT IN MY
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO RIGHT NOW
OR THE MAYOR IS TRYING TO PUT A
NAVIGATION CENTER AT THE
EMBARCADERO.
AND THEIR NEIGHBORS WHO THROUGH
GO FUND ME SIDE OF ALREADY RAISE
MONEY TO HIRE A LAWYER TO FILE A
CIVIL LAWSUIT AGAINST THAT WHEN
THERE IS NO ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
THAT I CAN POSSIBLY THINK OF SO
I'M A SUPPORTIVE AND I RECOMMEND
THAT I BUILT.
ON SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR I YOU KNOW THE
PROBLEM WITH WITH VIDEO
VIGNETTES IS IT EVERYBODY CAN
COME UP WITH ONE THAT THAT TOP
THAT REALLY EXPLAINS IT I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS ON IT
THAT THE ONE I'M VERY FAMILIAR
WITH IT AND FRANKLY -- IN
MONTEREY COUNTY AND THE CITY OF
SALINAS THERE HAS.
THERE THERE THERE IS THE THREAT
OF SEQUEL LITIGATION OR ITS
SEQUEL EDUCATION ON EVERY SINGLE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT AND
THE ONE THAT IS THE MOST RECENT
WAS A FARM WORKER PROJECT OUT IN
THAT COUNTY AND INCORPORATED
AREA OF SPRECKELS WHICH WAS AN
INDUSTRIAL SITE.
AND HAD HAS NOT BEEN UTILIZED.
FOR THIRTY YEARS AFTER SPRECKELS
CLOSE THE PLANT -- A LOCAL
COMPANY.
HAD PLANS TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR THEIR WORK FORCE THE
AT COMMUNITY OF SPARKLES DIDN'T
WANT FARMWORKERS LIVING WITHIN
PROXIMITY OF THEIR HOMES -- PUT
UP A HUGE CHALLENGE AND FRANKLY
SINCE THERE WERE NO PUBLIC FUNDS
IN THE PROJECT THEY WENT AHEAD
AND BUILT THE PROJECT WHILE THE
SECRET.
LITIGATION WAS PENDING AND ONCE
IT WAS RESOLVED TO THAT -- WELL
BASICALLY ONCE THAT HOUSING WAS
BUILT -- THE SEQUEL LITIGATION
WAS -- RESOLVED FOR PENNIES ON
THE DOLLAR BECAUSE IT REALLY HAD
NO MERIT AND AND IT WHEN IT WENT
AWAY SO IT SEEK WHAT IS USED
REPEATEDLY -- IN MANY
JURISDICTIONS AS A WAY TO
INTIMIDATE.
THE DEVELOPMENT OR FOR THE
PERSON THAT'S GOING TO BE DOING
THE DEVELOPMENT THE IN THIS CASE
IT WAS AN AGRICULTURAL COMPANY
AND THEY JUST THEY JUST WENT
WENT AHEAD AND DID IT.
AND HAT WAS BECAUSE THE JUDGE
ORDERED THAT -- THAT THERE WAS
COULD NOT GOING TO BE AN
INJUNCTION.
ON ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
PROJECT AND SO.
THERE MAY BE OTHER WAYS TO GET
THERE WHICH IN NO INJUNCTIONS
CAN BE GRANTED -- AND THAT YOU
CAN GO AHEAD AND BUILD IT.
TING A SEQUEL LAWSUIT BUT I I
AGREE WITH YOU IF WE'RE GONNA DO
SYKORA -- STREAMLINING FOR BIG
PROJECTS AND I THINK THE WORD
OKAY IT OUT VERY QUICKLY AND
YOU'LL SEE VERY FEW SEQUEL TYPE
LITIGATION CASES -- ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IF THERE'S AN
EXPEDITED REVIEW.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY OUT
CENTER OFFICE TO THE BILL AND WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY
FOUR BY SENATOR CABALLERO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER IMRO.
BATES. ZERO HI SEVERAL AYE
DORADO MCGUIRE.
MORLOCK.
WARLOCK I ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE AMBERG.
NUMBER FIVE CASKEY.
CASSIE NOW.
OKAY I BETTER SIX BOTH SIDES OF
THE BILL WILL BE ALFA WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN.
WE'LL NOW GO TO ITEM SEVEN SP
FORTY EIGHT ALL PRESENT AT ALL
AND THE GAVEL TO CENTER BATES
[inaudible]
AND SPECIAL.
THANK YOU FOR PATIENTS.
PLEASE RECEIVED SENATE UNDER
BATES -- COLLEAGUES -- I WILL
SENATE BILL FORTY EIGHT WILL
CREATE A STREAMLINED APPROVAL
PROCESS -- FOR LOW BARRIER --
LOW BARRIER -- HOMELESS.
SHELTERS THAT CONNECT PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. TO
SERVICES IN PERMANENT HOUSING
SOLUTIONS.
AS REPORTED CREATES A NEW
STREAMLINED PROGRAM FOR WHAT WE
CALL INTERIM SHELTER
DEVELOPMENTS.
THE GOAL OF WHICH IS TO EXPEDITE
THE APPROVAL OF HIGH QUALITY LOW
BARRIER SHELTERS I CONNECT
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
TO SERVICES AND SUPPORT OF
HOUSING -- ONLY SHELTERS THAT
MEET ALL APPLICABLE HEALTH
SAFETY AND BUILDING CODES --
THAT ALLOW FOR THE PRESENCE OF
PARTNERS PATHS AND STORAGE OF
POSSESSIONS.
THAT PROVIDE PRIVACY AND OUR LOW
BARRIER -- AND OFFER SERVICES TO
CONNECT PEOPLE TO PERMANENT
HOUSING ONLY THESE TYPES OF
PROJECTS WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS STREAMLINING.
THE BILL ALSO MAKES CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO HOUSING EXISTING
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW.
WITH REGARD TO ZONING -- IN
TERMS OF WHERE MERGING SEE
SHELTERS ARE ALLOWED AS A
PERMITTED USE -- WITHOUT A
CONDITIONAL USE DISCRETIONARY
PERMANENT.
AS YOU KNOW COLLEAGUES NEARLY
70% OF CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS
POPULATION -- IS ON THE STREETS
EVERY NIGHT IS I'M SHELTERED --
THE STAGGERING NUMBER IS A MORAL
FAILURE -- BUT WE KNOW WHAT WE
CAN DO WE NEED TO DO TO HELP
PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS AND THE
TRANSITION -- AND THE HOUSING --
WE ALSO KNOW THAT OTHER SHELTERS
OTHER DO EXIST FOR SMALL THEY'RE
BIG SWATHS OF THE STATE WITH NO
SHELTER ACCESS EITHER NODE BEDS
AT ALL.
WAR ON VERY LIMITED ONLY IN THE
WINTER -- AND THERE ARE ALSO
SHELTERS WITH VERY HIGH BARRIERS
SO THAT -- THERE ARE HOMELESS
PEOPLE WHO SIMPLY WILL NOT
ACCESS THEM SO THE GOAL THIS
BILL IS FIRST AND FOREMOST TO
INCENTIVIZE -- THESE LOWER
BARRIERS SHELTERS -- BUT THE
BILL ALSO ADDRESSES THE EXISTING
STREAMLINING PROVISION -- RIGHT
NOW CITIES ARE REQUIRED IN THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT TO DESIGNATE AN
AREA FOR EMERGENCY SHELTER
ACCESS -- UNFORTUNATE ARE NO
REAL CONSTRAINTS AROUND WHERE
THEY CAN IDENTIFY THOSE PARCELS
AND AND THERE ARE CITIES THAT
ARE IDENTIFYING THEM.
IN INDUSTRIAL AREAS THAT ARE
REALLY.
KNOW WHERE A BETTER NUMBER CLOSE
TO SERVICES AND REALLY.
KNOW WHERE THEY YOU WHATEVER
POINT -- SHELTER US OF THE BILL --
WILL -- REQUIRE -- THAT -- THAT
THE EMERGENCY SHELTER AREA AND
THE HOUSING ELEMENT BE
DESIGNATED EITHER IN A
RESIDENTIAL OR MIXED USE AREA
WORK IT IS IN OUR INDUSTRIAL
AREA.
THAT IT MEETS CERTAIN CRITERIA
SO THAT IT'S CLOSE ENOUGH TO
SERVICES THAT IT WILL ACTUALLY --
WORK -- SO COLLEAGUES THIS BILL
WILL HELP EXPAND ACCESS TO
EMERGENCY SHELTER AND THE LOW
BARRIER -- SHELTER OF COURSE
WITH THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF
GETTING PEOPLE ON THE HOUSING --
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF THE BILL ARE
ON YOUR LAWLER FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
AND SHERRIN REPORTER FROM THE
CORPORATION SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
GOOD EVENING ON YELLOW.
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AS A SENATOR SAID -- FOR
ABOUT A DECADE STATE LAW HAS
REQUIRED ALL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-TO HAVE AT LEAST A ZONE WHERE
EMERGENCY SHELTER CAN LOCATE BY
RIGHT -- THERE HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGES OVER THE LAST DECADE
IN IMPLEMENTING THAT LAW AND
IT'S ALSO REALLY NOT PROVIDING
THE SITES THAT WE NEED AT THE
SCALE THAT WE NEED THEM TO
PRODUCE THE SHELTER BEDS THAT WE
NEED THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
WHILE THE SOLUTION TO
HOMELESSNESS ULTIMATELY IS AN
ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF HOUSING
AFFORDABLE TO VERY LOW AN
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
IN EVERY COMMUNITY IN THE STATE --
SHELTERS ARE CRUCIAL IN TERMS
STEP TO ENSURING THAT PEOPLE ARE
NOT LIVING ON THE STREETS IN
CARS AND IN OTHER PLACES UNFIT
FOR HUMAN HABITATION -- WALL
THEY RECEIVE NEEDED SERVICES AND
ASSISTANCE IN SECURING PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR PERMANENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- AS HE
FORTY EIGHT EXPANDS
OPPORTUNITIES TO CREATE HIGH
QUALITY LOW BARRIER SHELTERS AND
COMMUNITIES WHERE MORE SHELTER
BEDS ARE CURRENTLY DESPERATELY
NEEDED WE FRANKLY NEED TO GIVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MORE TOOLS TO
GET BEYOND REACTIONARY
OPPOSITION TO PROVIDING SHELTER
TERM MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND THIS BILL WOULD DO
THAT.
YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING SHARON REPORT WITH
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING -- AGAIN LIKE MS LAWLER
SAID PERMANENT HOUSING IS THE
SOLUTION HOMELESSNESS BUT
SHELTERS PROVIDE A KEY ROLE IN
ALLOWING ACCESS POINTS FOR
GETTING PEOPLE INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING.
AN SB FORTY EIGHT CREATES
INCENTIVES FOR THE SHELTERS TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF RESIDENTS
INCLUDING REQUIREMENTS FOR
SHELTERS TO OFFER THESE SERVICES
TO CONNECT PEOPLE TO PERMANENT
HOUSING. TO PROVIDE PRIVATE AND
HABITABLE PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO
SLEEP TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO
ENTRY AND TO COMPLY WITH HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODES WHICH WE ALL
THINK ARE CRITICAL TO MAKING
SHELTERS AS AVAILABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE AS POSSIBLE.
SB FORTY EIGHT WITH EXPAND
ACCESS TO SAFETY AMONG THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS AND FOR
THIS REASON WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND OF WE SUPPORT THE
BILLS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANY
GEORGE OF THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL BUT IF AMENDED --
OUR MAIN CONCERN IS THAT WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE KNOW WHEN WE'VE MET
THE REQUIREMENT THAT WE HAVE
ACCESSTO SERVICES. FOR INSTANCE
IN WOODLAND TO JUST RECENTLY
THEY ACTUALLY GREW OUT OF THE
RESIDENTIAL AREA SHELTER AND END
UP GETTING INTO A AN INDUSTRIAL
AREA BECAUSE IT HAD EIGHT ACRES
THAT THEY COULDN'T AFFORD IN
TOWN -- THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
THOSE FACILITIES AND TO THOSE
SERVICES BUT NOT ALL OF THEM ARE
ON SITES WE JUST WHAT REALLY
CLEAR WHEN WE'VE MET IT WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO WE TOTALLY AGREE WITH
THE BILL BUT THAT'S ESSENTIALLY
WHERE WE ARE IN IT THANKS.
CHRIS MARTIN WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA -- IN SUPPORT IN AND
REALLY APPRECIATE THE SENATOR
LOOKING AT LOW BARRIER HOUSING
FOR SHELTERS.
TONY BE WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT SO SHE XIN HERE
SUPPORT AS WELL.
JAYCO KENYA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL ON COMMUNITY PAY FOR
HEALTH AGENCIES WE REPRESENT A
LOT OF THE CONSTITUENTS THAT YOU --
REPRESENT -- Là WHERE HOUSING
IS A MAJOR ARM.
THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IS A MAJOR IMPEDIMENT TO
HOMELESS PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING
WITH PAPER HEALTH ISSUES --
INSURING MORE TEMPORARY SHELTER
WILL GET THEM ACCESS TO THE
SERVICES THEY NEED THANK YOU.
IN THIS FRIDAY WITH CALIFORNIA
ME IN SUPPORT.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY OPPOSITION.
WELL.
BILLS AND MOVED ON COMMITTEE
COMMENTS.
WITH.
SENATOR MORE LOS MOVE THE BILL.
WE WE HAVE WE HAVE WE HAVE A
MOTION.
DEAR SENATOR MORE LOG THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR -- I JUST TO CLARIFY.
ARE YOU SAYING THAT AN SP TWO
ZONE IS JUST BECOME YOU YOU
COULD JUST.
PUT A SHELTER.
ANYWHERE IN THE CITY SO THERE
ARE TWO THINGS THERE THERE'S THE
SP TWO ZONE WHERE RIGHT NOW LIKE
BUT ANYWHERE SO COULD BE OUT WAY
FOR INDUSTRIAL SITE -- NOW ARE
REQUIRED FOR THAT EMERGENCY
SHELTER THAT THE CITY --
DESIGNATE THE SIDE IF THEY'RE IN
A RESIDENTIAL OR MIXED USE AREA
WORTH IT'S AN INDUSTRIAL AREA
THAT THEY CAN MEET CERTAIN
CRITERIA BUT IT'S CLOSE ENOUGH
TO SERVICES AND IT'S NOT OUT IN
THE MIDDLE OF NO WHERE -- AND
THEN IT CREATES A NEW
STREAMLINING PROGRAM FOR IF
SOMEONE PROPOSES ARE OF THE
MONITORS LOW BARRIER -- SHELTERS
WHERE PEOPLE CAN BRING.
GO IN WITH THEIR WITH THEIR
PARTNER AND WHAT THEY'RE NOT
HAVE TO LEAVE THE DOG ON THE
STREET WHICH IS A BARRIER FOR
PEOPLE AND SO FORTH -- BUT THERE
WILL BE A BROADER -- GEOGRAPHY --
IN TERMS OF WHERE -- THEY COULD
SITE THAT I'M SUBJECT TO THERE'S
STILL A LOCAL STANDARDS -- THAT
WOULD HAVE TO BE COMPLIED WITH.
BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE AN SP
TWO SO NOW.
THE BILL TO REMIND THE BILL
STILL.
IN EARLY STAGES AND WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK -- WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON A IT STARTED OUT
OF THE BILLION MY REMEMBER
STARTED AS AN INTENT ALL RIGHT
TO SHELTER BILL OR HAD A GRAND --
VERSIONS AND EVEN THOUGH SYSTEM
VERY IMPACTFUL WE'VE REALLY BEEN
SAYS WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
TO CONTINUALLY REFINE IT -- AND
THERE'S MORE REFINEMENT THAT
WILL HAPPEN WITH THE BILL POUND
I'M I'M I'M TRYING.
TO CAN I CONNECT THE DOTS
SENATOR BATES AND I YOU KNOW WE
WATCH TO CITIES.
SELECT YOUR SB TWO ZONES AND
THEN WE OPENED ESCROW.
ONE BUILDING SOMETHING OKAY
FINDS A GOOD GOOD LOCATION IN
FRONT OF BUILDING FOR SALE.
ONLY THEN HAVE THE CITY JUST
TURN AROUND IT'S EIGHTY SECOND
WE LIKE WE DIDN'T MEAN THIS.
YOU KNOW THIS AND EVERYTHING
WENT KIND OF YOU KNOW PITCH
FORKS AND AND AND AND TORCHES
AND THOSE ON A ROUTE TO SAVE
ROUTE TO SCHOOL.
BLITZER THROUGH THEY SAID
ALTHOUGH OUR ARMORY WAS RIGHT
NEXT DOOR TO A SCHOOL SO IN THE
SAME CITY SO WITH SO.
I'M I'M TRYING.
TO SEE HOW YOU ACCOMPLISH WHAT
YOU WANT TO ACCOMPLISH WITHOUT.
TO HELP ME OUT HOW ARE YOU HOW
ARE WE HOW WE GONNA MAKE THIS
WORK IN A CITY.
NO I'M.
YEAH I CAN YOU KNOW WHAT'S
REALLY FUNNY I I SENATOR WIENER
AYE YOU KNOW I SIT ON THE BOARD
SUPERVISOR FOR EIGHT YEARS.
BUT ORANGE COUNTY'S PRETTY MUCH
FULLY DEVELOPED SO WOULD WE
DIDN'T DO VERY MUCH LAND
PLANNING AT ALL.
WHEN I SERVED ON THE BOARD SO
I'M I'M NOT ABLE TO A LAND
PLANNING?
PRO SO HELP ME OUT.
YEAH SO ON THIS ISSUE IT IS THE
SAME.
EVERYWHERE AND AND WHETHER
YOU'RE AN ORANGE COUNTY OR
WHETHER YOU'RE IN SAN FRANCISCO --
AND BELIEVE ME THAT WE HAVE --
NEIGHBORS WHO WILL FIGHT.
ARE HOMELESS.
SERVICES IN SHELTERS AND EVEN
SOME OF THE MOST.
LEFTY PARTS OF SAN FRANCISCO
JUST AS HARD AS PEOPLE IN ORANGE
COUNTY -- WELL.
ON THE SO IT'S A CHALLENGE
EVERYWHERE -- AT THE SAME TIME
WE HAVE OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE ON OUR STREETS AND SO.
IT'S ABOUT -- MAKING IT EASIER
AND FASTER -- WITH LESS.
POLITICS.
HI TOAST SORRY OF BEES.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT PROGRAMS
THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
I DO MORE RESEARCH THAN THANK
YOU YOU WERE HAPPY TO TALK TO
MORE ABOUT.
TO ANY OTHER COMMENTS WE HAVE A
MOTION.
US SECRETARY YOU WANT TO CALL
THE ROLL.
DID YOU CALL WITHOUT YOUR
CLOTHES I'M SORRY SPUR FAST FOR
A MINUTE I'M TRYING TO SPEED
TRACK THIS.
THE SENATE BILL FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE AND GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER IMRO.
BATES NOW LOADING [inaudible]
EVER.
CAN VERIFYDORADO.
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORE LUCK.
ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER FIVE HUSKY.
CASKEY I IT'S GOT.
THANK YOU THAT PASSES LINDA.
THE PHONE CALL.
IN THE PAST.
WE'RE GONNA -- WE'RE GONNA OPEN
THE ROLL OUT JUST TO BE ABLE TO
GET EVERYONE OUT OF HERE AND
AWAY FOR CENTERS MCGUIRE AND ARE
ALSO AND WILL RE OPEN UP FOR
THEM -- SO -- WILL WILL RESTART
RE OPENING THE ROLE.
ON THE CONFIRM.
ON THE CONSENT COUNTY WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS FOUR IN.
TEN A BURKE.
NUMBER I OKAY THAT'S ELEVEN ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS APPROVED.
SENATE BILL FIVE A SENATOR BOTH
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER CABALLERO.
COVER I MORE LUCK.
NUMBER.
NUMBER FIVE CASKEY.
OKAY CI.
IT'S A TWO MISSING WHILE.
HE'S STILL HIS VISIT OKAY -- SO
OF HONESTY FIVE VOTERS NINETY
ONE THE BILL ITSELF.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
WITH CASKEY MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE [inaudible]
SENATOR MORAL [inaudible]
DORADO MCGUIRE.
OKAY WILL OUT OF WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN ON THAT.
THIS ISN'T A BILL EIGHTEEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY.
TOMORROW [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
TORONTO.
MCGUIRE.
MORLOCK.
IT WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
THIS IS SENATE BILL FORTY EIGHT
A SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND WE REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SENATOR MOREAU.
BATES DORADO MCGUIRE.
MORLOCK WOULD YOU THROW OPEN.
THIS IS AN ABLE TO THIRTY FIVE A
SENATOR DODD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR BATES.
BATES A CAMERA.
CAMERA I MORE LOCK ROUGH.
ROUGH HI NUMBER.
NUMBER I SOON BARBARA ROOM.
YES RESEARCHERS NOW WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN AND SEVEN TEN ZERO THAT
IS A TEN ZERO AND SO THE BILL IS
OUT.
THIS IS UNABLE TO THE TWO BY
SENATOR BILL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND RE REFER THE COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
SENATOR CABRERO.
COVER HI ROUGH.
ROUGH ICE AMBERG.
NUMBER I OKAY IT'S ELEVEN ZERO
THE BILLS OUT.
THIS IS SENATE BILL FIVE SEVENTY
THREE BY SENATOR CHIANG THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE REFER
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CENTER TOMORROW.
COVER.
COVER AYE ROTH ROTH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER I TWO ZERO NUMBER ROLES
ON HUNDRED OUT.
EMERALD SOMETHING BACK RIGHT
[inaudible]
IT'S GOING.
AVAIL TO THEM OKAY SO IT'S NINE
ONE THE BILL'S I'LL.
THIS IS SENATE BILL SIX NINETY
FIVE A SENATOR PORTANTINO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
WE WERE FOR THE COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES.
SEVERAL [inaudible]
COVER.
THE CAMERA I DORADO [inaudible]
MOORLACH.
MOORLACH AYE ROTH.
HELLO.
EVERYTHING.
OKAY.
MY APOLOGIES.
A ROUGH.
ROUGH AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
SKINNER I THROW SO WE'LL KEEP
ABOUT THE ROLE OPEN ON THAT.
SEVEN ONE YEAH. ONE SEVEN TWO
JOHN COMING BACK OR THE FRONT.
THIS.
IS JOHN COMING BACK OR SICK ON I
THINK.
THIS IS AN APPLE SEVEN FORTY
FOUR BY SENATOR CAFIERO MOTIONS
TO PASS AND RE REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SEVERAL [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
DORADO.
BROTHER I MCGUIRE.
IT WILL TO THROW OPEN
[inaudible]
OKAY -- SENATE MCGUIRE WILL BE
HERE MOMENTARILY SO THEN WILL
REOPEN EVERYTHING FOR SENATOR
ALSO OWNS AND THE WATER WAS JUST.
THIS HOTEL FOR MOMENTS
[inaudible]
NUMBER
WILL -- OPEN THE ROLE ON
THEM -- BOB PENDING ITEMS.
THIS IS SENATE BILL THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR WHAT CASKEY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER
THE COMMITTEE AND GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE.
MORRELL.
DORADO.
DRUG SO HI MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI.
THE VOTE OF TEN ZERO THE BILLS
OUT.
THIS ISN'T A BILL EIGHTEEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND WE REFER THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY MORROW.
BATES DORADO.
BROWSER I AM A CHOIR
[inaudible]
MCGUIRE AYE.
OKAY THE VOTE IS A TWO ZERO THE
BILL ITSELF.
THIS IS SENATE BILL FORTY EIGHT
A SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND WE REFER THE
COMMITTEE AND GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE.
CENTER TOMORROW BATES DORADO HI
DORADO I AM A CHOIR.
MCGUIRE AYE.
OKAY THE VOTERS EIGHT TO ZERO
THE BILLS OUT.
THE SENATE BILL SIX NINETY FIVE
A SENATOR PORTANTINO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND WE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES.
SENATOR MORROW.
DORADO.
DORADO AYE [inaudible] EIGHT ONE
OKAY THE ROAD FIFTY ONE THE BILL
ZEALOTS -- FOR ONE ONE MORE.
THIS IS AN APPLE SEVEN FORTY
FOUR BY SENATOR CABALLERO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER THE
COMMITTEE AND GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE.
SENATOR MOREAU.
BATES MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
THE FIFTY TO ONE THE VOTERS A
TWO ONE THE BILL'S OUTS -- OR
ANY OTHER BILLS ON CALL.
OKAY THANK YOU EVERYONE THAT
INCLUDES -- TODAY'S HEARING AND
WE ARE ADJOURNED